linux is a popular operating system for
server administration because it's
secure stable and flexible in this
course sean powers from cbt nuggets will
detail every part of configuring
monitoring and supporting a server setup
that runs the linux operating system
this course will teach you everything
you need to know to configure linux
servers including the boot process
kernel modules network connection
parameters localization groups and more
let's get started
[Music]
bios and uefi are two tools that
basically do the same sort of thing but
they can be a little bit confusing when
it comes to how do you know which one to
use on a computer and and do i need to
support one or the other or both or the
nice thing is you usually either have
bios or uefi now bios is an older
program it just stands for basic input
output system whereas uefi is the new
kit on the block and this stands for
unified extensible firmware interface
which sounds confusing but really it's
just the the way that we can interact
between the hardware and the operating
system now let's say that we have two
different vehicles now these are two
obviously very very different vehicles
one of them is a sports car and one of
them is an awesome yellow volkswagen
beetle i actually have a volkswagen
beetle that's yellow like this and it's
awesome
but nonetheless you could be a sports
car person either way even though
they're ridiculously different vehicles
they both have some common interfaces
right they're both going to have brake
pedals they're both going to have
steering wheels
they're both going to have windshields
and those interfaces are fairly common
across all vehicles now the brakes in
the underlying system are going to be
different this sports car probably has
really nice disc brakes whereas these
old volkswagens have drum brakes now
drum brakes aren't as good but the
interface itself is very very similar
you push the brake pedal and you stop
and that's kind of what bios and uefi
are they're interfaces between the
hardware and the operating system itself
now they do work a little bit
differently so here we have our hard
drive on our system now using bios like
the old method of booting a computer you
would have like the very first sector on
the hard drive would be the boot sector
and that's where the mbr the master boot
record would live and then that would
tell the computer where the partitions
are and you point it to where to boot
now there's a lot of limitations with
bios you could only have
four partitions using the bios and mbr
combination there are some hacks to get
around that you know they would take a
partition and do extended partitions
inside that but that's a whole nother
nugget still there was this limitation
also a limitation of size with the drive
how much this boot sector or this master
boot record can actually reference it
can be a small amount like two terabytes
instead of exabytes of data and so uefi
is a replacement for the bios technology
and rather than just have the single
boot sector what it does is there's an
entire partition
on the system and that partition is
where all of the boot code is for
whatever operating systems might be on
the computer so rather than just the
boot sector pointing to
you know the rest of the hard drive this
is an actual
specialized partition
on the computer and that's where the
uefi code is stored also it uses a
different partition scheme so you can
have tons and tons of partitions and it
can address a much larger hard drive
there's also other things like secure
boot that uefi supports that bios
doesn't basically just know that uefi is
the replacement for bios it replaces the
functionality of connecting the hardware
to the software of the operating system
now the good news is if you have a
computer that's older or even some new
ones so come with bios you can still get
around a lot of the limitations because
there are hacks that will let you use
really big hard drives or hacks that
will allow you to do some of the things
that you can't normally do out of the
box but most computers now are coming
with uefi and from a from an installer
point of view there's very little you
have to do because the operating system
is going to say okay i was booted using
uefi so i'm going to create a partition
a uefi partition and i'm going to put
all the boot code in there so from your
standpoint from the end user or the
installer standpoint there's very little
difference but under the hood a lot of
new cool stuff is going on and that's
why uefi is kind of the way of the
future
remember when you were a kid and in the
doctor's waiting room there were these
magazines and one of the games inside
the magazines was that you had to find
the difference in one of a bunch of
similar looking
figures like for example here are what
do i have nine different jokers and one
of them is a little different now it's
not terribly difficult to see which one
is different here if you watched while
they appeared this one has a tiny little
spot right there on his shirt that's
different than all the others so we've
been able to identify it but you can see
they're very very very very similar well
the same thing is true about grub
and grub 2 which of course is the next
iteration of grub now grub stands for
grand unified boot loader but really
it's just the way that the computer
transitions from bios or uefi booting up
conditions into the actual operating
system itself it's what tells the
computer okay where's my partitions and
stuff like that it's very easy to
confuse which is which on your system
which seems silly but it can be very
very embarrassing when you sit down at a
system you're like okay so is this
running grub or grub 2 because they do
the same thing right they both boot the
computer but they do have some minor
nuanced differences grub of course is
older you probably guess that by it not
having a 2 at the end of its name but
grub is often called grub legacy because
it is older but it's still on a few
operating systems not many but a few i
think slackware still uses grub legacy
now the biggest and easiest way to
figure out if you're dealing with grub
or grub 2 on your system is to look
inside the boot grub folder and if you
see
menu.lst
or grub.com that means you're running
grub legacy because grub 2 does not have
those configuration files grub 2 has
this configuration file grub.cfg
now it's easy to confuse
cfg.com so i always just look for
menu.lst if that exists you're on grub
legacy now the thing about grub is it's
kind of difficult to modify it was uh
it's very easy for automated systems
like when you install a new kernel to
figure out how to put how to you know
update the menu and update the boot code
but it's really difficult for the end
user to modify that stuff and the boot
menu usually when it's booting up it
says you know press something in 10
seconds in order to
change the way it boots so this usually
just appears for you and you can see it
now grub 2
is a lot more customizable in fact if
you go into the etc default grub file
this is a configuration file that's easy
to read and it's going to allow you to
change the way that it looks when it
boots up now grub2 also has a ton of
other cool features it can boot from an
iso file from a usb disk it can name or
it can identify hard drives based on
their uuid or their device like dev sda
so it's a lot more advanced than grub
one but one of the you know the
advancements that's also a frustration
is that boot menu that i talked about
that comes up with grub it's hidden with
grub 2. so it just goes right to the
login screen you never see anything from
grub 2. and if you don't know this
little trick it can be a real bugger to
get into that menu if you want to change
something during boot so be sure to just
hold down the shift key when the
computer is booting up and then boom all
of a sudden you're going to get into the
grub 2 interactive menu that you can
change boot code things on the fly it's
really really cool i'll show you what i
mean but it's not difficult once you
know if you have grub or grub 2 grub 2
which allows you to do a lot more
configuration stuff now i'm here on an
ubuntu system this has grub 2 and if we
were to look at let's just look at it
etc default
grub we're going to see this is just a
configuration file we can change these
things once you make a change you do
have to do sudo
update grub you do that it's going to
update the boot code inside the boot
folder and if we look in that boot
folder so go into boot
grub type ls i look at that grub dot cfg
there's no menu.lst so we know that this
is grub 2. so that's how you manage
things in grub 2. i'll show you really
quickly before we end this is a computer
that's turned off if i start this
computer and hold down the shift key as
long as i hold down the shift key boom
we get this menu but if i don't hold
that we don't see any menu
for us to interact with grub at all now
figuring out if you have grub or grub 2
can be a little bit challenging if you
don't know that simple trick to look for
menu.lst but they both do the same thing
they tell the computer how to boot up
and how to mount its different
partitions it's just that grub 2 is
definitely an advancement it's more
configurable it does more things and
it's easier for the end user to manage i
hope this has been informative for you
and i'd like to thank you for viewing
linux is so flexible it can boot from an
incredible number of
methods or sources now there are several
different things we need to understand
about the boot processes like is it
hardware based or is it software based
and i'll tell you what i mean about that
in a minute but there are just this
multitude of ways that a linux system
can boot it can boot over pxe or pixie
boot if you haven't seen that it's just
the coolest thing ever it's when it
boots up completely over the network we
can boot from usb from cd ipixi is a
more advanced version of pixi i'll talk
about that too and then iso images just
like the dot iso file you can actually
make a grub 2 entry that will boot
directly from the iso even though you
don't have it burned to a disk or to a
usb drive it can live on your system and
you can have a grub menu item that boots
directly to that iso image it's really
flexible what it can do but that
hardware software thing i wanted to talk
about because where the boot process is
taking place is really important some of
it is linux specific some of it is not
so first of all let's talk about the
hardware things now when i say hardware
i mean the bios or the uefi the part
that takes place before linux is ever
introduced and pxe is one of those
things
pxc which stands for pre-boot execution
environment is the way that the hardware
says okay i don't see a hard drive or
i'm not set up to use a hard drive so
i'm going to query the network and it
just queries a dhcp server and the dhcp
server responds with not only an ip
address which is what dhcp servers
normally do but also a boot file and a
tftp location a tftp server is just a
place you can store files on a network
and then basically the computer then
downloads that
image that boot image from the tftp
server and that's where linux comes into
play that kernel or that boot file is
the linux kernel so it downloads it off
the internet or off the internet um off
of your local network and then it puts
it in memory and boots itself from there
so pxe starts as just a hardware thing
and then turns into a software there's
also ipxc which is very similar but
instead of using tftp to download that
thing it allows you to use http which is
faster and usually more reliable than
the old-fashioned tftp but it's very
similar in concept ipxc if your computer
supports it then usb this is also right
on the hardware now the hardware
determines exactly how to boot from the
usb but on the usb itself is where the
linux code is right so the hardware
knows that it can boot from usb same
thing with cd and to be quite honest
same thing with a hard drive right the
hard drive is booted too because the
computer itself understands how to do
that but when under linux comes into
play we'll say the software side of
things
this is once it loads into linux linux
does some things on its own like the iso
booting with grub 2 that's after linux
starts right or after grub starts it
says okay i'm in grub now what are we
going to do we're going to either mount
a partition or we're going to look at
this iso file and actually use that as
our operating system just like it was
burned to a cd so some of this stuff is
software this is where you like select a
kernel this is where you can have mem
test so a lot of the stuff is done in
software but most things actually all
things have to start in the hardware
otherwise you're never going to you know
get to the point where the software
takes control but it's important to know
that pxe
ipxc these are not linux specific boot
methods these are boot methods the
computer supports that linux also
supports in that they can provide the
boot file so i don't want you to confuse
pxe network booting with something
specific to linux same with usb and cd
we can boot windows from usb or cds
and it works you know because the
hardware supports it if i'm honest
probably the most fun way to boot a
computer is using pxe only because
there's no media right it just boots
directly off the network and for some
reason that's just really awesome to to
be a part of it's really awesome to see
but there are multiple ways that you can
boot linux and it's important to know
that they're all there it's okay if you
don't know exactly how to you know boot
from an iso file using grub 2. anybody's
going to have to google the specifics of
that in order to make it work but
knowing all these different processes
exist for booting a computer that's
vital because that will help you learn
and help you troubleshoot when you run
into a booting issue when it comes to
actually booting the linux kernel there
are a lot of problems that need to be
solved and it's sometimes sort of like a
chicken and an egg scenario you have to
do one thing but you can't do that thing
until the other thing is done and what
do you do first and how do you do it
it can be really confusing but basically
we want to get the full kernel with all
of its modules running so the boot
process is very complicated and it might
seem over complicated but the issue is
to try to get the kernel running and
then allow it to access the modules that
are stored on the hard drive on your
system and it ends up being like i said
fairly complicated and if i'm honest
i've been a
system administrator for over 20 years
i've passed lots of certification tests
and i have never
fully understood every step of the
process of booting the kernel so you're
gonna be like the king of the next nerdy
party that you go to uh because you're
gonna go to you're gonna know all the
trivial pursuit answers when it comes to
linux kernel so let's look and see what
the boot process actually is and then
i'll show you on a system where those
files live so i have sort of a little
flow chart here now a lot of these steps
we probably are already familiar with
first the computer either has bios or
uefi and that's the hardware on the
computer which looks for something that
grub or grub too it's one or the other
here will provide and then that boot
code of you know that grub uses points
us to the kernel now this is the stuff
where it starts to get a little not
confusing so much but complicated it's
almost like this fine dance that has to
be done now norm what the process is
normally is we have the actual linux
kernel itself which is a file one file
and it's called vm linux or you'll
probably currently see it called vm
linus with the z and the only difference
here these are the same file
the pr the only difference is that this
is compressed right it's the z means
that it's compressed so it's just a
space-saving method uh so usually we use
vm linus just to save some room on the
system and then this is the the kernel
itself with no modules right so there's
no modules this is just the base kernel
and then
once the kernel boots up it will mount
all the file systems and then it will
have access to all of the modules that
it needs to insert to make things work
like you know your usb
mouse and your keyboard and your monitor
and your video card all those things are
modules that are loaded
into the kernel they're not part of the
the static kernel right i mean we could
build this huge kernel that includes
everything but that's just a waste of
resources and so we have this stripped
down kernel that has just enough stuff
to make sure that we can mount the file
system so that it can have access to all
of its modules and then become the full
running kernel on our system there's a
few problems what if this full kernel
and all the modules yeah so basically
what if all the modules here are on a
file system
that this stripped down kernel doesn't
know
how to mount right it's like well i
don't know how to get onto a raid device
or i don't have any idea how to mount
this fancy new ssd drive that you put
into the pcie slot or something well
that's where init rd or init ram disk
comes into play this is just enough
information
like module information and
driver information to be able to have
the linux kernel access the file system
so that it can get to its modules so
rather than make you know a custom
bigger kernel for every specific system
what we've done is we have a generic
strip down kernel and then this init rd
has the stuff we need in order to load
the modules
by mounting the hard drive or you know
whatever we need maybe this is stored in
a network drive so we have to have the
nfs stuff in order to mount a remote
disk on the on the computer so it can
access its module so this is just like
the the temporary staging area for
kernel stuff that we need and this is
kind of inserted right into this running
stripped down kernel okay now i want to
mention this because a lot of people
confuse the init ram disk with the init
ram file system and they seem similar
conceptually they are fairly similar
conceptually except that the init ram fs
is actually part of the actual kernel
itself it's part of this vm linus or vm
linux kernel and this is just like it
says it's a file system that it creates
and mounts in ram and i want to mention
this tool even though we're not going to
go into it much dracut is a tool that
has made this extremely generic using
udev and and stuff like that so that
it's very flexible but this is basically
the tiny little file system that the
linux kernel uses in order to do what it
needs to do to get to the point where it
can load the full kernel by loading
modules so init ram fs is a file system
that it loads into ram but that's part
of the kernel itself this init rd is a
ram disk that is mounted alongside of
the kernel that allows it to get to the
point so it can use the full kernel and
knit ram disc is not used after the
system is booted up this is just like a
temporary staging ground to get to the
full kernel
wow that was a lot of information but
it's really
fairly straightforward when you see why
it's doing all of those complicated
things now i want to show you really
quickly some of the files that we talked
about so here i am inside ubuntu and
this is the boot folder and we can see
we have here's the init ram sure enough
and this is i have a couple different
kernels in here there was an update but
the kernel numbers are listed here but
here's the init ram disk and here is the
actual kernel file itself there's a
couple other files the system map
actually tells the kernel where on the
file system all of its modules live and
then config this is the configuration
file when the kernel was actually
compiled so if you want to see the
options that were used there but those
are the main files that are on the
system one other thing i want to show
you is this system.map tells the kernel
to look in lib modules and then the name
of the actual running kernel and inside
there is where you'll see the actual
different modules okay and this is where
the modules that are going to be loaded
in to get that full kernel live so
that's the basic uh basics of starting a
linux kernel on your system now i know
we covered a lot of things in a lot of
terms and a lot of concepts but they
should make sense once you go through
that flowchart of what's happening and
why it's happening and in the end which
comes first the chicken or the egg well
it depends on what you need to do right
if you need an egg then the egg comes
first if the chicken can handle it on
its own no eggs are needed
now a kernel panic certainly seems like
a really good time to panic but i assure
you just because the colonel panics
doesn't mean you should soldier but
really kernel panic just means that
something went wrong with the kernel now
there's a couple common causes and
there's a couple things we can do
depending on what the root cause is now
if all of a sudden you're starting to
get kernel panics and you haven't done
any system updates recently
and it's kind of hit or miss it'll
happen it won't happen it happens when
you're doing something but not another
chances are you may have a piece of
faulty hardware and this is one of the
really common ways that you can
experience a kernel panic
if you have an overclocked cpu for
example that can sometimes cause kernel
panics a bad stick of ram is another one
that'll really do it and you know some
add-on card like video cards are
sometimes you know guilty of doing this
really anything on your system any
hardware if it fails it can cause a
kernel panic there's a couple ways to
you know try different things especially
if you have multiple sticks of ram
sometimes you can pull out a stick of
ram see if you still get a kernel panic
if you do then put that stick back in
and keep pulling them out one at a time
and see if the kernel panics
automatically go away when you remove
one certain stick hey chances are that's
what's wrong with you know that certain
stick is a bad stick of ram it can be
frustrating to track down hardware
related kernel panics but there's also
another very common kind of kernel panic
that happens and that's when you upgrade
your system so let's say that you just
ran a system update on your system and
it installed a new kernel you reboot the
computer and then boom it says something
like failure to init or kernel panic
blah blah blah blah if that happens
there is something that you can do which
is fairly easy to do and you can you
know rescue your system so to speak so
when it boots up we're just going to go
into grub and we're going to pick an
older kernel because when you update a
system
it keeps the older kernel for this exact
reason if something goes wrong you can
pick a different kernel and boot the
system and then fix it so i'll show you
what i mean
here we are on our ubuntu system and
let's say i just recently updated it and
during the update it says now i need to
restart my system so i'm going to
restart the system and everything should
go well blah blah blah blah
and then boom we get a kernel panic now
this doesn't actually give us the words
kernel panic because i did something
fairly simple to simulate what would
happen if there was some corruption in
the kernel uh but it says here you know
it's unable to find the init rd
sometimes you might see kernel panic
or unable to kill init or something like
that it says press any key to continue
but
there's nothing that's going to happen
right it's kind of locked up on me
because it aired out there's no init rd
so what we're going to do is restart the
system and when we do that we're going
to initiate the grub menu by holding
down the shift key so first of all we do
need to restart the computer i'm going
to hold down the shift key and we should
get presented with a grub menu sure
enough here's our grub menu
advanced options and we're going to see
here we have multiple kernels
this is the kernel the newest one is the
one that it tried to boot by default so
i'm just going to go back to the last
successful kernel that we had press
enter and it should boot this up and our
system should be just fine then all we
need to do is remove that kernel package
with the failed thing using our app
system reinstall it again you know do an
update so it reinstalls and then it
should install that init rd back in
place and we should be fine so it's nice
that linux keeps a few of the older
kernels kind of in line so that we can
do exactly this if something goes wrong
with one kernel or we've deleted modules
or just something doesn't load or we get
a kernel panic we can select a
previously successful kernel and then
here we are on our system working
perfectly and now we can go through and
remove that package and fix it etcetera
etcetera etcetera so if you do get the
kernel panic especially on a production
system oh it can be really scary but
know that there are ways
you know to fix it if it's just a kernel
corruption you can boot to a previous
kernel if it's a hardware issue it's a
little harder to troubleshoot but you
can also do something like boot from a
usb drive or a cd and at the very least
you'll be able to access the hard drives
so that you can get stuff off of your
computer if it is a hardware failure
that's causing the problem and then
you'll have your data to put onto a new
computer but kernel panics are no reason
to panic it's just one more thing that
we need to understand how is working so
we can fix it or troubleshoot the
problem and move on from there
we know that the linux kernel is modular
in that it doesn't load all of the
drivers that it could possibly ever need
automatically by default it has these
modules that it dynamically loads when
it discovers that it needs like a driver
for a certain sound card on boot now we
can configure it to automatically load
those modules by setting it up in a
config file which we're going to look at
now what happens though is it'll load
that module but then on behind the
scenes there's some incredible
dependency checking going on and that
dependency checking is really really
good at knowing what modules one you
know a particular module will depend on
there may not actually be a robot called
modbot in your system or even in my
system i just like to think of a cheesy
robot plugging in different modules in
my computer but nonetheless the computer
is really good at finding
dependencies in fact sometimes it's too
good and we need to blacklist certain
modules so that modbot doesn't say oh
this one will work and put it in i'm
going to show you why we would do that
and also how to do that but we're
looking at two concepts today how to
automatically load a module on boot and
how to make sure that the wrong module
isn't loaded on boot automatically by
the system detecting a dependency that
you don't want it to use
now here on our this is an ubuntu system
but all linux distributions have kernels
we're going to go into the etc folder
and there's a file here called modules
so we're going to look at that
we can see right now it's empty it says
kernel modules to load at boot time this
contains the names of the kernel modules
that should be loaded at boot time one
per line lines begin with this are
ignored so what we would do is put the
name of the module
and we would add something like e
1000 which is the name of an intel
network card module now normally the
system automatically detects the
hardware and it knows what to load but
we want to i want to give you an example
of how you can manually load a kernel
module and have it done automatically on
boot even if the system doesn't you know
detect it on boot like oh i have new
hardware i need this particular module
so this is how you would manually do it
all right now we're not actually going
to save this because i don't want to
load that module but let's say that's
loaded now if there are dependencies it
will also load those dependencies let's
say that the intel e1000 network card
also requires the pci bus to work well
then it would load the pci bus
module so it's really smart but let's
say that there are two different pci
modules there's like uh pci version one
and pci version 37 and by default it's
going to load pci version one and we
don't want that so what we would do is
blacklist it so if we go into
etc mod probe dot d
first i want to show you there's a bunch
of files in here anything with dot conf
is read in right so it doesn't matter
which one you put it in there's just
some conventions here anything we're
going to manually put in we're going to
put into blacklist.com so let's actually
edit that file
and we're going to see there are a bunch
of things that are already blacklisted
now what this does it just makes it so
that the kernel doesn't automatically
load it like here's a let's look at this
ethernet one okay so this is an e-1394
this is a firewire network device all
right it's saying here we never want to
use a firewire network device so if you
detect a firewire device i do not want
you to load the eth1394
or the ethernet module for a firewire
port so if we put blacklist here it's
not going to load it even if we put in
the firewire module itself so that it
activates that port this will make sure
that the kernel or modbot or whatever
however you like to visualize it doesn't
say oh well you're putting that in why
don't we also activate the ethernet
ability of that port we don't want that
so we put blacklist in here same thing
like that i've i've done this the most
with sound cards because there are like
150 different sound card drivers for the
ac 97 model of sound cards so a lot of
times you have to blacklist a bunch of
different models and see there's a
blacklisted sound card right here right
this is saying don't load this module
that's not what i want and this looks
like it's because of an ubuntu bug all
right so anyway this is where we tell it
what not to load even if it's compiled
in and it's part of the module we would
put it in here or any of the files in
this folder
anything that says blacklist space blank
is going to be blacklisted honestly like
i mentioned the linux kernel is usually
really good at automatically detecting
hardware and loading all of the modules
all on its own by detecting new hardware
on the system but if there are times
where you want to manually load
something but you want it to be done on
boot that's where we would put it in the
etc modules file and then blacklisting
is really important especially if you're
having problems with something like uh
it just doesn't work with this kernel
module let me blacklist that so the
kernel will pick another
module and try to activate that one
one of the things that makes the linux
kernel very special is that it's modular
so we don't have to install all of the
drivers for all the potential hardware
in a system we just installed the
drivers and the modules for the things
that exist it makes the linux kernel
very efficient because we don't have all
that bloat all those unneeded things
sitting in memory where they're never
going to be used so the kernel can be
very very efficient because of its
modular design but in order to take full
advantage of that we have to make sure
that we're putting the right modules in
the right place with all the
dependencies so we don't end up with a
kernel looking like this right with
pieces that don't belong thankfully
there are a handful of tools that we can
use to properly manipulate the kernel
modules and the first two i want to look
at are ins mod and mod probe because on
the surface they appear to do the same
thing insert modules into the running
kernel this is after we're booted it'll
insert them into the running kernel so
let's compare them to scientists right
so ins mod is a very basic program you
have to give it the full path of the
kernel module that you want to install
it doesn't do any dependency checking it
just kind of slams it into the running
kernel and if the kernel doesn't work
like it's the wrong kernel version or it
doesn't have the proper dependencies
it's just going to fail and it's not
going to give you an explanation as to
why it's just going to say well i
crammed it in there and it didn't work
boom
but mod probe on the other hand is a
more advanced program it's a more
efficient model and what it does you can
give it just the name of the kernel
module you don't have to give it the
full path you can give it the just the
name of the module itself it will look
and determine all of the dependencies
that that module needs so if one module
needs you know depends on another module
it will say oh let's load that other one
first it does a really good job now it
does need us to have a map of all the
all the needs and dependencies on a
system but there's a program to do this
we just make sure we type dep mod when
we're done installing a new kernel
module and it will recreate that map so
mod probe knows where to you know find
the dependencies now you might be
thinking okay well obviously i'm going
to use mod probe when i insert modules
and exactly that's what you should do
why does ins mod even exist well here's
the deal mod probe actually knows what
modules to install and then behind the
scenes it uses insmod to do the actual
inserting so mod probe is really kind of
a front end that's very intelligent
about what to do on the system but
that's why insmod still exists it's
still the you know the basic tool that
is used to cram modules into the running
kernel mod probe just knows which
kernels to load and in what order to
load them so modprobe is what the humans
use and ins mod is what modprobe uses if
that makes sense
it's really easy to see that in action
on our system so i'm root on ubuntu here
and let's go into lib
modules and we're going to see we have
folders for each of the kernels
installed on the system we're going to
go into the one that we're currently
running which is the latest one and
inside here we'll see this is where we
have a lot of like the map files for the
mod probe so it knows where the kernel
modules live let's go into the kernel
folder where the modules live
type ls let's go into the drivers folder
type ls again oh there's still a lot of
drivers let's go into the net folder all
right there we actually see some kernel
modules here okay so uh we're going to
play with thunderbolt
net but let's say we wanted to load this
in so we could use thunderbolt as a
network device if we wanted to use ins
mod we would say
ins mod lib
modules
generic kernel drivers net
thunderbolt net because we need the
entire path we're going to press enter
and it's going to say well i can't do
that unknown symbol in module it doesn't
work blah blah blah it has a dependency
it doesn't tell us what the dependency
is but if we were to use mod probe and
we were to say
modprobe i want you to put in
thunderbolt
net and that's all we don't have to say
a path we don't have to put ko at the
end just press enter
boom it's automatically installed how do
we know well one we didn't get an error
it just installed it but if we type ls
mod
will show us all the installed modules
and if we scroll a bit to the top we're
gonna see well look at that thunderbolt
net is installed into the running kernel
and we can see the dependency was
thunderbolt but modprobe knew to do that
and it installed it now there's another
tool for removing them and that's rm mod
now there's no super smart uh version
and dumb version of these rm mod is kind
of halfway between because if we were to
say rm mod thunderbolt it's not going to
do it it's going to say i can't do that
it's in use but at least it tells us
what it's in use by right thunderbolt
underscore net which that's a little
strange because the name of it doesn't
have an underscore right if we want to
get rid of this we could say first we
have to rm mod
thunderbolt dash net
okay no errors and now if we do the up
arrow twice now we can rm mod the
thunderbolt module
and again no problems because we we got
rid of that dependency first so now if
we do ls mod we're going to see we
scroll up
that they're not in there anymore
they're not installed into the running
kernel and that's how you can manipulate
kernel modules on your system some of
the tools are smarter than others but
it's really important to understand why
they're smarter and like insmod is
important still even though you don't
want to use it on the command line for
doing very much at all now one more
thing i just want to tell you about is
if you install a new kernel module like
you download a piece of hardware and it
has its own kernel module and you
compile it and so then you have the
kernel module that's put in this folder
you know so that it's in our current
running modules folder you have to type
dep mod in order for it to update that
database or that system map so that
modprobe knows where
it lives and what dependencies it might
have
it takes a while and now we have it
updated so now we can install that new
kernel module because it knows all the
dependencies on the system now i know in
the picture here i have these you know
wrong puzzle pieces put into the puzzle
this is actually a lot harder to
accomplish than you would think because
the tools just fail right they say oh
this won't fit or this is the wrong
kernel module some of them are smarter
about it than others but it's really
difficult to put the wrong kernel module
into a running kernel but i want to make
sure that you understand all of these
tools exist how they work what they look
for and the difference between them
first off we're talking about network
connectivity today and the first thing i
want to show you is
always check the cable now it seems
silly right of course the cable is fine
this is plugged in just fine however
ah see it wasn't plugged in tight and
whether it's a jokester in the office or
somebody who ran over a cable with a
vacuum cleaner or something sometimes it
is the cable and you can spend a ton of
time on the command line and be very
frustrated to discover that it was just
a bad cable so that's just a pro tip
check the cable make sure it's plugged
in tightly and that the little lights on
the back are flashing and doing their
thing
now we could probably do an entire
course on troubleshooting a network
connection that's not working or not
working right but today i want to go
over just a couple quick tools so you
can determine very quickly what your
issue might be on the network so i want
to look at ping and then just to check
out our address on our computer and so
the first thing i want to do is give you
this scenario we're on the computer and
we're trying to go somewhere like google
and it says unable to connect oh we
can't get online so the first thing i
would do is open up a command line
window and i would say let's try to ping
google so ping
google.com network is unreachable okay
well i know that the google dns server
has an ip address of 8.8.8.8 so that's
the next thing i would do to eliminate
whether it's dns right maybe it's dns
that's not working so i want to see if
my network itself is working so i'm
going to say ping
8.8.8.8
ah network is still unreachable okay so
there's an issue with more than dns that
means that there's a problem with my
network so let's look and see what our
network address looks like now there's a
couple tools you can try to type if
config if this doesn't work yes see it's
not on my system it's a newer system so
type ip
add for address
and it will give you the ip addresses on
your local computer for your network
devices so this is the localhost
127.0.0.1 this is just like a virtual
host that says it's it's local so we
don't want to use this one but this is
our ethernet port right eth0 and it
looks like we have an address of
10.10.10.10.
so i would say let's ping that so let's
make sure that you know our network
stack itself is working okay so this is
working i can ping my own ip address so
the ip stack itself is working i'm going
to hit control c
but for some reason i'm unable to ping
out of the network now let's assume that
my
gateway address is 10.10.10.1
ping
10.10.10.1
okay i can ping other computers on my
network so it's not well first of all we
know it's not my computer cable right
because i can ping a different computer
that's across the network but i'm still
unable to ping google so for some reason
my internet connection is down
well let's look at our ip routing
information i'm going to type ipspace
route
and press enter
all right it looks like
10.10.10.0-24 so this network is
directly accessible via eth0 okay so
that's working that's why we could ping
this up here but if you'll notice now
you might not notice but there's a line
here that's missing we don't have a
default route set so that means that the
computer while it can access other
network or other computers on our local
network it doesn't know where to send
network or where to send packets that
are destined for another network there's
no
ip routing information here now if this
is an ip routing nugget i could say okay
let's add a route manually but this is
more of a troubleshooting nugget so
here's the deal probably when we got our
dhcp address we didn't get all the
information or something fell apart the
first thing you do is either turn it off
and turn it back on right that's that's
the standard it guy response right well
in this case it might work or we could
actually go and just go to our wired
network interface here turn just the
network interface off
connect again turn it back on and now
let's well let's just look and see what
our ip route information looks like haha
look when we brought our network
interface down and back up now we have a
default route added so now let's see if
we can ping google.com
boom we're able to ping it we go over
here and we should be able to access
google as well and sure enough there's
google so we've successfully
troubleshooted the problem with our
network connection in our case it was a
route thing and really just turning off
the network interface and turning it
back on was the way to solve it but the
important part is going through the
process of determining where the problem
is we knew it wasn't a network line or
that network cable because we were able
to ping other computers
on our network so it's just a matter of
troubleshooting and going down the list
of where can i connect where can i
connect and what might cause those
issues figuring out connectivity
problems is sometimes more of an art
form than it is a science you just have
to kind of put yourself in the mindset
of a packet and say okay what
information do i need to go from point a
to point b and what is stopping me from
getting in between there tools like ping
were are able to make sure that you can
or can't connect to remote computers and
then using the ip80d you can see what
your address is we also used iprout
to look at the ip route information and
that's where we discovered we didn't
have a default route but tools like this
are what you can use to troubleshoot
your connectivity to figure out what's
going on but don't forget always check
that cable because sometimes it's just a
physical cable unplugged
dns or domain name system is the way
that your computer converts a url or a
domain name like google.com into the
numbers the ip address that the actual
computer knows how to connect to using
ip routing so google.com
isn't really helpful for anything except
for dns really what the computer needs
is that ip address so that it can get
there now there's a couple tools that we
can use to test dns on our system one of
the most common is ping right you just
ping and see if it can reach it if it
can reach it and get a response hey it's
working great but there are three other
common tools that i want to cover dig
nslookup in host and let's actually look
at those individually because they all
do about the same thing but they do it
in a slightly different way now dig is
the program that i use most often only
because it has a cool name right there's
really no reason that i use it other
than the word dig is just kind of cool
so
dig
you type dig and then you can just type
the host you want to look up like dig
google.com and it will use your default
dns server and look it up if you want to
specify a dns server for it to use
instead of the one that your system is
currently using which is a way that you
can test your particular dns server you
you put the at symbol and then the ip
address of the server that you want to
query now the other two programs can do
the same thing they just do it in a
different order you can say nslookup and
the host you want to look up and then if
you want to specify a server again you
don't have to but if you want to then
you put the server after that same thing
with the host command you put type host
the host name you want to look up and
then if you want to specify a server you
put it there if you leave it off it'll
use your default and they all like i
said do kind of the same thing so let's
look at them really quickly and then
i'll talk about how to query different
servers and do just a little bit of
troubleshooting on your system because
testing dns is kind of vital if you want
things to work on your system and they
don't seem to be so first of all let's
look at them all
how they function just by default so i'm
going to say dig
google.com
all right and this is the response i get
it's queried my default server and we
can look my default server is listed
right here
8.8.8.8 so that's pretty awesome and
this is the response it gets there's a
bunch of a records for google.com now
let me clear the screen we can do the
same thing with ns look up
google.com and this is going to give us
a little bit different format right it
says our server right here this is the
ooh i missed i highlighted the wrong
line that's our server the same server
of course it's our default server and it
gives us all the addresses these are all
the a records a little less detail but
it gives us the same information now if
somebody tells you that ns lookup is
deprecated and it's not used anymore and
it's going to be abandoned if there's a
weird case with nslookup that's true
until it wasn't they were going to get
rid of nslookup and replace it with dig
but then they came out with bind 9.3 and
for some reason decided that nslookup
was going to stick around so we have
nslookup and dig and lastly let's clear
the screen again we can just say host
google.com and this will give us
information as well it actually doesn't
tell us what default server it's using
but it gives us a lot of information
these are all of the a records for it
these are all you know the ip addresses
this one actually also tells us the mail
handlers the mx records for google.com's
domain which is kind of interesting as
well so just pick the one that you like
the best and that's what you can use and
the reason that it's important to
pick one that you like and use it often
is so that you're comfortable with it
right like i said i usually use dig and
that's weird i know because it's the
least like common way to
handle specifying a server right the
other two you do you know like nslookup
what you're looking up and then a server
with dig you say dig
at and let's say
127.0.0.1 that's localhost right so dig
at localhost
for google.com
and we got a response okay google.com
and it gave us this address which is
different but it came from our local
server now it did not get all the same
responses that we got from the 8.8.8.8
domain server you know our default
domain server if we were to say dig
at 8.8.8.8
google.com we would get a totally
different set of ip addresses so that's
why it's really important to be able to
query different servers so that you can
get different responses because on this
computer if we try to ping
google.com
it's going to try to ping that other
address and time to live exceeded it's
not ever going to work so there's
something wrong with the dns server
running on localhost now i'll show you
what the problem is
the hosts file i've actually sabotaged
here this is the etc hosts file this is
where your computer will look first for
any dns lookups and sure enough i've
kind of bamboozled it here i put the the
wrong ip address for google.com so i put
that in there
now if i restart our local server
now if i try to ping google.com
it's going to be just fine because it's
going to actually use the real address
that it looked up on the internet but
that's how you can use the different
tools to specify not only what host you
want to look up but what server you want
to query when you look it up so
whichever one of these makes the most
sense to you or whichever formatted
results you like best just pick one and
use that because you can specify a
server for each of the different
commands but knowing how to use them is
important because troubleshooting
usually means querying more than one dns
server so you can figure out what the
heck is going on
one of my favorite things about linux is
that everything is configured with text
files right it's just plain text files
it's awesome and the network is no
different it's configured with text
files now there are a few differences
when it comes to distributions if you're
on debian or if you're on centos there
are going to be some configuration files
that are different because they
configure their networks different now
there's nothing wrong with being unique
i really like the differences in the
distributions but there are some files
that are consistent regardless of what
distribution you're using we're going to
call those the common files and that's
what we're going to look like look at in
this nugget these files here are
consistent across the board they're just
kind of standard linux files so i want
to show you what they are and and where
they live and how they are configured
and what they do and that's again just
the common files there's going to be
specifics in the different distros but
we're just looking at the files that are
common to linux in general in this case
we're going to look at the files in
ubuntu and the first one i want to look
at is the etc hosts file so let's
actually become root if we want to edit
them we have to be root to do so so i'm
going to look at etc hosts there's no
extension at the end it's just etc hosts
and this is a file that acts kind of
like the first resort dns lookup so
before a system even looks things up via
dns it looks in here and there's a
couple things here like localhost and
ubuntu this is our hostname are set up
in here but we can add something we can
say what if we wanted to make sure users
were never able to go to google we could
say okay
127.0.0.1 which is our localhost is now
going to be
google.com so if somebody tries to go to
google.com they're going to try to hit
our local machine and we don't have a
web server at all so it's just going to
error out so if we save that
now on our computer if somebody tries to
go to google it's going to fail
so google.com
unable to connect even though our
network is working just fine we could go
to yahoo if we wanted
it's just a matter of that dns entry in
the etc hosts file that we kind of broke
all right so another place we can look
is in the etc
switch dot conf file now this configures
a bunch of things on our system like
group and password files but what i want
to show you specifically here is the
hosts line so this is saying where does
it look for dns lookups to you know find
what the host's ip addresses are the
first one is called files this points to
etc hosts if we have this listed first
that means before it queries a dns
server it's going to query that file
it's going to look in that file first
and then in order these are what it's
going to do from there it's going to do
you know the mdns for local lookups and
then it's going to use a dns server so
this is the order that it's going in but
the first one it looks in is the files
specifically that etc hosts file
so you can change the order of that i
don't recommend changing the order
because that's kind of what we wanted to
do
but one more thing i want to show you is
etc
resolve.conf and this is a little bit of
a confusing file because while this
tells the computer what name server to
use you'll notice up here it says do not
edit this file now back in the day you
would just put name server and then the
name server you wanted to use on your
system but now this is all handled with
the systemd resolve d service and and it
creates this file on the fly so really
we do not edit this at all network
manager handles all of the name server
entries in here um or whatever your
distribution uses for configuring the
network so we don't actually edit this
but if you want to see what server your
your particular computer is using you
can look in here and it looks like it's
it's querying
127.0.0.53 which is another ip address
to our local computer so that means that
it has some sort of local caching dns
server and it's not querying directly to
the internet
now you probably noticed that all of
these common files have to do with dns
and that's fine but it's it's
interesting that dns is kind of commonly
configured across the distributions when
it comes to actually configuring the
individual network
devices that's drastically different
from one distribution to the next but
the common files are generally dns files
and that's what we looked at in this
nugget
ubuntu is one of the most common
distributions out there but it's based
on and built upon debian so when we look
at configuring one it's very similar to
configuring the other and that's the
case with network files now i want to
show you where to find the different
network files on an ubuntu or debian
system but it's important to note that
in the last
iteration of their long-term support for
ubuntu that's when a change has been
made to how the network is configured
and what files are used and how those
files are configured now there is one
commonality between them and that's if
you use network manager to manage your
network instead of editing the
configuration files that hasn't changed
you can still use that across all the
versions that are current with ubuntu
and debian but these two ways have
changed so first i want to look at the
older version of ubuntu and when i say
older i mean one that's still valid to
use as of the date today you can still
use version 1604 let's see what version
this is etc os release so this is ubuntu
1604.1lts long-term support and this is
still as of today a valid version of
ubuntu to use in production but this is
configured by going into the etc
network directory and there's a single
file in here called interfaces so if we
look at
interfaces we're going to see this is
how you configure a network interface
with an older version of ubuntu or
debian now this is pretty much the
stanza that you configure there's
usually something in here you can look
at and base it off of but this is the
format for it we're not going to go
through the you know configuring
different things it's pretty
straightforward you don't have to indent
this is just for ease of readability but
this is how you configure a network
interface via the configuration files
now we could still use the um network
manager if we were on a gui system like
this is a gui system we could use that
but i'm actually ssh into a server that
doesn't have a gui interface and that's
where we use these
network files to configure it so let's
quit this one this is how you configure
an older version but a modern version
like 1804
or the most modern version of debian
uses a completely different network
configuration system now here we're on a
newer version of ubuntu this is actually
1804. let's check that out so this is
18.04.1 another long-term support
release of ubuntu and this one uses the
net plan system for configuring network
interface so if you go into etc net plan
and you look in here depending on what
kind of system you have you're going to
have some sort of file in here it's
either going to be like zero one network
manager dot yaml or 50 cloud init dot
yaml if it's a server the thing about
yaml files so let's look at this
yaml files do
depend on indentation in order to be
properly configured so while with the et
cetera network interfaces of the old
ubuntu system it didn't matter how
things were indented here it really
really does and so here this is where we
would configure like a static ip address
and we you know here's our ip addresses
gateway name servers the format's a
little different but it's fairly similar
conceptually to the old system like i
said except for that white space that's
really important that it's indented
properly so if you make a change to this
then you just would do sudo netplan
apply and then it will activate the new
changes that you made now i do want to
point out again this is a gui system so
it has network manager but there's also
nmtui
which is network manager text user
interface and then you can edit
interfaces using just the text boxes on
your screen if you don't have a gui
system installed so that's just one more
way that you can edit your file in
ubuntu or debian if you don't have a gui
but you want to use network manager as
opposed to just configuring those files
on your own whether you have an older
system using etc network interfaces or a
newer system using configuration files
and etc netplan configuring the network
on debian ubuntu is not difficult and
you know it's usually just a matter of
changing what's existing but if you want
to use the network manager to manage all
those interfaces either using gui or
text tools you can do that as well it's
very flexible and even with the change
in versions it's not a whole lot more
difficult to do one over the other if
we've been learning together for a while
you know that i prefer debian based
distributions and ubuntu is my jam
but i have to admit when it comes to
network configuration files centos or
red hat they really have an elegant
solution for how to configure the
network and there's no confusion between
if you're using the gui network manager
or if you're just using the
configuration files in the etc config
folder let me show you what i mean
because centos is just so awesome when
it comes to network configuration now
here we are on a centos system and it
doesn't matter which way you configure
the network interface you can go up here
and go into the network manager to
configure it or we can go directly into
etc sysconfig and i just wanted to show
you quickly inside the sysconfig folder
and sent to us is where all of these
configuration things are this is kind of
unique to centos and red hat they put
most of their configuration inside this
etc sysconfig folder but inside here
there's also another folder called
network scripts and that's where our
networking is configured if we look in
here we're going to see there is this
configuration file for our interface
ifconfig dash eth0 so let's look at that
if we edit this it's going to change the
way our network interface comes up like
if we were to change boot proto from
dhcp to
static and then we were to add a line
ipaddr
equals let's say 10.10.10.111
which is not currently the ip address if
we were to do that and save it
and then just do a quick sudo
service network restart
we would be able to restart our service
and if we were to do ifconfig
we're going to see scroll up here sure
enough that is our
ip address now now there are a couple
problems we didn't add like netmask or
anything so let's go up into
network manager
wired settings
click on the configuration thing so
we're going to edit this in network
manager if we go over to ipv4 we can see
it went from it used to be dhcp now it's
manual this is the ip address i put in
and it just guessed this netmask because
the 10 range is a class a ip address so
it guessed that i wanted to use a class
a netmask but i don't i want to use
255.255.255.0
and i didn't supply a gateway so let's
do that now 10.10.10.1
and i didn't supply any dns server so we
can do that here
8.8.8.8 and now we'll save this we'll
click apply
if we go back and edit that script sudo
vi
we're going to see that some changes
have been made now this stuff is still
the same boot proto equals static ip
address but look down here it added the
gateway address that we added it added
the dns server that we added and it
added the prefix
255.255.255.0 translates to a
24-bit netmask so put that in there just
use a different form and we can see that
it made the changes to the actual
configuration files rather than having
like two different systems and you have
to decide which one you want to use
centos allows us to make changes in one
place and whether we're using the gui
interface or just this text-based
interface it's going to allow us to make
those changes i love that it has all the
change places in a single file as
opposed to conflicting and trying to
decide which method you're going to use
if you use network manager you you're
using this configuration file if you
don't use network manager you're using
this configuration file so it's a really
elegant way to handle network interface
configuration like i said at the
beginning i'm a debian ubuntu man that's
what i usually use in my server
situations but when it comes to
configuring network interfaces man
centos has really stolen the show they
have an elegant way of doing it either
using network manager gui tools or using
the scripts inside the network scripts
folder of etc sysconfig
network bonding in linux is really just
a way to utilize computers that have
more than one network port and most
servers nowadays come with that let's
say you have a server and it has
three network ports built into it well
if you have to connect it to a switch
all each of these connected to a switch
you would ideally like to use all of
that bandwidth and you don't want to
have to supply three different ip
addresses to the computer you just want
to use all of the available bandwidth on
all three of those wires and that's
where network bonding comes into place
now there's basically two different
kinds of network bonds that we're going
to look at those that require special
switch support and those that are
generic and don't require the switch to
know at all what's going on now linux
does provide some pretty cool options
when it comes to there but the options
can be a little overwhelming i mean this
screen is like oh my goodness there's so
many choices well that's okay because
your choices are going to be fairly
limited once you learn what all of these
are now the first thing i want you to
look at when we're looking at this list
is does it require switch support and
what i mean by that is a lot of switches
especially layer three switches or smart
switches they're sometimes called will
support link aggregation and different
vendors call it different things but
it's going to be either link aggregation
or lacp or ether channel the idea is a
smart switch will have built-in code
that will allow them to work together so
if you have a smart switch chances are
that you have the ability to use link
aggregation now some of these require a
switch that supports that i'm going to
start with the confusing one here so
balance round robin basically how
balanced round robin works is you have
multiple ports and it says okay when i
transmit packet 1 i'm going to use this
port packet 2 is this port packet 3 is
this port packet 4 is this port packet 5
is this port packet 6 is this and it
just keeps going through packet by
packet and transmitting across all of
your interfaces now the reason i said it
sorta requires switch support is if
you're plugging these into a switch it
does require a switch that supports link
aggregation but what a lot of people do
is they'll use this balanced round robin
and they will connect two servers
together with crossover cables and
actually with gigabit we don't need
crossover cables anymore but they'll
connect two servers together and they'll
use balanced rod robin and in that case
you don't need a switch support or a
switch that supports it because there is
no switch involved right they're just
directly connecting the two computers
together and so like if you have a file
server that you want to connect to your
other server a lot of times this is a
way that you can increase throughput
without requiring any special switch
support so if you're connecting directly
computers you don't need to have switch
support if you're connecting to a switch
you do all right that's mode zero mode
one is an active backup and this one's
pretty easy to understand basically
however many ports you have on your
system only one is going to be active
and if that one fails then another one
is going to turn active and that's just
how it works they always have one this
is fault tolerance but this doesn't
speed anything up it just means if one
fails another one's going to come online
all right this doesn't require switch
support because well you know it
basically just only uses one port unless
the next one fails and then you switch
to that port and the switch is like okay
so now we're going to use this port
great
balance xor
does require special switch support and
this is kind of cool how balance xor
works basically you have your computer
here your linux computer and it does a
hash based on your mac address and the
client's mac address and so here's
another client over here and basically
it says okay based on this hash i'm
always going to use port 1 to connect to
this client and then over here the hash
is different so i'm always going to
connect to this computer so it's
basically a way to just spread out
which computers use which port but this
computer is always going to use this
port and this computer is always going
to use this port now this isn't used
very often because if you have switch
support which is required chances are
you're going to use 802.3 ad which is
the industry standard link aggregation
protocol right this means that your
switch knows what to do and your client
knows what to do and it's just a really
smart way of increasing through
throughput and availability fault
tolerance so if your switch supports
link aggregation you should use 802.3ad
or mode4 which is the industry standard
okay so even though balancexor is cool
it's not very often used because if you
can use it you might as well be using
the one that's even better broadcast i
kind of skipped over that broadcast is
only in very specific cases that you
would use it it just takes all of your
ports on the server and spews all of the
data out all of the ports at once it's
not used very often and it definitely
requires your switch to know what on
earth is happening now the two i do want
to focus on a little bit are these
bottom two let's say you have a dumb
switch it's not a switch that supports
link aggregation it's just one you
bought from amazon for 40 bucks it's
gigabit but it doesn't have any smarts
built in linux is smart enough to be
able to utilize the dumb switch and
increase bandwidth and throughput and
reliability and there's two different
ways it does it balance tlb which is
balance transmit load balance and the
balance of all load balancing and what
this does is let's say we have four
ports on our switch okay with tlb it's
going to transmit from whichever port is
currently the least busy so all the
transmit is going to be balanced out now
incoming is still going to always go to
one active port so that's not as good as
alb which is the same concept except it
does it for incoming and outgoing so
basically the least busy port gets the
traffic and this is really brilliant and
how it does is it constantly changes the
mac address on these ports or on these
ethernet cards so the switch is like oh
you moved again oh you moved again oh
you moved again and from the switches
standpoint it doesn't care how many
times you switch the mac address so it
generally works just fine now some
people have issued with this i've used
this in production for years and never
had a problem so balance alb if you have
a dumb switch i highly recommend you use
mode six okay if your switch supports
link aggregation i highly recommend mode
4 because that's the industry standard
and if you're just connecting two
servers together with multiple cables my
shirt mode 0 works really great to be
honest the most difficult part of linux
network bonding is figuring out which
mode to work but really it's not that
tough of a decision if your switch
supports it use 802.3ad there's really
no reason not to if your switch is a
dumb switch and doesn't support it i
highly recommend mode 6 or balance alb
if you want to take advantage of bonded
network interfaces but you don't have
the expensive hardware that will support
it
once you know the type of bond that you
want to set up for your two ethernet or
two or more ethernet connections on the
computer configuring them is pretty
straightforward although it's
drastically different depending on
whether you're on ubuntu or centos so
i'm going to show you how to do it on
both and then i'll show you also how to
test it to make sure that the bonding
modules are working so here i am on
ubuntu i've actually already configured
it so i've gone into etc
netplan and i have my file in here so
let's look at this file and what i've
done is i've set up the proper yaml
formatted with indentation and
everything to set up bonding so i'll go
over it really quickly first of all we
need to use network d as our renderer we
can't use network manager in order to
configure bonds because it just doesn't
support bonding
we do have to define the ethernet cards
themselves so ethernet's eth0 i set dhcp
4 to false because i don't want it to
actually assign an address to eth0 after
all that is done we don't need to set up
anything more for the ethernet ports
themselves then we need to set up a
bonded interface so a new section here
bonds the name of it is bond 0 dhcp 4 is
false because i'm going to assign a
static ip address and the interfaces is
a section that we tell it what
interfaces are going to be a part of
this bond in our case we only have one
which is silly i mean we're only bonding
one interface but you can do that
one or more it's just silly that we only
have one to bond that's just all this
computer has i've set up the addresses
the gateway
the name server is set up just like it
would be if we were setting it up for
each zero really the only new difference
down here is the parameters and the
parameters what i've done is mode active
backup that's just one of our modes it
happens to be
mode one but we actually say active
backup we specify by name the mode here
and then we save this file and do
netplan
apply now how you can tell if it's
working we can do ipadd
to see that you know sure enough it's up
here's our bond zero interface here's
our ethernet zero interface which is up
but doesn't have an ip address and
another way you can test is to look at
so we're just going to cap the file it's
in the virtual file system proc under
net
bonding
bond zero so if we look at this file
it's going to tell us the information
about it and say the bonding mode is
fault tolerance active backup
primary slave none but the current
active slave is eth0 it's our only one
that we have it's up and it looks like
everything is working good here's our
slave interface eth0 down here and
that's all working well as well so we
have it all set up and it's working now
with centos the setup is a little bit
different because centos is set up
differently in centos in order to
configure our ethernet ports we go into
etc sysconfig
network scripts and in here we have our
ifconfig files so i'm going to first
look at the changes we have to make to
ifconfig zero so
here we basically make it pretty simple
ethernet type
boot protocol is none uh the name the
device is eat zero on boot we want it to
come up but notice i haven't given any
ip addressing information and here are
the two things the master
is bond zero and yes this is going to be
a slave to this bond all right so those
are the changes we make here if we look
at if config bonds zero this is where we
set up bond zero we name it bond zero
bonding master is yes i did give this
one an ip address and a prefix which
means the subnet mask
on boot we want it to come up a boot
protocol is none and then here the
bonding options we tell it what we want
it to do i actually set this one up to
mode 6 mode 6 is
balance all load balancing so it does
its own version of load balancing for
incoming and outgoing traffic again i
only have the one interface on this
computer but that's okay
let's do the same thing now checking to
make sure it's working is similar we can
do ipadd you can see sure enough here's
the bond set up right here and our
ethernet is right here
and really for configuring the bonds
themselves that's all there is to it
ubuntu and centos are configured
differently but underneath they're both
doing the same thing they're using the
bonding kernel module and they're
allowing you to do some awesome things
with multiple ethernet ports on your
computer
gpt and mbr are two different ways of
taking a hard drive and sharpening it up
into pieces so that those pieces can be
recognized and mounted as different
drives and stuff on your on your system
so they're they do the same thing but
gpt is much newer and much more
feature-rich than the old-school mbr now
there's also a really cool thing called
protective mbr i want to talk about but
basically we're going to talk about the
differences between gpt and mbr here i
have two big squares and i'm going to
say that these actually they're
rectangles i'm going to say that they
represent the drives themselves and
they're going to be partitioned with two
different systems so we'll start over
here with the old one mbr which stands
for master boot record okay now
how this would work is let's say this
drive
is device sda okay so this is the device
on the linux system it recognizes this
drive now the mbr is a little tiny bit
of reserve space
at the very beginning of the disk and
this is basically like a table of
contents and it describes
how
this is chopped up okay so this is
chopped up into let's say four pieces
there's four primary partitions you can
also cut each one of the primary
partitions into four so we could have
you know mult we could have this one be
like
have four partitions there if we wanted
but basically what this means is once
the mbr defines in this little
first part of the drive right here what
is what we come up with other devices on
the system we have
dev sda1
devsda2 and it goes on down the line and
so each of these chunks is referenced on
the system as their partition name now
this is the raw device dev sda doesn't
go anywhere it's still there but the
individual partitions get their own
device and that's how we reference them
on the system so mbr has this you know
this little tiny table of contents at
the beginning and it says where things
are chopped up now gpt or
gui id partition table which i think is
interesting because there's an acronym
wrapped inside of an acronym this stands
for globally unique identifier partition
table and basically it does conceptually
the same thing right it will chop up
this drive and you'll end up with dev
sda for the raw device
and so on down the line the differences
are though gpt does have a spot at the
beginning with the table of contents but
then it also scatters them
copies of them
around the drive so that if something
were to happen with one of the copies of
the gpt it can still figure out what's
on the disk it also does some crc
correction on the files itself or on the
the file system itself so that it knows
if there's some corruption and it can
fix it it's just very very robust along
with the ability to use much bigger
drives mbr is limited to two terabytes
gpt is limited to i think petabytes i
mean there's no practical limit at this
point of how much drive space it can
talk about rather than being
limited by four partitions you can have
tons of partitions on here so you know
we could chop it up into as many as we
wanted and it just goes down the line
sda1 sda2 sda3 and one other really
interesting thing and i wanted to talk
about is the protective mbr so gpt is
used on newer systems it's specifically
part of uefi that replaces bios but
biosystems can still see gpt drives and
part of the reason they can do that is
at the very beginning
there's this section that looks exactly
like an mbr basically it's an mbr record
here that says okay there is one big
partition on this drive the entire drive
is a partition
there's no room available on this
partition and it takes up the entire
drive now why would that exist it's
basically so systems don't say oh well
there's no mbr in this drive so this
must be a blank drive with nothing on it
well we don't want that to happen so
basically what it means is it allows the
mbr system or a bio system that is used
to seeing mbr it will allow it to
realize that this is not an empty drive
it's just something it can't read and
then there's some really cool stuff
where part of this initial mbr can be
hints to the operating system itself as
to what's happening underneath and so
some older bio systems are able to boot
from a gpt drive
even though it shouldn't be able to
because the linux system or you know the
operating system itself says okay i see
mbr is saying that um you know it's
really a gpt drive but i know enough
about gpt myself that i'm going to be
able to find the software and you know
the the drive files and partitions on
here myself and so you can actually use
it on there but it's because of that
protective mbr that all that is possible
so when it comes down to it mbr is the
old way of doing things gpt is the new
kid on the block honestly there's no
reason not to use gpt it does everything
mbr does it does it more efficiently
more reliably
it's just the better way to go so i
recommend that you use gpt and while
there are significant differences a lot
of those backwards compatibility issues
make it so that you don't even have to
worry about them
the linux file system is actually really
cool because all of the network mounts
and different hard drives and usb drives
are all on one
giant file system it's not there's no a
drive b drive c drive d drive there's
nothing like that it's just all one big
file system hierarchy and we're gonna
look at the different things because
whether it's a real or virtual file
system it's on the same file system
whether it's relative or absolute this
is just how you traverse
the actual file system we're gonna look
on the command line about that network
mounts they're just you know on a remote
system but they just show up as a folder
on your local computer it's just it's
really cool so first of all let's let's
start at the very beginning it's a very
good place to start so we have a hard
drive right so we're going to say it's
dev sda1 and that has the root partition
on it you know just forward slash so
this is like where everything starts the
root partition is the basis of our linux
file system it's it's on a hard drive of
some sort in our case it's this one now
inside there there's tons of files and
folders some of the files are directly
on that dev sda drive right on the root
file system or folders within that root
file system they're actually stored on
that hard drive some of the folders and
the files in there are a virtual file
system if you look inside the
root directory there's a proc folder and
a sys folder these are dynamically
created file systems that are just a way
to interact with the kernel itself so if
you want to make a change to the running
kernel you can make a change to one of
the files in these folders and it's
going to affect the running kernel but
it's not actually files it's a virtual
file system it's just a way that they
represent that interface with the kernel
is this virtual file system then we also
have like a remote nfs server it could
be nfs or samba or you know whatever
your network protocol of choice is but
it's mounted on the folder
inside of your root system so this could
be like the home folder on your system
might not be on the actual hard drive it
might actually be on a remote system but
it's mounted inside your file system and
from you know from a layman's position
just looking at the system you don't
know if it's a remote system or a local
system or a virtual system because they
all look the same same thing when you
insert a usb drive it doesn't come
through as like you know like the e
drive or the f drive like on a windows
system it's just mounted somewhere
on a folder inside that same
one solid
monolithic file system even if you put
in another hard drive so this is we're
saying this is dev sda1 like the
partition one on the sda drive even if
you were to put in a second hard drive
in the system it's still going to mount
inside a folder or a subfolder of this
root drive right it's going to be like
in mount data or wherever you happen to
mount it it's just going to appear as a
folder inside this root file system so
everything is inside that root file
system it's really a neat way to handle
all of the various things that can be
stored in linux and the virtual file
system is very unique in that it's not
really a file system it's more like an
interface designed as a file system so
you can interact with the kernel itself
all right so let's go to
our file system here and i just want to
show you kind of how it looks i want to
talk about this whole absolute versus
relative thing all right so i'm just
going to
show you the file system here we have ls
and we have a folder called pictures we
can do ls picture
gotta spell it right ls
pictures and i have a folder cbt gold
which is this background and then a
trips folder uh what if we were to do ls
trips
okay there's a folder called grocery
store mexico orlando now there's a cool
program called tree i'm going to use so
let's say tree
pictures it's going to show us a tree
representation of all the files and
folders inside here so we can look we
have the pictures folder there's a one
file in there called cbt gold then
there's a folder called trips inside
that folder are three different folders
grocery store mexico orlando inside each
of those there are files that are stored
in there this is the hierarchy of that
now honestly
this mexico folder this could be like a
remote nfs share we don't know because
it's all on the local file system that
is you know mounted everywhere on the
system it's just one file system so we
don't know where these are we just
interact with them as if they're all one
local file system so that's just a
really cool thing about it but this
whole absolute versus relative let's go
over to
the pictures folder
and trips
i'm going to clear the screen and if we
were to type ls minus a we're going to
see all of the things in here now we
already saw some of these orlando mexico
grocery store but these dot and dot dot
now these are special folder entries
that mean the dot means the current
folder so if i were to say cd to dot
i'm in the same folder dot dot means the
directory above me so if we're in trips
dot dot is going to be pictures so if we
were to say cd dot dot
all of a sudden you'll see now we're in
the pictures folder that's pretty cool
right now we can use that as a folder
name anywhere so let's go into
trips orlando okay and inside here let's
do an ls minus la we can see here are
all the the pictures that we have and
then these two folders dot dot and dot
in every single folder you're gonna find
a dot and a dot dot because it's just a
pointer that means this directory
the directory above me okay so we can
put that in a string too let's say i
want to cd to dot
dot dot
and see where this takes us
two pictures now why did it do that well
because dot dot if we're in orlando dot
dot means trips and then we're in trips
the second dot dot means pictures so
that's interesting we could do something
really complicated and it'll end with
this we could say
cd
trips
orlando
dot dot
grocery store
oh okay what happened there we'll end
with this one like i said so we started
in pictures and we went to the trips
folder
orlando
back to the trips folder and then into
the grocery store folder and sure enough
that's where we ended up pictures trips
grocery stores so you can use dot dot
anywhere in your thing to talk about the
relative path of where you're where
you're going okay now the absolute path
of this is going to
be cd home
bob
pictures
trips
grocery store
and then sure enough we're in the same
folder this is the absolute path
starting at the root level but we can
use relatives paths using things like
dot dots one other thing i said i was
going to end there and i guess i lied to
you this tilde image or this tilde thing
is a shortcut for your home directory so
if we were to say cd to the tilde which
is usually to the left of your one key
boom now we are in the tilde which if we
type pwd we'll see is home bob all right
so those are the relative path tools
that you can use to construct where you
want to go but that's really how it
works and the tree program is just kind
of a cool way to look at things you can
see everything else spelled out there
the big takeaway is that the linux file
system is just one big monolithic file
system and whether you're mounting
network shares or you're mounting usb
drives or second hard drives or even a
virtual file system to interact with the
kernel it's all under the same bunch of
file system in this big hierarchy
partitions are really just
organizational units that are on a hard
drive you kind of chop a hard drive up
into different partitions and those
partitions are used for different things
like swap space or you know a particular
folder on your system
you can use partitions for a lot of
things and depending on the system that
you're using whether it's going to be an
mbr master boot record or gpt gui id
partition table you can have a multitude
of partitions or just a few and
depending on which scheme you use it
depends how big your hard drive can be
now we're going to look at a handful of
tools like parted and g parted and this
stands for partition editor and
graphical partition editor
and the old school f disk which is just
a command line tool that didn't used to
handle the gpt partition table but now
it does so there's this one size fits
all tool called fdisk and then i do want
to show you a couple tools that will let
you see what block devices are available
to partition on your system so let's
actually go right to the command line so
that we can check out what's on our
system and i chose to use centos today
for no other reason then i thought let's
use centos so i want to show you first
of all how we can identify the block
devices on our system we can type lsblk
and it's going to show us this really
nice little cool tree thing right so we
have fd0 floppy disk which actually is a
lie there's not a floppy disk on this
system it's a virtual machine but then
sda is the main hard drive on the system
and it's partitioned into two partitions
the sda1 which is the boot partition and
then sda2 which is used in lvm which
we'll talk about in a different nugget
then there are a bunch of other hard
drives installed in the system that
don't have anything on them at all there
are four 10 gigabyte
drives sdb sdcsd and sde we can also see
these things if we look at proc
partitions this is again the virtual
file system that shows us an interaction
with the kernel and we can see sure
enough here they are sdb c d and e and
this is how big they are the number of
blocks so they're 10 gigabytes and of
course if we just looked in the dev
folder and gripped for sd we would see
all these devices too right sd b c d and
e so what i want to do is just partition
one of them we're going to pick sdb and
there's a couple ways we could do this
we could use g parted now notice i'm
root we have to be rude if we're going
to do the system level stuff like
partition a hard drive but we could say
g parted and it'll start up and scan for
all the drives available and there's a
little drop down here sdb
very cool we would have to start by
creating a partition table and then we
could create a partition with gui tools
it's really really easy to use g parted
but a lot of times the system doesn't
have a gui so i don't want to do it that
way now we could also use parted or
partition editor this is the cli version
of the program that we just used we can
type help
and it'll show us it does the exact same
things it's just used you know use text
to tell it what to do all right so i'm
not going to use this one either but i
want you to know that they exist and if
you're more comfortable with them
they're a little bit newer and they have
a few more features and that sort of a
thing but what i want to show you is the
old school f disk and i want to show you
this because if you're on a server it
may not have partition editor you know
part ed or especially g parted the
graphical one so i want to show you what
almost every linux system is going to
have and we're going to use that one to
actually do our work so we're going to
say fdisk
dev sd b we have to tell it what device
we want to use so it's a good thing we
know how to find the available devices
on our system
type this and type m for help now we
just have these single letter commands
but that's okay the first thing we're
going to need to do is to create a
partition table and it can be one of two
types we can create a gpt partition
table by pressing g
or we can create the old mbr or ms-dos
partition table using oh
i'm just gonna pick since it's not over
two terabytes in size either one is
going to work so let's just use gpt for
the heck of it so i'm going to say g
press enter it says okay it built a new
gpt disk label this is its id and now we
have a partition table but no partitions
to create a partition we can actually
type p to see what's there there's gonna
be nothing there so to create one let's
press m again so we hit the whole help
screen we can say n for add a new
partition so new and now it says
partition number one through 128
right this is not mbr mbr would only
support one through four this is gpt so
one through 128 i'm just going to pick
the default
first sector the default is going to be
the first one available
last sector the default is going to be
the last one available right this is our
range and it chose the last one so i
want to fill up the entire partition or
the entire drive with this one partition
so if we type p now we're going to see
sure enough we have a partition there
it's 10 gigabytes linux file system type
that's okay and now to quit let's press
m again for help to quit we could just
press q and it would quit without saving
changes but we actually want to make
these changes so we want to make the
change to the disk so we're going to use
w to exit which means right so w
enter and now our partition table has
been done we can say lsblk and look at
that now it shows up that we have a
partition created on our system it
happens to be a gpt partition table and
it's a single partition that takes up
the entire drive i didn't actually go
through the process of using parted or
gparted they're very straightforward and
they walk you through it and the help
screen is right there and easy to use so
if you want to use those by all means go
ahead but i wanted to show you the more
complicated fdisk because it's going to
be on every single system that you run
across
there's a wide variety of file systems
that you can put on an empty partition
in linux but the idea of all of them is
the same you take a big empty partition
like a big field and you divide it up so
that you can store data efficiently like
if this parking lot were
an example of a file system each car
would be a piece of data that is stored
logically in its place and and some file
systems have you know bigger spaces for
parking buses some have littler spaces
for parking compact cars but
conceptually they all do the same thing
now like i said there's a bunch of
different options available in linux ext
is the most common family of file
systems that you can use on linux it's
very mature it's been around forever the
later versions support journals so that
if a computer gets powered down before
the reads and writes are synced up
usually you can salvage the data on
there so it's fairly robust as well xfs
is a file system that's been around for
a long time this used to be what you had
to use for really really big drives but
now everything supports big drive so
that's not really the issue anymore it
is still used by centos and red hat
though so xfs is still widely used
interestingly it has its own set of
tools like for
file checking fixing things manipulating
the the xfs file system itself rather
than using standard linux tools it has
its own set of xfs tools there's a
couple others
btrfs it's often called butter fs
this was the new kit on the block right
this has awesome features like
snapshotting and it's just awesome
unfortunately it's kind of been
abandoned which is weird but nonetheless
it's kind of what happened so btrfs is
still functional but it's not widely
used anymore and then of course i'm just
going to mention them dos or the windows
world has their own file systems like
ntfs vfat fat32 things that you're
familiar with if you're in the windows
world and linux can usually read and
even write to most of these file systems
but when we're talking about linux file
systems we're generally talking about
linux specific ones and ext
is awesome i'll be honest i like ext
there's generally three there's e xt 2
ext3 and ext4 now this isn't necessarily
like one is better than the next they
each have their own features but ext4 is
the newest and has the most features
i'll be honest i almost always pick ext4
as my default file system not because
it's necessarily better than any other
option but because it's so widely used
that means there are a ton of tools and
utilities and tutorials online to get
data back if you have some corruption so
ext4 is my file system of choice mainly
because it's used in so many places when
it comes to creating a file system
basically you need a partitioned hard
drive so that you can you know have a
partition or that empty field in order
to draw the lines for your parking lot
or put that file system on now i'm going
to say lsblk
and we're going to see these are the
different block devices on our system i
have two partitions created i have sdb1
and sdc1 these are just 10 gigabyte
partitions on 10 gigabyte drive so it
takes up the whole drive and we're going
to format each of them all right so i'm
going to say oh here's another really
cool thing about linux the file
formatting or the hard drive formatting
programs all start with mk for make fs
file system and then just hit tab a
couple times and you're going to see all
the various tools for creating the
different types of file systems so let's
say we're going to make a butterfs file
system so we would say mkfs.btrfs
[Music]
and then what partition we want to
create that file system on in our case
dev
sdb1
alright so it's created it it says we
have 10 gigabytes idu's one that's the
path okay so it looks like it did that
without any problems let's create
another uh file system so uh mkfs hit
tab a couple times so i can see our
options now like i said i usually use
ext4 so i'm going to say ext4
dev sdc one which was the other
partition that i had created on this
system and it went through and it
created that file system and now a
really cool thing if we use the
lsblk but we add the dash f it's going
to show us the file systems that are on
the particular block devices as well so
if we do that we're going to see up here
we have sda1 which remember i said red
hat and sent to us use xfs well sure
enough there it is xfs is used sdb1 is
that butterfs file system that we
created and then down here is an ext4
file system that we created on our
system so that's all there is to
creating the various file systems and
really you can pick whichever one you
want but you do have to have a partition
in existence before you can create a
file system on it and while yes there
are a whole bunch of file systems that
you can use on linux and it supports a
bunch i really recommend that ext family
of file systems if you have a choice and
you're just trying to decide what one to
use largely because it's used so often
there's so much support if something
goes wrong you can find a lot of help
online
if we want to be able to access the data
that's on the drives or the partitions
of the drives that we put into our
system we have to mount them into our
local file system now we can do that
manually using tools like mount or
u-mount or we can use the etc tab file
to do it automatically on boot but
conceptually what's going on is that we
have a new hard drive or a partitioned
hard drive and we want to
incorporate that into our file system
now it's really important to note that
when you mount a partition or a hard
drive it goes into a folder and that
folder becomes what is in that drive now
we couldn't mount it on this folder
because this folder already has things
inside of it it has to be mounted on an
empty folder because it doesn't make
sense
to have all the things in this hard
drive in this folder and then have these
other folders alongside of it so it has
to be in an empty folder that we mount a
partition or a drive so we could
actually take this hard drive and mount
it into this folder if it's an empty
folder and that's what we're going to do
on our system is find an empty folder
and then this all the files inside this
drive will become part of our bigger
linux file system starting at this mount
point
now i'm here on an ubuntu system and i
have the regular route mounted hard
drive and then i also have an additional
10 gig drive and if we do lsblk we can
see that we have well a bunch of things
here loop loopback devices but we have
down here sdb1 okay this is a 10
gigabyte partition and it's all set up
and ready to mount but it's not
currently mounted on our system so in
order to mount that i actually want to
mount it in a folder if we look inside
mnt there's a folder called 10 gig and
inside that folder
is nothing it's an empty folder so i
want to mount it on there now if we do
blk id we can see a little bit more
information about the device itself so
here is dev sdb1 now here is the
universally unique identifier for this
partition uh keep note that this is
something that's specified about the
partition we'll look at that in a second
but we know that it's type ext4 okay
that's good to know and we know that
this is where the actual partition lives
so we can say
mount now i'm going to say dash t for
type ext4 usually mount can
automatically figure out what kind of
file system it is but if we know there's
no reason not to do that so i'm going to
say mount dev
sdb1
and where do i want it to mount on mnt
10 gig
press enter and now if we go into
mnt
10 gig
we're gonna see sure enough now there's
a lost and found thing this is the root
level of that hard drive but now it
actually lives in our file system right
here we can type mount alone on the on
the line it will show us where it's
mounted right so right here it's mounted
on mnt 10 gig so let me type cd and then
we can unmount it by typing u-mount
mnt
10 gig it's not unmount it's u-mount all
right so there now that that's how we
manually mounted and unmounted if we
wanted to have it mount automatically on
boot we would edit the file etc fs
tab all right and i'm actually going to
stretch this out so we can see
everything on here we can see there's
already an entry in here for the root
file system sda or s yeah sda1 but
notice it doesn't specify it by its
device it specifies it by its
universally unique identifier which we
could get by using that blk id command
it'll get us that uuid for the
particular partition now we could use
the uuid for
a dev sdb1 and we could put that in here
to mount it but i'm actually going to
use let me make another entry here i'm
actually going to
say that the file system is on
dev sd b1 we can specify it by device or
by uuid or we can even use the drive
label if we want but in this case i'm
just going to use the the device itself
and then tab over the next field here is
the mount point so i want this mounted
on mnt
10 gig
tab over the next thing is type it's an
ext4
options i'm just going to say defaults
and then the last two fields are dump
and pass now dump is an old school
backup program it used to dump the files
to a backup this is really deprecated
it's not really used anymore at all so
dump you're going to want to put 0 for
dump the last line though pass this
means do you want it to run a file
system check 0 means never run a file
system check
one means run the file system check
first so you put a one on the root
partition
any other partition that you wanna have
checked when the system boots up you're
gonna put a two
so i'm going to put dump of 0 you always
put 0 for dump and then pass is 2. it's
the second most important because the
root is the first one you want to have
scanned and then everything else is
going to be 2. so you can have like five
different partitions mounted they could
all have pass of 2. now there's more to
it to get it to scan automatically on
boot but when you're setting up the
fstab file this is where you do it so
save this and now we could just type
mount minus a and it's going to mount
everything that is specified in fstab
and we can look by saying
mount and it'll show us that sure enough
it remounted that because we defined it
in fstab and if we reboot the computer
it's going to automatically boot it or
it's going to automatically mount it as
well it's really easy to mount
partitions using the manual tools it's
also pretty easy to use the fstab file
to specify it and you can either specify
it by device name or the uuid that we
can find out using the blk id program
to scan a linux file system generally
you use the tool fsck or just fisk as
it's often referred to now the real key
though is to have it scan automatically
periodically on boots so you don't have
to manually do it because here's the
deal in order to run fisk the file
system itself has to be unmounted that's
not really a problem for secondary or
tertiary drive mounts like the home
directory or something like that but the
root directory it's pretty difficult to
unmount the root directory and scan it
unless you're in the boot up process or
you've booted from a cd or something so
i want to talk specifically about how to
set up the system to
scan the the file system on boot
including the root file system so that
you can you know have it automatically
maintain itself now when it comes to
scanning automatically there's a few
different flowchart things that go on
the very first thing the kernel looks
for is inside your fstab file if the
pass setting is set up if it's a zero
you know if you have your your dump and
pass and if the pass is set to zero then
it won't scan it just absolutely will
refuse to scan it doesn't even look any
further it just stops right there and
continues booting up the system if
however you have that partition set up
with either a one or a two a one for the
root partition a two for any other kind
of partition if you have it set up then
it looks at the drive itself and it says
okay
has the maximum number of allowed mounts
been reached and if that threshold has
been reached it will scan the drive
before it boots up if not if it hasn't
met this maximum yet then it's not going
to scan it's going to increment it's
going to say okay i'm going to mount one
more time and add it to the number of
times i've been mounted but i'm not
going to scan it even if the pass is set
up to scan it's not going to scan it if
it hasn't met the max now the max by
default is negative one which means it's
never going to scan because that's just
the way of saying like don't ever
automatically mount so by default you're
never going to get an automatic scanning
which is a little bit frustrating
because you do want to have your system
automatically scanned so on ubuntu here
i have
dev
sdb1 mounted on mnt 10 gig okay so this
is another partition this is not my root
partition but it's mounted on mnt 10 gig
all right if i look inside of the fs tab
file
we're going to see that on this
partition that i have automatically
mount on boot it's set up with a pass of
2 which means that it is going to check
to see if it should scan automatically
okay it's not the root partition so i
don't have it set up with a pass of 1
but since it's set up with 2 it's going
to check and say okay if it's time i'm
going to scan this
so let's get out of here and how we can
see what the maximum number of allowable
mounts before it will scan is is to use
the tune 2fs
we're going to do dash l for a listing
of
dev sd b1
and it's going to show us this now what
you want to look for in here is this
maximum amount count remember i said by
default it doesn't ever scan that's
because this is set to negative one and
you're never going to reach that because
that's just the way of saying disable it
if we want to have it automatically scan
every so often we need to change this so
we would say
tune to fs
dash c for count and i'm going to say
every 10 months i want it to scan and
dev sdb1 okay so now the maximum amount
count is 10. we can look at that by
doing the same command over and we can
see now the maximum amount count is 10.
okay so what does that mean well every
time the system boots it mounts the
partition well we could speed that up we
could say umount dev sd b1 mount dev
sdb1 we do that and now if we look it's
going to increment it by one because we
unmounted it and remounted it so if we
do that a bunch of times
and now we look back and see okay our
mount count is now 16 and our maximum
count that is allowed is 10. well why
didn't it automatically scan well it
only does that on boot so if we were to
reboot the system it would go through
the flow chart and it would say okay you
have your pass set to two so that means
i need to check the drive and say okay
drive is your mount count higher than
the maximum amount count allowed before
a scan and it will be so if we do a
reboot
and once it's booted back up we look and
run that tune 2fs again so sudo
tune 2fs
l
devsdb1
now we're going to see that the mount
count is down to 1 which means that it
scanned it it ran fisk on boot before it
was mounted and it reset the mount count
to zero and then of course it mounted it
so now it's one so now it's not going to
rescan that on boot until the mount
count gets above this maximum amount
count and then it will do it
automatically and figuring out what
number to set here can be kind of tricky
because here's the deal if you're on a
laptop you might reboot fairly often so
you're going to want to have that number
kind of high so it doesn't scan every
single time but if it's a big file
server maybe you rarely ever reboot it
maybe once a year well in that case you
might want the mount count to be very
low so that every time it gets rebooted
it does scan for consistency's sake
and then one more thing if it's a huge
partition with just millions and
millions of files it's going to take
hours or days to scan so maybe you don't
want to scan it every time it mounts it
really depends on your situation so plan
out how often you want to scan and the
type of situation that you're in to make
the best choice for your particular
partition and honestly the best choice
for you might actually be just to run
fisk manually just unmount the partition
or boot from a cd or usb drive if you
need to scan the root partition maybe
you never want to automate the process
you only want to do it manually for some
cases that's fine too regardless it's
important to know how the system works
so that if you think you're
automatically scanning you really are
lvm or logical volume manager is
basically like a software version of a
storage area network it allows you to
take a whole bunch of physical devices
and lump them into one big group that
allows you to kind of carve out slices
of storage for the use in your local
system it consists of a bunch of parts
physical volumes volume groups and
logical volumes they use the word
volumes a lot in there
but nonetheless it's a way of taking raw
storage and combining it into a thing
that you can just slice up and expand
and contract and add more things to it
without disrupting the existing services
here's how it actually works or looks in
practice so we have we start with
physical volumes i'm just calling them
pv and we're going to say that we have
four 10 gigabyte drives now in the
standard practice these could be actual
hard drives they could be raid devices
or they could be partitions on a hard
drive it doesn't really matter what they
are they're just chunks of storage and
you create physical volumes out of them
and then you combine those physical
volumes into volume groups and so then
all of these are combined into a volume
group and if you add 10 times 4 you get
40 gigs so then you have this volume
group which is like just a big bucket of
storage and that bucket of storage has
no protection now i know that's not like
a feature right but i really want you to
know that if you just have 10 gigabyte
drives all in a bucket so you have 40
gigabytes of storage and you're just
gonna take and carve out chunks of that
that doesn't offer you any protection so
if one of these drives fails
all of a sudden you could have your end
result be completely corrupt and useless
so physical volumes being raw devices
and not having any redundancy is a
little bit scary so anyway just wanted
to throw that in there once you have
this volume group you carve out a slice
of it and it can be a small slice like
here i just said this is about seven
gigs i just kind of like spatially
guessed how much of 40 gigs that would
be um but you can carve out a big chunk
so you could have like a 30 gig slice or
you could have like a 32 gig slice that
would use like two plus a little of
another drive basically you don't know
underneath what's going on the volume
group is just a big chunk of storage
that you carve out a slice of and then
this slice is called a logical volume
that logical volume is what you format
with a file system and mount on your
local hard drive or on your local file
system and what you install linux on so
it's a long step process but it allows
for a lot of flexibility and so i want
to show you what it looks like in
practice even though it's not this
robust system with multiple physical
volumes if you have centos
installed they actually use lvm even if
you only have one drive so i'm going to
show you here if we look at the etc fs
tab
file what we have here is our device is
called dev mapper centos dash root okay
now this is like dev mapper what is that
well this is where logical volume
manager creates those logical volumes
for us to use and you'll see here this
dev mapper sent to us root is mounted on
the root of the hard drive or root of
the file system it has xfs as a file
system and it's installed same thing
down here they have another carved out
slice called centos swap and that's
mounted as swap space on the system so
if we look inside devmapper
we're going to see we have sent to us
root and sent to us swap now i want to
show you really quickly a handful of
commands so you can see what's going on
if we look at pv
display this is physical volume display
it's going to show us what's going on
behind the scenes right like what makes
up the bucket of data that we're going
to use we only have one physical volume
i know it seems weird right why am i
making a bucket out of one device well
you can expand it if you want so they're
giving you the room to expand later if
you want to do it after it's already
installed so we have one physical volume
and it's a partition it's dev
sda2 all right it's in a volume group
named centos
and that gives us it looks like about 19
gigabytes of storage okay so this
physical volume is inside a volume group
called centos so our our bucket with all
the data is called sent to us and it
looks like we carved out root
and swap from that bucket so let's look
at that really quick we're just going to
look at lv
display logical volume display and we
should see two and sure enough we have
two logical volumes i'm going to scroll
up a little bit here our first one
is named swap it's in the centos volume
group because that's the only volume
group we have it happens to be two
gigabytes in size and it lives in dev
centos swap this is an interesting thing
you can you can use dev mapper and the
name of it or you could use
dev
the name of the volume group
the name of the logical volume as like
in folders here so that's another way
that you can reference it and find the
actual logical volumes and then the same
thing down here dev sent to us root
the logical volume name is root it's
carved out of the centos volume group
and this one looks like it's about 17
gigabytes so if we look inside
dev sent to us we're going to see sure
enough there we have root and swap as
our two different logical volumes that
we could one is formatted right this is
formatted with xfs and this is just swap
space i know we didn't go through the
process of actually creating all of the
different parts but hopefully you
understand exactly what lvm is doing
taking physical volumes whether
partitions or hard drives or raid
devices combining them into a volume
group and then carving out logical
volumes that you can use as regular
devices on your system and it just
allows for flexibility kind of like a
software-based san in your own computer
building an lvm is actually one of the
most straightforward things that you can
do when it comes to block storage
devices on linux it's surprisingly
consistent all the way through the
process for you know the names of the
tools and it really is kind of fun and
once it's built you can expand it by you
know adding more drives to the system or
you know stretching your existing
volumes but let's go ahead and actually
create from start to finish an lvm
system on our linux device now here i am
on ubuntu and if we do lsblk we're going
to see that well we have a bunch of
stuff but down here this is the drive
that our system is installed on so we're
not going to touch this one we're going
to use these four
devices so sdb c d and e which are 10
gigabyte devices notice i don't have
partitions created on these now you can
create partitions some people prefer to
use partitions for their physical
volumes in an lvm some people prefer to
use the raw devices either one works
fine they work the same
the advantage of setting up a partition
is that if somebody else comes to your
system they're going to see that there's
partitions on the system and they're
going to know that something is already
done there whereas if you leave them raw
devices they might think oh look empty
drives now it's kind of far-fetched and
you're not just going to like start
formatting drives in somebody's system
but that's the reason some people like
to use partitions i'm just going to use
the raw devices and to turn these raw
devices into physical volumes we use pv
create and we just make a list of the
devices we want to use so dev sdb devs
dc dev sdd and dev sde so it created
them now we can do pv display if we want
and it's going to show all the devices
that we have now each of them is 10
gigabytes and the name of it is just
the device itself dev sdc so the next
step is to create a volume group now to
do that we just do vg create which is
very very nice
uh the first flag or the first command
argument here is the name of the volume
group so i'm going to call this
bucket because it's just a big bucket of
our hard drives right of our data that's
available so i'm going to call the
volume group bucket and then we just
make a list of the physical volumes that
we want to add to it so those same
volumes we just did before
and then press enter our volume group
bucket was created we can look at that
by doing vg display there's four
metadata areas meaning we have four
devices our current active pv are four
we have 40 gigabytes of storage just
about all together because each one was
10
and now we have this thing called bucket
that we can carve a slice out of if we
want and use that slice and put a file
system on it so to do that we're going
to use i'm sure you guessed it lv create
i love the consistency of these tools
it's really nice here we do dash capital
l and how big of a slice we want in this
case let's do something that's going to
span all four disks so i'm going to say
32 capital g for 32 gigabytes
and then dash n the name that i want to
call it i'm going to call this big
underscore
slice and then we have to tell it where
we want to get the data from well in our
case it's in bucket the name of our
volume group right there is bucket so
what we're doing is creating a 32
gigabyte slice called big slice out of
the volume group bucket
press enter logical volume big slice is
created so we can do lv display
and sure enough lv size is 32 gigabytes
so we know if that worked the name is
big slice it's in bucket the lv path is
dev
bucket big slice which is exactly what
we would expect because we've created
this volume group called bucket and now
this logical volume lives inside there
so the last step is that we would
actually use this as an actual block
device or as a hard drive in and of
itself and then we could just do
something like mkfs
ext4 dev bucket big slice
and there we go so now we've done that
we could mount it somewhere and every
time the system starts it's going to be
available in dev bucket big slice and
then if we put it in fstab it's going to
be mounted on boot and then there are
other tools that we can go and like lv
extend if we wanted to make it bigger so
we could do something like lv extend
dash l i'm going to say plus 5 gigs dev
bucket big slice and now it says the
size has gone from 32 gigabytes to 37
gigabytes it was resized and we did that
without adding anything to the system we
just used the tools to change the size
of our logical volume the thing to
remember again about lvm is that it
provides flexibility in your system it
doesn't provide any redundancy so if you
have one physical volume fail it's going
to crash the entire volume group and
logical volumes are going to get messed
up so you want those pvs to be like a
raid device if you're worried about
something going wrong underneath and
losing data but setting up lvm as you
can tell is very simple and honestly
even kind of fun raid is a redundant
array of independent disks or drives and
basically what it means is that it you
take a bunch of drives and put them
together and you end up with a larger
pool of storage now the cool thing about
raid is that it doesn't just pull things
together like lvm and give you a bunch
of data it allows you to do some pretty
neat things with performance or
redundancy so i want to talk about the
different raid levels that we can offer
using raid specifically linux rate linux
has a software version of raid which is
very powerful very robust and
surprisingly efficient so basically i
want to make sure we cover all the
different raid types and to do that i
want to show you this big scary dragon
now here's the idea i'm going to i'm
going to talk about
raid but instead of a redundant array of
independent drives we're going to say
they're a redundant array of independent
knights of the round table okay and in
true 80s fashion our knights are going
to be just squares like from atari's
adventure anyway here's the deal with
raid 0 our drives are set up in a stripe
which means that they work together
reads and writes happen across two
drives very very quickly and so with
raid 0 or a striped array it's very fast
right you can get dual writes and dual
reads at the same time the problem is
let's say that the knights are attacking
the dragon and the dragon is attacking
the knights if we lose one of the
knights well then the dragon can get
right through to the king because if you
lose a single drive in a striped array
or in a raid 0 all of a sudden your data
is gone because half of your data is
written on that other drive so while
it's very fast they better kill the
dragon quick because if one of them
fails all of their data is gone and the
king gets destroyed now raid 1 is kind
of the opposite it still has multiple
drives but they're set up in a mirror
which means every time you write
something to the first drive you write
it to the second drive so you have a
complete copy of both now because
they're in a line like this they can
only attack the dragon one at a time
right they can't both attack the dragon
like over here in the striped setup but
the advantage here is if one of them
dies there's still another full night
there protecting the king same thing
with your data right if one of these
dies you still have a full set of your
data because you've been writing it to
two drives the entire time so a mirror
doesn't give you any speed increase
because you're not spreading the writes
across here you're actually writing all
of your data two times once to each
drive so you don't get any advantage
over a single drive when it comes to
speed but you do get that advantage of
either drive can die and you still have
full protection for your data now raid 5
this is a little bit different raid 5
uses a parity disk and how that actually
works is like some digital magic that is
beyond the scope of this nugget and to
be quite honest it still stumps me a
little bit but conceptually how it works
is you have multiple drives three
minimum and any of these drives can die
any one of them it doesn't matter which
one and all of your data is still in
place so you get the advantage of being
able to lose any drive in your array the
disadvantage is you lose one drive's
worth of storage now what do i mean by
that let's say these are all five
gigabyte drives okay if these are all
five gigabyte drives together that would
be 15 gigabytes but you lose one drive's
worth of storage for that parity magic
and so if you have three five gigabyte
drives you're only going to have 10
gigabytes of usable space but the
advantage is it's writing to multiple
drives as it's going along and if one of
the drives dies you still have all of
your data represented in the remaining
drives now if you lose two of course
then your date is corrupt and and you're
done but you can lose any drive and it's
not just like this is the drive you can
lose no you can lose any one of these
and all of your data is still there it
really is magical and so that means that
you can lose a knight and the dragon is
still going to be stopped by whatever
two of the knights are still protecting
the king hopefully that makes sense with
the different raid levels and just
briefly i want to talk about there are
some hybrid levels as well so raid 0
could be raid 0 1
where you have like four drives and what
happens here is you have a stripe of
mirrors your drives are mirrored and
then striped across the mirror or raid
1-0 which is a mirror of stripes or vice
versa but basically four drives and
you're mirroring two two of them and
then striping those two mirrors and vice
versa you're going to stripe them and
then mirror those two stripes with raid
5 there's actually a raid 6 which is
cool but it requires another drive and
then you can lose up to two drives and
still have your data there's two of
those parity drives in place now the
downside is you lose two drives worth of
storage on your full array but it's
awesome because you can lose more than
one drive now even if you don't follow
along with my awesome dragons and
knights kind of scenario hopefully the
raid levels make sense now my trick my
little mental trick to remember what it
is i look at the number after raid and i
say how many disks can i lose because
for years i would confuse raid 0 and
raid 1. but here's the deal with raid 0
you can lose zero drives right because
if you lose one you lose your data with
raid 1 you can lose one drive and you
still have another drive raid five i
guess you could lose one of five i don't
know it kind of falls apart but rate
zero and raid one are the ones that i
would always struggle with so i think of
that number as how many drives i could
lose and still have my data
you can go to the store and buy a raid
card like a hardware raid device and
then you can use that on your system and
you'll be able to have hardware raid but
linux has a really awesome and powerful
software raid program that will use
kernel level tools to allow you to
create your own raid devices without
needing any specialty hardware at all
now there's a couple things we need to
discuss like partitions versus using raw
devices i want to make sure we cover all
the configuration stuff but conceptually
it's really easy rather than having a
hardware based card we just use our
regular sata controllers and then our
hard drives can all work together in a
raid array that we choose now when i
talk about partitions versus raw devices
let's say we have 200 gigabyte hard
drives but they're from different
manufacturers now they both say that
they're 100 gigabytes however if you
look close they might have slightly
different number of sectors and slightly
different size so this one says it's 100
gigabytes but it might be actually 1028
megabytes and this one says 100
gigabytes but it might actually be 1022
megabytes now they round for marketing
purposes and that's perfectly fine and
usually on a system it doesn't matter
but if you have like this drive fail in
a raid array and you need to replace it
with another drive and you try to use
this drive and all of a sudden oh you
created a raw disk device raid array
unit and it has
1028 megabytes of space and you try to
replace it with another 100 gigabit
drive but this one only has 1022
megabytes you're not going to be able to
work it because this isn't big enough so
generally what people do is you take and
make a partition
inside of your drive that is slightly
smaller than the hard drive itself so it
might be
99.9 gigabytes and then the same thing
when you have a new drive you're going
to have enough room to create a 99.9
gigabyte partition and so even though
this drive itself is slightly different
the underlying partition is going to be
the exact same size so you're going to
be able to use it to replace a failed
drive in an array so that's why we
generally use partitions even though
using a raw device would work until you
need to replace it with a smaller drive
that is your replacement now here on our
ubuntu system if we do lsb lk we're
going to see we have four 10 gigabyte
drives that are installed in here we're
going to make a right array with those
this sda1
this is our root partition this is where
our system is installed but these drives
down here are the ones that we're going
to use to create our raid array now i've
already partitioned the first three
you'll notice it's a 10 gigabyte drive
and the partitions are 9.9 gigabytes
awesome we're going to do the sde the
last one together and so f disk dev sd e
and the first thing well we can press m
to see all of our different options but
i'm going to go kind of quickly i'm
going to say o to create a new partition
type and it's going to be a dos one it
doesn't have to be dos but i just
decided dos and then i'm gonna say n for
a new partition and i want the partition
to be primary so default number one
default the start point on the drive
default and here's where rather if i
choose default it's going to be 10
gigabytes in size and that would be fine
as long as our replacement was the exact
same kind but i want to do it slightly
smaller than the drive itself so here
i'm going to say plus
9.9
g and press enter and now we have it 9.9
gigabytes in size so any 10 gigabyte
drive we'll be able to replace it with
because we'll just create a 9.9 gigabyte
partition inside now the one last thing
if we do t for type and press enter it's
going to say okay what partition type do
you want here it says it created a new
partition with type of linux but if we
type capital l we're going to see all of
the available codes here now this is not
a format this is just like a flag to
give the kernel a hint as to what sort
of partition this is supposed to be so
the one that we want to put on here is
actually f d
for linux auto raid so i'm going to type
fd
and now it says change type of partition
to linux auto raid or linux right auto
detect i'm going to press w to write
this change to the disk and now if we do
lsb lk we're going to see we have all of
them here now that partition type is
just to give the kernel a hint if you
put these drives in a new system it's
going to say oh look at those partitions
those are part of a linux array or of a
raid array so we're going to treat it as
such so it's just a hint but it works
even if you don't change that partition
type all right so now it's pretty easy
to create the actual raid device we're
going to create a raid 5 device with
four 10 gigabyte devices well about 10
gigabytes and so we should end up with
about a 30 gigabyte usable space with
our raid 5 array now the tool we use is
mdadm and then we're going to say dash
dash create because we want to create a
brand new one i'm going to say verbose
just so we can see it do things as we
type it in and now what device do i want
to create well the devices are dev
md and then the number of the raid
device you're creating so we're going to
start with md0 because that's our first
device and we don't have any raid
devices on here yet i'm going to do dash
dash
level equals
5 i want it to be a raid 5 device and
then dash dash raid
devices
equals 4 because we have 4 devices and
now we need to list those devices out
and we're going to list the actual
partition so
dev
sdb1
dev sdc1
dev sdd1 and dev sd e1 and press enter
boom it created it that quickly now we
can see the details of it if we were to
look at
md stat this is the virtual file system
proc and this is going to show us the md
stat which is the current rate arrays in
our system so here we have
it's currently a raid 5 array it shows
our devices here lots of information it
says recovery that's because it's
building the array but we can use it
while it's currently using the array
which is really awesome okay so we look
into
dev
grip for md we're going to see there we
have md0 so we have a device all created
and we can now use this as a hard drive
in our system before we do that though i
want to save this configuration of this
raid 5 array into our system so that on
boot it knows exactly what sort of array
to build to do that we just do md mdadm
detail
scan
and if we do that it's going to show us
the configuration so that's the
configuration for our current array what
we want to do is save that so i'm going
to redirect it into etc mdadm
md mdadm dot conf so we're going to save
that result into this file
and now every time we boot the system
md0 is going to be created and then we
just treat it like any other hard drive
on our system so
mkfs
dev md 0 and boom it created it and now
it's part of our system and it's going
to be about 30 gigs in size let's see ls
blk and we look down here md0 shows up
as 29.6 gigabytes about 30 gigabytes of
raid 5 storage on our system if you're
thinking that was a little bit too easy
well you're right linux raid is awesome
it's super simple to set up it allows
you to use the regular drives in your
system and set them up as a raid device
so as long as you can save that file
into mdadm.com that detail scan that we
did and you can check for the progress
or the status of your current rate array
in md stat you are really set that's all
it takes to use raid on a system using
nothing but software provided with the
linux kernel installing tar balls sounds
like some sort of prank you might pull
on somebody in high school but really
this is the way that we would install
software on linux for years before
package management systems came out now
you can still download tarball files of
source code for programs and install
them although it's not terribly common
anymore now we used to refer to this as
the three step we would extract compile
and install and this is the process to
convert source code into an executable
program now i'll show you how to do that
really quick i've downloaded already a
very simple program as a tarball file
it's called sun weight it's just a
simple program that waits until the sun
goes down and then executes so if you
have a script that you want to run at
sunset that's kind of a cool tool to use
to do it but the first step is to
extract it so we're going to say tar
minus zxvf
sun weight we'll go into the folder
that's created if we type ls we'll see
there's a couple files in here this is
the source code and also a make file now
sometimes there's more complicated
things like dependencies sometimes
there's going to be a config file so
we'll run
config and go through that process and
it'll tell you if you need other
dependencies since we don't have a
config file i'm just going to type make
because make will compile it into an
executable program now you'll notice we
got some warnings but we didn't get any
errors a lot of times if it's a big
program it'll say oh i need this
dependency or oh you forgot this library
and you'll have to download and install
those dependencies before you can
compile it but this one is very very
simple if we type ls again we're going
to see now we have a result here we have
the sun weight program now we can
execute it right here by saying dot
forward slash sun wait and we'll see
sure enough there it runs and we could
use this to wait until sunset to execute
a program if we want to install it
though we have to either copy it to our
user local bin folder or sometimes
they'll include in the make file an
installer so we could say something like
make install this one doesn't actually
have that ability to install it it's a
very simple program so if we wanted to
install it if you get an error like this
you just simply say okay i'm gonna move
sun weight to user local bin and now if
we type sunway it's going to execute
because it's in our path now i told you
that three-step process is really really
simple and it is you just basically type
make and it compiles and then you have a
binary that you can install either using
a script or just putting it in your user
local bin file there is a big
disadvantage though if you compile
things from source and that is there are
no update mechanisms for getting a newer
version if you use a package manager
it'll update old software but if you
just compile it yourself and install it
manually there's no way to update it and
that can be a real problem especially
when security concerns come up so while
it's important to understand how to use
tarballs to compile and install programs
it's not really the best way to go about
it if you have any other options
deb files are the way that programs are
packaged up in the debian and ubuntu
world now there's a couple different
ways that we can manage the subsystem
and there's a little bit of confusion as
far as what tool to use now behind the
scenes they all use d package which is
like the the lowest level of interaction
with dev files and i'll show you why
this is not what you use on a regular
basis in order to actually install
packages on debian or ubuntu there are
three different options though for
installing packages using the proper
system apt apt-get and aptitude now i
want to talk about them because they do
the same thing but it's just a matter of
being replaced by something better so
apt just apt all on its own is the
newest program to interact with the app
system it's new it's simple this is the
one to use so just use apps i'm going to
try to use apt if i can aptitude you may
find online instructions people telling
you how to install packages with
aptitude this is older but it still
works i don't recommend you use it
though it's a little bit strange when it
comes to dependencies but it's been
outmoded and now apt is the way to go
now here's the other thing apt-get has
been around for a very long time it's
the oldest of the three it still works
but i don't recommend you use it because
again apt is by far the best way that
you can go about installing packages
here's the real problem though i've been
installing packages on debian and ubuntu
for so long that sometimes if you're
watching me in a nugget i might use
apt-get by mistake just because it's a
habit it still works there's nothing
wrong with doing it but the proper way
to go about installing packages is to
use apt that's what i'm going to try to
do and that's what i'm going to show you
now now on our ubuntu system if we type
ls we're going to see i have a deb file
so it's kate kate is a text editor that
works in the kde environment and this is
the installer the dev file now remember
i said that d package is the program
that is used behind the scenes that's
how you interact with dub files here's
the problem so i'm going to say sudo d
package minus i for install kate.deb
it's going to try to do it but here's
the problem it doesn't resolve any
dependencies so if i want to use d
package to install it i'm going to have
to find every one of these deb files on
the internet download them install them
one by one find out if they have
dependencies and it can be a real mess
so thankfully the apt system takes care
of all the dependencies for us so i have
to erase this so i'm going to say pseudo
d package minus r kate and it's going to
undo the mess that i made and now we're
back to square one rather than
downloading the deb file we can use the
app package management system and just
say sudo apt
install
kate
and it's going to look for the latest
version and get all of the dependencies
and you can see there are a ton it would
have taken me a week to come up with all
these dependencies so if i say yes it's
going to install them all
and it's finally finished that took like
over three minutes i sped it up so i
didn't have to sit here with me the
whole time but now all we have to do is
run kate because it's installed with all
of its dependencies on the system and
here it is our little text editor kate
now another nice thing about using a
package management system is we can keep
things updated so we could say sudo apt
update which is going to download the
latest repository information to find
out all the updates that are out there
for us to install and then once we have
the freshest versions of what's out
there we can use that same program apt
and say sudo apt upgrade and looks like
we have a couple things we could upgrade
hit enter and it's going to keep our
system up to date that easy not worrying
about dependencies it does all that on
its own so while all three of these will
technically work for installing and
updating packages you really want to use
just the simplest one which is apt it's
the newest and it's the easiest to
remember
rpm is the red hat package manager and
it does just that it manages packages on
a red hat based meaning red hat or sent
to us or anything else that uses the rpm
system that's how it manages their
dependencies and their installation and
their programs and updates etc now
there's a few tools we need to know how
to use in order to really utilize rpm
yum is kind of the de facto standard but
there's a new kit on the block called
dnf when i talk about that and then of
course rpm itself is not only a package
management system but it's also the tool
the low-level tool that we use to
actually handle packages now the cool
thing about rpm is there's no two steps
required when it comes to installing now
what do i mean by the two-step process
well here we have our multiple programs
i just mentioned now yum is yellow dog
updater modified which may seem silly
but just for a brief second yellowdog
was a linux distribution that ran on
powerpc or old apple hardware and its
claim to fame was actually that it
started this yum program for managing
packages now the
operating system itself didn't do well
after the power pc platform kind of
faded out but yum is still around today
and in fact that's the program that we
use on almost every rpm distribution it
handles dependencies um it is it updates
the repo information as it's installing
and upgrading so unlike app you don't
have to say like yum update and then yum
upgrade when you upgrade yum updates
before it does anything else now dnf
which and i'm not kidding here it stands
for dandified yum
but dnf is the new program it's in
fedora right now it's not incent os but
it's going to replace yum it's just a
rewrite it has some features that are
that it worked better but similarly
structured and how it works and then of
course rpm is what happens behind the
scene there's a program called rpm and
this is the low-level tool but it
doesn't handle dependencies so we
generally don't use the rpm tool on its
own let me show you what i mean i'm on
centos here and we're going to use yum
to install packages but first i want to
show you rpm now if we look i have
downloaded this program called kate this
is just a text editor that works in the
kde environment but if we were to
install it with rpm we would have a
problem if we say rpm dash i for install
the name of the package it's going to
say i can't do that because you have 110
billion different dependencies that
aren't installed so what you'd have to
do is find every dependency every rpm
install them one by one
these probably have dependencies of
their own that we'd have to track down
but thankfully that's where the package
management system yum comes into play so
we could simply just say
yum
install kate and it's going to go to our
repositories it's going to update the
cached information like show us the
latest information from those
repositories and then it's going to
search for kate it's going to find all
of the dependencies right here say it's
looking for all the dependencies and the
dependencies of the dependencies and now
it says would you like to install it
along with the 77 dependent packages
okay i'm going to say yes actually i'm
going to say no if we install it then it
would just download install all of those
packages and life would be good and we
would have kate installed but what i'm
going to do is now show you that's how
we would install a package but if we
want to update the system all we need to
do is type yum
upgrade and it's going to query all of
our repositories it's going to download
all the package information dependency
information that we need and now it's
just telling us if we want to get our
system updated we're going to have to
download 116 packages install one new
package and it's going to take 308
megabytes of space do we want to do that
i'm just going to say yes and it's going
to go through the whole process of
downloading all those rpms it's going to
use the rpm tool in the background
install each one of them one by one
until they're all updated and all
installed to the latest version so yum
is very simple to use and knowing that
it comes from you know a distribution
that's no longer even a valid
distribution i don't know that's just
cool for me that you know yum is still
around even though yellow dog hasn't
been a distro for many years now i don't
have a fedora system to show you dnf
first hand but it's a very similar
program to yum it's going to work very
very similarly so if you find yourself
on fedora just use it very similarly to
how you'd use yum and you'd be fine one
of the big things i want to point out
though is that there's no two-step
process like there is with the apt
environment meaning you don't have to
update your repositories before you
install it you just run yum and it's
going to update and upgrade all the
information before it does any
installing or upgrading
one of the nicest things about the app
package management system is that you
can add repositories which are just
different groups of software packages so
if something's not in the standard
ubuntu or debian system and somebody
else has written something you can add a
whole repository of new software and
then the app system can use it just like
any other package on your system it's
pretty cool now we're going to look how
to add something and there are a few
gotchas that we need to look at but
thankfully it's a fairly simple system
when it comes to configuring new
repositories so i'm here in the etc apt
folder on an ubuntu system if we do an
ls we're going to see there are two
things i want to show you there's
sources.list sources.list.d this is a
folder and there's actually nothing
inside there right now but we could
create a new file.list in here and it
would be read just like this
systemdefaultsources.list so it doesn't
matter where things go i'll just add
something to the existing sources.list
so we're going to look and you'll see
there's already a bunch of repositories
added each one of these lines is a
repository containing software that the
app system can install now some of them
are commented so we would just uncomment
the existing ones like here this is a
partner archive we could uncomment this
and then this would be an active
repository but if we want to add a third
party repository we can like i said
either add it at the end of this file or
create a new file in that sources.list.d
folder and call it like new program.list
but i'm just going to add it in here and
i'm going to add the opera browser
repository in here let's say we wanted
to add the opera browser it looks like
this
it's okay if every field here doesn't
make perfect sense to you this is just
the format it says what kind of a
package it is where it's stored what
folder in there and then what version of
the software we want to actually add the
stable and then it's non-free as far as
like what what type of repository it is
so this is the line right this is where
the opera browser is stored on the opera
website so if we save this we would be
able to do apt update
no dash
apt space update and if you look it is
updating them all but i do want to show
you back at the top here it gave us a
little warning slash error oh and it
repeated the error down here so i'm
going to show you here it says this
repository is not signed so what that
means is we don't have their key because
we don't want there to be a man in
middle attack where somebody you know
takes over opera.com and then starts
sending us bogus packages so they do
signing key signing in order to make
sure that we get the right software so
if we want to use the repository we have
to add their gpg key to our system now
it's not difficult to do we just do kind
of a two-step here we have to download
the key itself so wget
so we're going to download the file and
then pipe that into
app key add all right so we'll do that
it's going to download the key and it's
going to add it to our system and it
just says ok we can see if it's there by
typing apt key
list and it's going to list all of the
keys in our system and if we look we
should be able to find sure enough
here's the opera one so there's the
upper key that we installed now if we do
app update
notice there's no errors at all it
updated and now we could just install it
using our apt system app install
opera stable and it would install our
needed packages you know it would
resolve dependencies even if they're in
other distributions and it would install
it for us just fine i'm going to say no
because i want to show you another way
you can add a repository and this is
kind of a cool thing that ubuntu added
it's called a ppa or a personal package
archive there's a particular text editor
that i really like it's called adam atom
and they have a ppa which is a
repository and to add it you just say
add apt repository ppa colon and then
where it lives or what user it is web
up date team and the name of the
repository is atom
press enter it's going to do a couple
things it's going to add it to our
sources.list but it's also going to
download that key for us so all we have
to do is say press enter and it's going
to install the key it even does an apt
update for us and then we would just do
apt install adam and sure enough it
would be able to do it from that package
or from that repository that we just
added it can be a bit overwhelming once
you have to start adding gpg keys for
the repositories that you put into your
sources.list but ppas make it really
really really simple they do everything
for you i really like ppas i think it's
been a wonderful addition to the way we
handle apt packages
repositories in an rpm system using yum
are very similar to that of an app
system adding them is maybe even easier
and editing the config is about the same
just with different files let me show
you what i mean now the main
configuration file in centos is going to
be the yum.com file so let's look at
that it's in etc and it's
yum.com here's where we can do a couple
things one we set the main configuration
things like where the cache is stored
and things like this one thing i want to
point out in here is this gpg check now
you can actually turn off yum's ability
to verify using signed key pairs and
this will just allow it to install any
repo or install from any repo that you
install in your system it's not a good
idea to turn this off though because
again this is a safety check to make
sure you're not getting a man in the
middle attack but the main section is at
top you can put new repos in the bottom
or like it says right here you can put
them in etc
yum.repose.d as individual files with
the format file dot repo that's usually
what's done but we could add them here
let's look inside the
yum.repos.d folder so let's get out of
here go into etc
yum.repost.d
and here's where all of the repos that
are currently installed on our system
live so let's look at one really quick
look at the base file here and we're
gonna see how it is set up so there's
the base configuration up here the name
of it the release where the actual files
are stored gpg check you can turn this
on and off for individual repos as well
so if you set up a repo and you don't
have signed key pair you could turn it
off for just one repo and then this
tells us where the actual key file if
it's turned on lives so we can put our
put it in there manually so that yum
knows where to look to find that key now
normally these aren't added manually but
you could type all of these in these are
all individual repos that are defined in
here in this bracketed section usually
what you do though it's really elegant
is let's get out of here you just
install the package so one of the really
popular packages is called apple which
stands for extra packages for enterprise
linux and to do that we just do yum
install apple release
i'm gonna say yes to install it and now
if we look in here we're gonna see here
we go the apple.repo has been added so
now if we were to install packages apple
would also be one of the places that we
could pull packages from we can just cap
this to look at it
and we can see it's enabled the gpg
check is on it tells us to use this key
file for checking the signatures and
that's all there is to installing a
repository in yum and since yum
automatically updates we don't have to
like update the cache when we install a
package it's going to automatically fill
in the blanks for us yum is an
incredibly awesome and powerful package
manager and we can tell just by how easy
it is to add a repo and edit that config
either using the yum.com file or the
individual files inside etc yum.repo.d
apt and yum are certainly the most
common package managers out there but
there are a few less common package
managers that you should still be aware
of now arch linux uses a program called
pacman for managing their packages and
open souza uses zipper now i'm not
saying that the mascot for zipper is a
purple horse but i'm just saying maybe
it should be nevertheless it's not too
difficult to use them even if you're not
familiar here i have two terminal
windows to two different linux
distributions the first one is arch
linux which uses the pacman package
manager so if we just do pacman minus h
we're gonna see here are a list of the
commands now it's not immediately clear
how you go about installing a package
unfortunately it's not just install it's
actually capital s for sync we kind of
want to sync the system into a state
that we wanted so to install a package
it isn't difficult once you know what to
do just pac-man minus capital s and
let's install vim my favorite text
editor you have to actually spell
pac-man correctly pac-man
minus capital s vim it'll say do you
want to install it and say yes it's
installed it and now if we type vim you
can see sure enough there's vim my
favorite text editor now over here in
open souza it's a little bit different
here we use a program called zipper zy
pper and you do zipper minus h
and it'll show us all of the help
commands that are available this one it
is pretty easy you just do install or
you can shorten it to just in so we
could say
zipper in
vim we'll install them again press enter
it's going to retrieve the repositories
online just like yum or apt would do and
then it's going to install the vim
package for us and we'll be able to use
it on open souza
it'll ask us so we want to continue i'm
going to say yes
and it installs all of the packages and
the dependencies so now same thing here
we get startup vim and sure enough
there's vim this time on open souza
pac-man and zipper are really two of the
more popular alternative package
managers but there are some others if
you're on slack where you're going to
have to install things by hand using
tar.gz files but these two along with
apt and yum will get you through most
systems
managing local users on your server is
really easy and there's a bunch of tools
that make it even easier now there's the
standard command line tools that allow
you to add modify and delete accounts
and there's this super cool script that
i really like which makes adding a user
very very easy there are a whole bunch
of different facts about a user that is
stored in the system though full name
username password all of these things
plus some others that aren't even listed
are on there and it's important to know
that the tools will manipulate all of
these but you don't have to specify
every single thing every time especially
things like office number those aren't
even really used anymore but there are
possibilities that you can add specific
information in the local group now i
just want to go right to the command
line so we can actually start adding
users and at first we're going to use
the tools that you know kind of come
with it like the low level tools user
add user dell in user mod so first of
all i want to say
user add because we don't have any extra
users on our thing i'm going to do dash
h and that'll give us the help screen
now you can see there are tons of
options for adding users but the format
is pretty much the same user add
whatever options you want to add and
then the login or the username for the
new user now we're going to use just a
couple and i want to show you the
problem with using user ad as opposed to
that fancy script add user
we have to determine like a home
directory and a user shell and all sorts
of things like that so let's say we
wanted to make a user we're just going
to say now notice i'm root we have to be
root to make a system user but we would
say user add and i want to do minus d
home susie minus s for shell i'm going
to use the bin
bash shell and her username is going to
be susie
press enter it's all done now there is
no password for susie we'd have to
actually do that with the password
command uh we'll actually say p a swd
susie alright so now she has a new
password and we can here let's start a
new window
ssh suzy at
susie
and we're logged in as susie oh but see
it says unable to change to directory
home susie there's no such file or
directory well dog on it we said that
that's our home directory but by default
it doesn't make that directory we
actually have to make that directory or
there's another command dash m which
will create it as we're adding the user
so it's possible again to use this tool
and set all of those different flags up
as we create the user if we go through
all of these things but it's much easier
to use the add user script and i'll show
you what i mean add user frank and now
it says okay i'm creating the frank user
added a new group for frank created
frank's home directory copying all the
files from etsy scale and now it's
asking me put to give frank a password
so i'm going to do that now the full
name of frank his room number which
again we don't use room number work
phone all those things anymore really
but full name is nice to have in there
and is this information correct i'm
going to say yes
and so now we have a really nicely set
up user so if we were to open a new tab
again and do ssh frank at localhost log
in with frank i have to type frank's
password correctly and now you'll see
sure enough if we do pwd we're gonna see
we're in frank's home directory he has a
perfectly usable account because that ad
user script goes through and remembers
all the various things that we need to
do so let's get out of here now there is
another tool we can use user dell so we
can say user dell let's do minus h so we
can see the options there's really only
one option that's ever really important
that is minus r which removes the user's
files so we could say user dell
minus r for remove frank and it removed
all those files that said there wasn't
any mail form so i couldn't remove that
but now frank's home directory is gone
now we could modify susie's account if
we use user mod so let's see user mod
minus h and we're gonna see same thing
we have a whole bunch of tools and this
is just to modify an existing user so we
could do something like change her shell
like right now it's been bashed but we
could change her shell so we could say
user mod
minus s let's say bin
false susie
what this is going to do it's going to
change her shell so if she tries to log
in it's going to fail so let's open up a
new tab and try to log in as her ssh
suzy at localhost it logged in and then
immediately logged out see it says it
still doesn't have a user account we are
a user directory we didn't make her a
home directory but then it says
connection to localhost closed that's
because as soon as it logged in her
shell is been false which immediately
exits and then we're back to being
logged out we're logged in as bob here
so the ability to modify a user account
is really important but if you're going
to add a user i highly recommend you use
that script you can certainly use the
manual tools with all the flags to add
that account but add user just makes it
so easy by remembering all the steps and
i'll be honest i often have a difficult
time remembering is it add user or user
ad add user user ad for my own sake i
like to think okay alphabetically add
user is first and that's the first tool
i want to use for adding a user so
that's just the trick i use regardless
of what tools you use to add users it's
important to understand that modifying
them on the command line is fairly
simple and not that difficult to learn
local groups on a linux system are
fairly straightforward to handle but
it's important to understand the
difference between primary groups and
secondary or supplementary groups on
each individual user now every user on
the system is going to have their own
personal primary group now usually
that's going to be the same as their
username so bob is going to have a
username of bob and he's also going to
have a primary group of bob and that's
usually how it goes it could be a it
could be a different group that says
primary group but almost always that's
how the primary group is going to be on
a linux system and then there are all of
the supplementary groups which happen to
be like things that he belongs to like
maybe he's in the admin group maybe he's
in the sales group marketing third floor
public all of these groups are in
addition to his primary group and it
will give him access to certain folders
on the system that he might not have
access to if he didn't have these
different group memberships now in order
to actually create groups the tools are
very straightforward just like adding
users with much fewer options so let's
actually look at that and i want to show
you how to manipulate users in groups on
a system now here we are on an ubuntu
system and we can simply say
group add
public it's going to add the group
public to our system we could say
group add
sales and it's going to do that now we
could look at the different options
group add minus h you see there aren't
too many options we could specify a
group id number if we wanted we could do
some things with group mod to change
some of those features like the group id
and then of course we could delete them
with group dell and the same sort of
thing you know we just delete them as we
would use user dell on a system to get
rid of a user so this is pretty
straightforward but the part about
primary and secondary can be confusing
so right now if we type groups bob we're
going to see that bob is in all of these
groups the first one listed is his
primary group so bob's primary group is
bob and then these are all of his
supplementary or secondary groups now i
want to show you user mod minus h
because it shows us how we can
manipulate groups right here so
lowercase g is how we force a user to a
new primary group so we could change
bob's primary group using the lowercase
g flag on user mod in order to change
his secondary or supplementary groups we
use a capital g but here's where the
gotcha comes into play if we do like
minus capital g public it's going to
delete all of his other supplementary
groups and only make him part of the
public group and that's not what you
almost ever want so there's this nice
dash a which means append the user to
another supplementary group without
getting rid of the additional groups
that he already belongs to so let's
actually do that in practice so we're
going to say user mod minus a for append
minus capital g
public bob okay and now if we do groups
bob we're going to see that bob still
belongs to all those secondary groups
and also to the public group which is
exactly what we wanted to have happen
because if we wouldn't have used that a
this is what would have happened if we
would have done user mod minus g
let's do sales for bob this seems like
it's going to do the right thing no
errors but then if we do
groups bob we're going to see
he still has his primary group of bob
and then just sales and so we'd have to
manually go back through and add him to
each individual group which is really a
pain in the butt so you don't want to do
that you want to always remember to use
the dash a now in function the
difference between a primary group and a
secondary group the primary group is
what is used if bob were to create a
file so let's open up a new tab here we
are bob
say this is in our home folder if bob
were to touch a file and we do ls minus
l we're going to see the file that we
just created is owned by bob and the
group membership is bob's primary group
of bob so that's really the difference
between primary and secondary is when
you have a primary group that's what the
group membership of a new file you
create is going to belong to now
creating groups is really easy with the
group ad group mod group dell tool so i
didn't even go into that very much in
depth the real important takeaway is the
idea of primary versus secondary or
supplementary and how to take individual
users and put them into groups without
deleting all of their other
supplementary groups that they already
belong to i hope this has been
informative for you and i'd like to
thank you for viewing figuring out what
users are on your system and what
accounts they're using and what they're
doing is really an important part of
forensics but also it's an important
part of a sanity check like why is my
computer running slow or what user am i
logged in as and there's a handful of
simple command line tools that we're
going to go over that will just help you
figure out the users on your system now
the first scenario this happens a lot if
you log into embedded systems like
routers and stuff where you don't get a
prompt that tells you who you are you
just get like a hashtag here well what
you can do is say who am i which seems a
little bit silly but it will just give
you the user that you're currently
logged in as if you're starting to use
sudo and su and you're sshing from one
computer to another sometimes just
figuring out what user you're logged in
as is really important so that's it
seems silly but it's something that i
use in nuggets even you'll see me use
that quite a bit
another one if we just do who it'll show
us who is logged into our current system
it actually gives us quite a bit of
information we have bob frank and looks
like susie is logged in twice and it
tells us when that person logged in and
where they're logged in from so bob is
our current user and i'm logged in on
the display zero meaning i'm using an x
windows session here and then frank and
susie are both logged into localhost
probably ssh and then susie is logged in
from a remote computer probably over ssh
as well so who tells you that w which is
like what although you don't have to
type the rest of it it's just a w gives
you the same information with a little
bit more so these are the users where
they're coming from when they logged in
how long they've been idle and then what
again that's where that what came from
what they're actually doing so here i'm
using a gdmx session
looks like frank is sleeping on the job
frank judging you buddy
and then susie's just logged into a bash
terminal so these are tools that give
you information another one is pinky
which seems like a silly tool but it
replaces the older tool finger that has
kind of been abandoned about 10 years
ago but this gives you even more
information but not the what's going on
this gives you the login name full name
when they logged in how long they've
been idle where they're coming from and
a combination of these really usually
any one of them will give you the
information that you want but these are
all here to give you information on
who's logged into the system now if you
want further information about it you
could also do id susie and it will give
you information about susie's id
including her user id her primary group
id what groups she belongs to looks like
she only belongs to the susie group so
let's do an id on bob and yeah bob
belongs to a whole bunch of other groups
so it'll give you all of that and then
lastly lastly there's the command last
hahaha if you type last it gives you a
history of the people that have been
logged into the system recently so it
looks like we go back all the way to
march 7th here today's march 13th and i
logged in a bunch of times just so we
would get some results here and we can
see who logged in where they logged in
from and when they logged out or if
they're still logged in so you can see i
logged in at 1001 logged out at 1001 up
here logged in at 1003 still logged in
from the local host computer and that is
suzy so there's a lot of tools that you
can use to figure out who's logged into
your system how long they've been there
where they're coming from what they're
doing and these really might seem like
throwaway commands like why would i need
to figure out who's logged into the
system but knowing the simple little
tools like who and w and last can really
be convenient when you're tracking down
what's going on in your server who's
logged in who was logged in did somebody
log in bob said he logged in did he
really log in well check out last and
it'll tell you the point is there's a
bunch of tools that are available
that'll give you information on users on
your system whether they're logged in
not logged in or have been logged in in
the past
passwords and group memberships are
things in linux that are stored in text
files just like everything else but the
problem is we don't want people to have
access to our passwords and so there's
kind of this elegant system of shadow
files that has been invented this is
fairly recent in the world of technology
it used to be everything was stored in a
single file called etc password but
things have been changed now so that
everybody doesn't have access to seeing
the encrypted password so how it works
now is this let's say this is our user
bob now bob when he logs into a system
has to be able to see what his home
directory is so he needs to have access
to a lot of information about his
account however we don't want bob to
have access to everybody's encrypted
passwords so that's kept over in another
file called a shadow file so what we
have in the password file is we have
bob's username and then literally just
an x that takes the place of where the
password used to be stored and if this x
is here then the system knows okay i
need to go over and look in the shadow
file for the actual encrypted password
of bob and then it does system
authentication with root access as
opposed to bob's access which is to read
the password file
but he doesn't have access to
everybody's encrypted password the
reason we don't want that is if he were
to do like a brute force attack if he
had access to everybody's encrypted
password he could just keep hammering
away at it until he finally figured out
what the password was we don't want that
so we don't want every user to have
access we just want root or the system
to be able to authenticate and check out
you know the encrypted password files so
anyway there's a neat and elegant system
of how this works now notice obviously
the etc password file is readable by all
the et cetera shadow file is only
accessible by the root user but when it
comes to editing those there are special
tools to make sure that we do it
properly now first let's actually look
at the file so if we do an ls minus all
of etc pass sswd we're going to see that
sure enough it's owned by root and
everybody on the system can read it
right only root can write to it but
everybody can read it but if we look at
the etc shadow file we're going to see
that only root can write to it and only
people in the shadow group can read to
it everybody else in the system can't
even read it so our encrypted passwords
are protected now there's also if we do
ls minus l etc
group we'll see the same scenario where
this is the group definitions for users
on the system and the same settings
permission wise as etc password has and
if we do ls minus l
etc
g shadow we're gonna see it's the exact
same thing as the shadow file now groups
don't normally have passwords associated
with them but they can so the shadow
system does the same with the group file
as it does with the password file now if
we wanted to edit one of these files we
could do something like sudo vi etc pass
s wd and it's going to let us edit this
file using our text editor but this is
not the ideal way to go about it because
we want to do it the shadowy way right
we want to be able to edit it and then
be sure that the shadow file matches so
let's get out of here let's not make any
changes to properly edit these files
what you do is say sudo
vipw this is part of the shadow package
and it's going to ask us what editor we
want to use if you want to use nano this
is the easiest one like it says right
here easiest you can use this i prefer
to use vim so i'm just going to choose
selection number two but number one is
perfectly fine and it opens up and looks
exactly the same and we make changes
here and we could like go down here
you'll notice all the things about bob
are listed in this line right here's his
username his password is just a
placeholder here as an x because the
actual encrypted password is in the
shadow file but his user id is group id
his full name his home directory his
shell we can make any changes we wanted
here and then we would just go and save
the changes
and this is what it would tell us it
would say okay you've modified the etc
password file you may want to modify the
shadow file too and to do that you do
vipw dash s for shadow so the same thing
we would say
sudo vi pw
dash s
and now this is the actual shadow file
that we're editing and we can go through
and if we wanted to make changes here
this is bob's encrypted password now
this is obviously not bob's plain text
password his plain text password is just
the word bob we know that
but this is what it's like encrypted but
since this is only accessible to root
there's nobody who's going to be able to
do a brute force attack to try to
decrypt this
because they don't have access to the
passwords encrypted themselves so we'll
get out of here and now the exact same
thing with the group password or the
group file in the group shadow file is
done too we can say sudo vi gr and this
is going to edit the group file and sudo
vi gr
s and that's going to edit the g shadow
file all right so that's the proper way
to go about editing those files manually
if you man if you edit these files it's
going to do the same thing as if we did
like user mod and changed somebody's
home directory it just does it by
editing the underlying configuration
files so yes group and password files
are still just text files but there is
this elegant shadow system that allows
us to make sure that the right people
have access to the encrypted passwords
and not everyone on the system can see
everyone else's encrypted passwords
quotas are the way that we make sure
users or groups don't overuse the hard
drive we don't want a particular user a
particular group to use up too much of a
hard drive and stop other people from
saving files now there's soft quota
limits and hard quota limits the
difference is with a soft limit you're
warned every day hey you've gone over
your limit hey you've gone over your
limit whereas if you reach the hard
limit you're no longer able to save
files at all now there's a couple things
that we have to do to get our system
ready for using quotas and keeping track
of things but the first thing is we have
to make sure that our partition is
mounted correctly so on our system here
i have a disk mounted or a 10 gigabyte
drive mounted on
mnt
disk okay now if we look into our etc fs
tab file i'm going to show you how you
mount it so that quotas are enabled so
here's our drive it's dev sdb1 and it's
mounted on mnt disk it's ext4 i've used
default mounting options and then i've
added a comma and usr quota now we could
also put grp quota we put another comma
and grp quota i'm just going to do user
quotas group quotas work the same way so
we'll learn one and we'll know how to
use both but we have to make sure that
it's mounted this way so if you're
making this change you want going to
want to reboot your system to make sure
that it actually takes effect
and then if we type mount we're gonna
see that sure enough mount disk or mnt
disk is mounted with quotas enabled
specifically user quota management okay
so we know that the drive is able to
support it but out of the box quotas are
not turned on so what we need to do is
first of all scan the existing drive for
files owned by a particular user so we
need to actually do sudo quota check
dash a for all partitions that support
quotas dash u for user owned files press
enter it's going to go through it's
going to check our drive and now if we
look in mnt
disk
we're going to see sure enough now
there's a quota file that has been
created and it shows just you know all
the files on the drive who owns them
which is none right now but we're going
to change that in a minute now the other
thing is so that prepares the drive but
we actually have to turn quotas on so
we're going to say sudo quota on
dash a for all supported partitions
so now quota quota ing
is actually turned on but if we want to
set a particular quota for a user we're
going to have to use ed quota so sudo ed
quota and i want to do this for the user
bob on our system so we're going to do
it for
bob and then we get this list now it's
going to show us all the file systems
that support quotas in our case that's
just this one devsdb1 now i have to
explain really quickly there's two kinds
of quotas we can do we can set up quotas
for inodes or we can set up quotas for
block usage now an inode means a file so
we could say how many files a person can
store on a particular partition but this
isn't all that useful right i mean what
if they have two files but those two
files are like 27 gigabytes each so
rather than set limits on inodes i tend
to like to set them based on blocks now
by default these are one kilobyte blocks
so this zero means how many are
currently in use and there's nothing on
the drive owned by bob so that's set to
zero right now
but i'm going to make some changes here
i'm going to say i want the soft limit
to be 500 kilobytes
and i want the hard limit to be 1000
kilobytes okay or like one megabyte this
is not practical number you'd probably
do something bigger in real life but
we're going to save this say yes and now
as bob if we go over to mount disk ls
we're going to see that's in there now
there's no usage currently but let's say
i were to create a file now to do that
i'm going to use dd it's okay if you
don't use the dd command basically we're
going to say an input file of dev zero
output file of file one block size
equals one kilobyte so that we can know
exactly how many kilobytes we're using
up and
count equals let's say 400 so this
should make a 400 kilobyte file if i
press enter and do ls minus l we're
going to see sure enough we have a 400
kilobyte file on here and this is fine
this isn't meeting our quota at all we
haven't done anything bad we're not even
up to our soft quota but if we do this
again i'm just going to push the up
arrow and change this to file 2 and
press enter okay it's done the same
thing we do ls minus l now there's 800
kilobytes stored on this particular disk
what this means is it hasn't stopped us
from creating it but every day we're
going to get an email from the system
that says uh hey you've gone over your
soft limit you really need to delete
some files and we'll maybe do that maybe
we won't do that but here's what happens
if we try to create another 400 kilobyte
file which will take us over the limit
right because 400 plus 400 plus 400
would be 1200 but we only have a
thousand kilobyte limit so what's gonna
happen if we press enter it says that
there's an error writing file three the
disk quota is exceeded so let's do ls
minus l and see what happened so it
looks like it went along and it was
creating fine creating fine it got to
200 kilobytes and all of a sudden it
couldn't write anymore and that makes
sense because 800 or 400 plus 400 is 800
plus 200 it is a thousand so we hit our
hard limit and that's exactly how quotas
work on the system once quotas are
turned on it's really a hands-off kind
of thing they take care of themselves
the emails go out automatically every
day if the user goes over their soft
quota and at the hard quota it stops
them no matter what so quotas are easy
to set up once you remember to use quota
on to turn it on make sure that it's
mounted with the proper options and run
that initial quota check so that it
knows what files are on there so it
knows when it is or isn't getting close
to the actual quota that you set
user profiles are where initial settings
are set for a particular user like if if
they're going to set up like aliases or
they need their path variables those are
the sort of things that profiles will do
and there are system-wide profiles and
also individual profiles and it can be a
little bit overwhelming because not
every linux system is the same now there
are some commonalities usually there's
an etc environment file and that file
will
often but not always set up the path
variables so that the users who log in
get a particular
path set up now there's almost always an
etc profile in the system-wide file in a
profile is something that is run on a
login shell so like the very first time
you log into a system like if you're
logging into a gui
that first time you log in you will
execute the profile these are settings
that only need to be executed one time
like it doesn't matter if you're going
to open a new terminal you only need to
set these settings
one time and then there's also going to
be one of these not both of these it's
usually either one or the other either
the etc bash rc or etc bash dot bash rc
uh this one is pretty common in ubuntu
this one is pretty common in centos but
nonetheless these are they serve the
same function so you're going to have
one or the other and these are profile
settings that need to be set every time
you open a shell so let's say you're
already logged in to
x windows like in a gui session you're
in there and you click on an icon to
open up a new terminal window well
that's not considered a login shell this
is just considered a sub shell of your
main system login so you will not
execute a profile you will only execute
your bash rc now this is again system
wide so that happens to everybody when
you log in you get the systemid profiles
applied and then every individual has
the possibility to have these individual
files in their home folders now they all
start with a dot so they're all hidden
you have to do ls minus a if you want to
see them
but these are the same things up here
it's just if you have any changes or
additions you want to make to the
system-wide settings you put them in
your own personal folder and you put it
in like bash rc and that'll run every
time you open a sub shell everything in
here will be set up and then the dot
profile or bash underscore profile
depending on which system you have
you're going to have one or the other
one of these but this is executed
the very first time you log in just like
the system-wide profile your personal
profile only gets executed that initial
time when you log into the system any
sub shells will only apply the bashrc
files but that's the way it works i'll
show you really quick how it's set up on
a system
but the hierarchy is really the
important thing to understand now this
is bob's home folder i did an ls minus
la so you can see all of the things in
here he has a dot bash rc file and he
also has a dot profile that means that
these are going to be applied after the
system-wide settings because the
system-wide settings are given to
everybody and then any personalizations
like if you have an alias that you want
to set on your own you would put it in
your own personal bashrc file now inside
etc there are those common files like ls
minus l grep4
profile we're going to see we have etc
profile and also etc profile.d this is a
folder if we go in there we're going to
see there's a bunch of sh scripts all of
these are included in the dot profile in
fact i'll show you what i mean vi dot
dot
let's look at that system-wide profile
file
and if we look all the way down on the
bottom here it's going to call in all of
those files inside profile.d so when i
say that the profile is executed by
everybody not only etc profile but also
etc profile.d everything in here is
going to be executed as well to every
user on the system now there's a couple
important things to remember don't worry
so much about what exactly is the name
of the file when you look in the etc
folder you're either going to find an
etc bash rc file or an etc bash dot bash
rc file
don't worry too much about which system
has which whichever one is there is the
one that you need to use now as far as
the hierarchy goes it's important to
remember that the system-wide stuff is
executed for everybody so everything in
etc is executed for all users and then
if you have changes or additions you put
them in your personal dot profile or dot
bash rc user profiles are pretty easy to
track down and once you understand how
the system-wide and individual settings
work it's a snap to figure out which
comes first
if you're working on the command line a
text editor is going to be an invaluable
tool because pretty much everything in
linux is text based now you should use
nano nano is the editor you should use
it's a wonderfully simplistic
straightforward intuitive text editor
that works just fine and then there's vi
vi is clunky it's hard to use it doesn't
make a whole lot of sense and it's the
editor that i use almost exclusively now
i know that doesn't make any sense but
here's the deal vi has been around for a
very very long time like since the
beginning so even though it's difficult
to use i've managed to learn to use it
and it's just what my fingers do with
muscle memory so i encourage you use
nano unless you've been using vi long
enough that it's the only option that
seems to make sense now there is one
scenario that you may want to learn at
least the basics of vi
sometimes you're going to come across a
system that doesn't have nano installed
most systems do but if you end up on a
system that only has vi these couple
commands are going to kind of save your
bacon so here's the deal this is what
makes vi so confusing there are two
modes there's command mode which is what
it starts in an insert mode which is
what you use when you actually type text
now the way that i can kind of describe
this is if you're sitting down and
typing you're going to be in insert mode
because insert mode is where you insert
text and delete text and use your arrow
keys to you know go around and change
text but then if you need to do some
command
like save or quit or anything like that
you're gonna go into command mode and
the way i think about it is let's say
you are on a standard word processor if
you're typing you're in insert mode if
all of a sudden you need to reach for
the mouse and click on something
you're going to be in command mode so
while it's not a perfect analogy if you
want to do something like save you're
going to want to go into command mode so
that you can save and quit now since
there's no mouse it's all still text
things that you're doing but think
mentally okay i'm in the mode where i'd
be using my mouse to save things instead
of just typing out text now to go back
and forth that can be confusing too so
you start out when you open vi you're in
command mode if you want to start typing
something you press either i for insert
or a for append meaning like do you want
to insert right where the cursor is or
to the right of where the cursor is but
either one is going to work fine so
either i or a and then if you want to
get back
into command mode you press escape so
those are your magic keys to go back and
forth right i or a i usually use i to go
into your typing text mode or insert
mode escape to go back so that back and
forth that's how it works
now the actual commands to save or quit
or save and quit are right here and they
may not make sense but if you're in
command mode you're going to press colon
and then type w and then q
and press enter that's going to save
your document and quit a lot of times
people get stuck in vi and have no idea
how to get out it can be so frustrating
so this will get you out also if you
want to quit without saving like you've
accidentally made changes and you didn't
mean to you press escape again to get
into command mode and then you press
colon q
exclamation point and press enter and
that will that will exit without saving
and then if you just want to save
halfway through a document you can just
do colon w enter and it's going to save
but you'll stay in then you'll press i
to go back into insert mode and continue
making edits i'll show you really
quickly well i'll show you what nano is
and then i'll show you vi just so you
can see it in practice like i said
almost every distribution is going to
have both nano and vi so i'll show you
nano first if we do an ls we'll see i
have this text file dot
so if you just type
nanotextfile.txt it's going to open the
editor with this and you can just use
arrow keys and you can start editing
right away this is like you would expect
any text editor to work okay so press
enter it's going to insert blank lines
and then if you want to save you can
look right down here we have control x
to exit and you can do other things too
there's all sorts of commands but i'm
going to show you the basics here
control x to exit and then it says would
you like to save your changes and you
can say see the options here y for yes
and for no control c for cancel i'm
going to say yes and then it says what
file name would you like to write well
it'll default to the current text file
but if you wanted to save it as like
copy 2 you could i'm just going to hit
enter
and boom we're done the text file has
been edited it's very simple very easy
to use and again i recommend you use it
now vi i'm going to look at the same
text file with vi so vi text file
text and here we have we're in what mode
are we in we're in command mode now we
can still use the arrow keys to get
around but we can't edit any text or
insert any text if we want to add text
we press i and then look down here it
says insert so this is a little cheat it
tells you that you're in insert mode if
we're gonna go back into command mode
press escape i'm gonna go into insert
mode press i escape to get out insert
mode and once you're in insert mode you
can type text and then if you wanna save
it again you have to press escape
and then
colon
w
q
enter and then boom we've saved the file
we can look and see the text file has
been changed all this changes were saved
and that's how you use vi it's confusing
but that's how it works so again use
nano it just makes sense it's easy
that's what i recommend you use but if
you have to use vi at least now you know
the couple shortcuts that are going to
get you through so that you can actually
use it to edit text now remember i said
i use vi all the time and it's true but
the funny thing is that it's followed me
into things like word processors so
sometimes in my microsoft word documents
even on the very bottom you'll see colon
wq because my head i just automatically
do that when i'm done editing text
anyway use nano but vi is fun and it's a
good skill to have i hope this has been
informative for you and i'd like to
thank you for viewing viewing text files
is an extremely common thing for a
system administrator to do on a linux
system so we're going to look at a bunch
of tools that allow us to examine text
files in a way that allows us to view
but also to search and i'm just going to
go right to the command line so that we
can see these things work in real time
now i've created in my folder here a
file called two cities now this is just
the public domain tale of two cities
this is the first chapter i'll just type
cat so we can look at it
two cities see it's just a tale of two
cities the first chapter all right so
let's clear the screen now the first
thing i'm going to show you is the head
command and what it does it'll show you
the first lines of a text file so the
head or the beginning of it so we can
just say head two cities and it's going
to show us the first 10 lines of the
story so the best of times the worst
times that's part that we're familiar
with now we can change that how many
lines it shows us if we were to do head
dash and 20 it's going to show us 20
lines the first 20 lines of the file so
see it's a little bit longer now and
it's shown us all 20 lines now head
isn't usually as commonly used as its
companion which is tail so let me clear
the screen oop and it spell clear right
clear the screen now if we were to do
tail
two cities this shows us you've probably
already guessed it the last 10 lines and
we could do the same thing with the dash
n and a number we could decide how many
lines of the file we want to see now
this is really useful if you're looking
at log files and that's almost
exclusively where i use the tail command
if i'm looking at a log file i just want
to see the last things that were written
to a log file so i'll do a tail of the
log file in question and i'll see what
was added to the very end so i don't
have to look like 27 megabytes of text
for all of the logs just the last little
bit of it and so that's a very useful
command and again you can use n20 if you
want to see 20 or whatever number you
want to see 10 is the default now the
other ones i want to show you are less
and more we'll start with more this is
the older command so let me clear the
screen if we were to type more
two cities this is going to show us the
entire
file and if we wanna scroll through it
we press the spacebar and it'll go to
the next page spacebar go to the next
page the enter key will go line by line
but this is that's it so we're all the
way to the end of the into the first
chapter but that's how more works you
just kind of go through it like that you
can also search but it only searches
down and it's not one that i use very
often anymore because it's been outmoded
by the much more powerful although it
has a more diminutive name
less so actually let me clear the screen
so if we were to say less
two cities
now we have what looks like a similar
kind of interface but we can use our
arrow keys to scroll up and down
page up and page down work so we don't
have to worry about like hitting the
space bar to go down a page we can
spacebar will go down a page but then we
can scroll back up with the up key now
the other really nice thing about less
and more does this to an extent but less
is even more powerful if you type
forward slash in a term so let's search
for france press enter it's going to
take us to the first entry of the word
that we searched for it's going to
highlight it and it's highlighted all of
them so if we were to press forward
slash and enter again it's going to
repeat the same search and here we are
francis found again france is down here
again forward slash it'll take us to
that one put it right to the top of the
screen so we can search through an
entire text file as well so it's very
very powerful to use the command that
seems like it would be less powerful
because it's named less but really it's
a lot better okay so to get out of here
and this actually confused me for a long
time if you just press q just the letter
q it'll exit the less command and get
you out of it so less more head tail
they're very commonly used i usually use
less and tail more commonly than the
other two but that's just because i want
to see the end of a log file and i want
to be able to go up and down when i'm
scrolling through a text file and search
really powerfully it's not a really
tough nugget because these are pretty
straightforward tools they're all useful
and you'll probably find yourself using
them fairly frequently on the command
line
sometimes when i'm at the grocery store
i wish i could search for where things
are like i think pizza sauce should be
right next to spaghetti sauce but it
almost never is well thankfully when it
comes to searching for text in a linux
system there is an awesome tool that
allows you to do just that narrow down
what you're looking for with tool called
grep now greb does use regular
expressions or regex and if you're
interested in the you know very
fine-tuned filters you can get with
regex i cover that really great in the
linux foundations course but today i
want to talk about searching for strings
of text using grep because it can be a
real powerful way to get the information
you want really quickly now i said that
grep uses regular expressions so if you
want to make sure that it's absolutely
searching just for strings of text you
can use the dash capital f flag and that
means just fixed strings
usually you don't have to do that
because if you just search for a string
it's going to generally find it in the
file but occasionally your string might
be regular expression characters and you
can cause yourself some headaches so if
you want to be safe use dash capital f i
usually don't because it's usually not
an issue but i just want you to be aware
that if you do grep minus capital f it's
going to just search for strings now
there's two different ways that we can
use grep we can say
graph
the string
from a file and it's going to search the
file for the string that we specified
and that works really well but there's
also another way you can do it you can
do this cat file or anything that has a
text output like ls or anything that's
going to output text and then you can
use the pipe symbol and kind of push it
through grep and search for a string
i'll show you why this is a really
powerful way to use grep because it
seems a little backwards like why
wouldn't we just say you know grep this
string from this file i'm on an ubuntu
system here and i'm just going to search
a log file okay so i'm going to say
grep now we can say dash capital f or we
can leave that off i'm just searching
for strings i just again want you to
know that capital f is going to force it
to just use strings but i want to grep
for dhcp from the var log syslog file
press enter and it's going to find all
of the lines in that text file that have
dhcp in it actually even highlights the
dhcp which is really convenient now
there's another place we could get some
system log information and that is using
the
dmesg command
but here's the problem that's a command
that has output but it's not a file we
can't grep the d message command so
that's where the pipe symbol comes into
play and it works really really well we
could just say d message and instead of
just having it print to the screen we
can use the pipe symbol which is usually
above the enter key in a us keyboard
grep i'm going to use minus f this time
we don't have to necessarily
dhcp
and then it's going to take all of that
output from d message and grep for dhcp
and sure enough there's two lines that
have dhcp now another really useful way
that we can use the pipe symbol let's
clear the screen
because i want to show you that first
one that we did right we we actually
grew up for dhcp from that file and we
got these results let's say we had just
pages and pages of results and we wanted
just to look for things that mentioned
init init what we could do is kind of
like chain greps along we could say
grep dhcp from var syslog and then pipe
those results into
grep init and press enter and now we're
just going to get the lines that were in
this result that also contained the word
init and so here now we've filtered all
the way down to these two lines of text
from the log files so even if you're not
getting super fancy with regular
expressions you can do some really
powerful searching of strings using the
grep tool for things like log files or
any kind of text that you want to search
for and remember you can chain those
grep commands together so that you get a
really fine filter looking for exactly
what you're looking for
every application in the linux system
has three sort of like pipes it has
standard input standard output and
standard error and basically it's just a
way to get information in and out it's
an io type situation for every
individual app now i have just an
application here uh drawn out and i want
to show you the difference between the
three so standard input is pretty easy
to understand right this is like if
you're putting something into a program
we use the pipe symbol if we're gonna
pipe something into it or we can use
less than if we want to just assign a
file to the standard input now a lot of
programs don't accept things on standard
input but some of them do so if you've
ever seen me pipe a command into another
command what i'm doing is piping the
results of one command into another
command so it can work on it i'll show
you how that works on the command line
but then there's two other pipes and one
of them is the standard output this is
what happens if you type ls and it shows
you know the contents on the screen
that's the output that it shows you is
the standard output now there's also
standard error if an error occurs it
also prints the things out on the screen
but they're different pipes now we don't
realize the difference because they both
end up on the command line that's like
the default place for standard output
and standard error to go but you can
treat them
differently so if you want to redirect
the output of a file of an application
into a file use the greater than symbol
if you want to redirect the standard
error or like you know an error message
you have to use two greater than because
it's a different pipe and you have to
redirect it separately so let me show
you what i mean first of all let's talk
about standard input now i have in here
a file called file.txt i'll show you
what's inside of it okay so this is what
we have okay just the text file with
some text in it now if we wanted to use
grep to search for text we could just
say
grep text from
file.text and it would show us the text
that's in there but we could also
redirect to the standard input rather
than telling grep what to use so we
could say
cat
file.txt
and then pipe the results into standard
input of grep and then have grep look
for text we should get the exact same
results now what we've done though
rather than telling grep you know what
file to choose from we just piped the
results of cat into standard input and
then grep used that as its input for
grepping for the word text now that is
using the pipe symbol we can also say
grep for
text and i want you to use file.txt as
your standard input
now this looks very similar to this up
here but it's drastically different
because what we've done is we've used
redirection so this is redirecting
standard input this actually functions
exactly the same as this one because
here we're using the pipe symbol to
redirect standard input here we're using
the less than symbol to redirect
standard input so that's how you can do
standard input it's not something you do
as often apart from with this scenario i
do this a lot you know piping one thing
into another so that you can get the
results from there now the other thing
is standard output and standard error so
i have a really quick way to show you so
we say ls and we get these are the
contents of ls we could redirect that by
using greater than into a file called
results.txt and we should get no output
because rather than redirecting the
output to our terminal window here it's
actually redirected the standard output
into results.txt so if we look there's a
file now called results.txt and if we
look at results.txt it has the contents
of that ls command right it just dumped
the contents into there
here's a problem though what if we did
this let me clear the screen
what if we did ls lsf
and we tried to redirect the standard
output into
results.txt
why did we get the error message here
and let's look at results
well there's nothing in results now
because there was no standard output
this is an error there is no file called
ff for us to use ls on if we wanted to
redirect an error we would have to do
lsf
to greater than
error.txt if we do that ah nothing
appeared however if we look at in the
file here now we have a file called
error.txt
if we look in that sure enough that was
the error message we redirected it using
a standard error
redirector using standard input standard
output and standard error redirection is
something you're going to find yourself
doing a lot because you want to see the
results of things when you're not there
to see it happen on the command line
that's basically what log files are
right they've taken errors and
redirected them into a log file for you
once you understand how input and output
works with an application on the command
line there are some really cool tricks
and tips that we can learn to make life
a little bit easier now there's a
handful of things we want to look at but
i've drawn a diagram so we can actually
get a real good taste for what each
thing is now devnl you may have heard of
people call it the black hole or the bit
bucket and basically devnull is a
location on your file system that you
can copy anything to and it will
disappear forever now that seems like a
weird concept i know but if you have
like
extraneous logs that you don't really
want to ever see you just want to like
throw them immediately in the trash
devnl is where you want it to go for
example you would not want to copy
important information and redirect it to
dev null because it will just disappear
forever so devnet is just a place that
everything disappears when you copy it
there now t is an interesting command it
doesn't seem like it does very much but
it accomplishes a task that's remarkably
difficult to do without using the tool
itself so here's how it works we take
some sort of text like output from a
file or something like that and we put
it into teas standard input and then all
it does is dump that same information
out of its standard output but it also
writes it to a file so it does like a t
in the road or a fork in the road it
lets you see what it is right on the
standard output right in your command
window but then it also copies it to a
file so that's what t does and it's
really nice if you want to see what's
happening but you also want to have a
record of it and keep it into a file
and then arguably the most complicated
one but also the niftiest one maybe is
called x-args now how x-args work is
let's say you have a different program
like ls or something and you do the
command and so you see stuff come out in
standard output and then we're going to
pipe it in or redirect it into x-args
standard input then what x-args does is
it takes it and says okay what program
do you want me to use this information
that you just piped into me on and you
tell it like application number two and
then it executes application two and it
uses that information as the arguments
for the second command now the reason
this is really powerful is not all
applications can accept things from
another program on their standard input
so x args basically takes and forces a
program to accept something from
standard input by accepting that
standard input itself and then putting
it as an argument onto the application
now let's look at all of these really
quick because the cool part is you know
when you actually do it now first of all
devnl so we're going to say
echo
hello and it'll put it to the screen if
we do echo
hello and then we redirect it to
no
boom it's completely gone right that's
how devnet works it's just a place that
never fills up it's kind of like a
teenage girl at a pizza party sleepover
right it just never gets full you can
put as much as you want in there it's
just gonna disappear now we've
redirected standard output we could also
redirect standard error
and then we should see hello because
there was no error there right if we did
something like this uh let's say
ls
documents
and ff we should get both standard
output and standard error sure enough
here's our standard error there is no ff
but here is the contents of documents so
we got both now if you wanted to do
something cool and redirect both
standard output and standard error into
one place you can do this you can say ls
documents ff just like we did and i'm
going to redirect standard output into
dev null and here's the magic part and
then i'm going to redirect standard
error into
and
one oh my goodness what is this well the
ampersand one is a way that we can tell
it that what we want is standard error
to get redirected into standard output
so the one is standard output so what
this does is all of our standard output
is getting redirected to dev null so all
of our standard error is going to go
into standard output which is of course
going to devnet so this should give us
absolutely no results and sure enough
both standard output and standard error
have gone into devnet alright so that's
just a really cool thing that you can do
with redirection and then devnet is just
a place that never fills up all right
let's clear the screen i want to show
you so here i have a couple files or one
file let's look and see what's in there
all right just a bunch of different
words in the text file so what we can do
is say
cat file.txt i'm going to pipe my
standard output into t's standard input
and then i'm going to call it copy.txt
and now we should see the contents of
file.txt sure enough it printed to the
screen but then the t command also
created that copy.txt that also contains
this so if we look sure enough there's a
copy of our stuff and then last i'm
going to show you x args and it's hard
to come up with a real good example but
i think i have one all right what we
want to do is i want to create a folder
named everything in this file so i want
to have a folder named red named yellow
named blue and name tuna fish well it
turns out to be kind of difficult to do
that but we can do it really simply if
we say
catfile.txt
pipe that into x-args
and then
args is going to mkdir and then it will
put the standard output of this command
and kind of like plunk it right there so
if we press enter
and we do ls look at that we have a
folder with each one of those names
which is really convenient right it was
able to do like what would have taken us
quite a bit of typing to do it just did
it by piping it and then it kind of
pastes the results right at the end of
whatever command you tell it now we
could also do something cool if i want
to clean up my mess instead of mkdir i'm
going to say rm dir
and then they're gone
standard input standard output standard
error they're really cool things and
there are some additional tips and
tricks that make using them even more
usable and more beneficial on the
command line
dealing with text on the command line is
something that's kind of fun to do to be
quite honest and there are some tools
that are pretty nifty to play with so
let's look at a couple of them right now
we'll just go right to the command line
now i've already set us up with a few
files i file one and file two so let's
look at them just so we know what's in
them that's what's in file one
and that's what's in file two just a
list of words so i wanna show you a few
things now you'll notice that these are
not in alphabetical order okay so we
could use the sort command so i could
say sort file1 dot txt and it's going to
return the contents but notice now
they're in alphabetical order chicken
fish monkey turtle so what we could do
is if we wanted to save a file call it
sorted then we could redirect the output
to
sorted.txt
and then if we look at sorted.txt now
it's going to be a file with them in
alphabetical order so sort does just
that and if you look at the commands for
sort like do the man page for sort you
can see that it does some other things
you know you can actually sort with
options like you know do i ignore case
what about numbers what about you know
what if it's a bunch of dates so sort's
very powerful but that's basically what
it does it takes a text file and then it
outputs that text file sorted however
you tell it to do so let's clear this
screen all right the next one i want to
show you is word count it's pretty
simple it's just wc and it stands for
word count so we could do word count of
file1.txt and it'll give us three fields
it says 4 4 and 27 in our case what this
means is it means there are four words
there are four lines and there are 27
characters now if we just want to know
one of those things we could just say wc
minus m for character count
file1.txt and it's just going to show us
that there are 27 characters in
file1.txt now the last two i want to
show you are really the most interesting
so there's cut and paste which i know
sounds like a gooey thing but let's
actually look at our file again just so
we know exactly what we're dealing with
so file1.txt
this is what we have these lines if we
were to use the cut command we could say
cut i'm going to do cut by characters
and i want it to cut out character oh
let's just say 1
from
file1.txt if we do that we should see
just the first
oh i did file two my goodness i'm like
those aren't the first letters at all
so let's look at file one that dxd that
makes more sense so the c in chicken the
f and fish teen turtle m in monkey okay
so we have those uh we could do more
than just one character and we could do
more than just the first character let's
say we wanted to do cut minus c
the third fourth and fifth character in
the file file one dot txt so now we
should see
[Music]
and what it did is it took the third
fourth and fifth character but you see
fish only has four characters so there
is no fifth character so it just did sh
for the fish line all right but see
that's that's what cut does it'll
actually take it right out of the middle
of the file which is surprisingly
difficult to do if you don't actually
use the cut command and paste does kind
of the exact opposite so let me clear
the screen because it's kind of full and
i want to show again file 1 and file 2.
now let's say we wanted to put this file
file 2
after file 1. right we wanted to say
chicken lips fish whiskers turtle
feathers and monkey flippers well that's
kind of difficult to do if we cap them
together it's just going to put one at
the end of the other so that's where
paste comes into play we can say paste
file1.txt
file2.txt and it's going to output
sure enough it put a tab between them
and then we have chicken lips fish
whiskers if we wanted to do this and
redirect it into a file
and then we look at join.txt look at
that our file now has those two pasted
together now i know that most of what we
did using these commands was really just
playing around but really playing around
is one of the best ways to learn to use
a tool and you're going to find that
every once in a while one of these tools
like cutter paste especially are going
to be extremely useful because it's kind
of hard to put things next to each other
in a text file or cut out the middle
bits of a text file without using simple
tools like this
awk and said are text manipulation tools
that for some reason most people are
afraid of and i honestly don't know why
yes they can be very complicated you can
do a lot of powerful things but you
don't have to you can do some very
simple yet still powerful things with
awk and said now what do they stand for
said just stands for stream editor and
awk i actually had to google this
because i had no idea i mean i've been
using awk for decades but i didn't
really know what it stood for it turns
out it's the initials of the people who
first wrote it and i'm not going to try
to pronounce them all but that's what
the a the w and the k mean basically awk
is a data extraction tool it allows you
to pull out certain bits of data from
text and set of course is just a stream
editor which allows you to edit things
without interacting with it directly so
let's actually go to the command line so
we can see it work now i've already
prepared a couple files so if we do ls
we're going to see we have file 1 file 2
and join so let's just look at them this
is file 1 this is file 2
and this is basically the two of them
joined together i actually use the paste
command to do that so i have these three
files and i'm going to use said and awk
to do things with these files okay so
first of all said is a stream editor
which means you can put files in and
you'll it'll output the edited version
and how it works i'm just going to cat
one of these files so cat file1.txt
and i'm going to pipe that into
said for stream editor and here's where
i'm going to set up the rules i'm going
to substitute so i'm going to say s and
then forward slash what i want to search
for is the word monkey and a forward
slash what i want to replace it with i'm
going to say dolphin and then a forward
slash ng for global that just means that
if it occurs more than one time i want
every occurrence of monkey to be
substituted with dolphin and then i'm
just going to press enter and what we
get is chicken fish turtle dolphin
because it took this initial file and it
substituted monkey for dolphin and
really that's what said does it's a
stream editor it allows you to edit
things as it flies through there so you
can make changes to text as it's being
manipulated so you can put this inside
of a script and do things without
interacting on a like a a gui like you'd
want to open it up with vi and edit it
out and change monkey to dolphin or
anything like that so that's what stream
editor or said does now i'm going to
clear the screen
and we're just going to look at joint
i'm going to say cat join just so we can
see it now awk takes a text file and it
will allow you to pull out bits and do
things with them so i'm just going to
type this out and then we'll see what
i'm talking about so i'm going to say
awk and i'm going to put single quotes
open curly braces print
dollar sign 1 close curly braces close
single things and i'm going to use
joined.txt as the file so what this is
saying now this is maybe why people are
scared there's a bit of an odd syntax
here but we say awk and then this is
what we want awk to do with the file i
want it to print out the first field now
it will auto detect that these fields
are separated by a tab they could just
be spaces and it'll auto detect it but
basically this is on line one this is
field one field two line two it's field
one field two so this should print out
the first field of every line so let's
press enter and sure enough chicken fish
turtle monkey it printed them all out
now we can do more than just one thing
at a time so let's go back over here
what if we wanted to do dollar sign two
dollar sign one now we should get a
printout of whiskers fish and and
flippers monkey and let's see what what
turns out here now it is gonna be a
little hard to read and i'll show you
why see it did do that right here we had
chicken lips and it gave us lips chicken
whisker fish feathers turtle flippers
monkey now the problem is it took those
fields and just mushed them right
together so we could add another thing
in there we could kind of build this out
longer and we could say i also want
a space in there so hopefully that makes
sense it's going to print field 2 and
then it's going to print this space and
then it's going to print field 1. so
let's see if that's what we get sure
enough lips chicken whisker fish feather
turtle flippers monkey and it doesn't
have to be used just one time right we
could do this we could say i want dollar
sign two dollar sign two which means
field two field two and now we should
get a duplicate of each one lip slips
whiskers whiskers so awk just takes bits
of data and allows you to manipulate
them and do what you want with them
honestly the only thing i could think is
that the syntax for awk and said
intimidate people but once you get used
to doing it and especially with stream
editor the syntax is very similar to the
vi editor when it comes to replacing and
substituting things in a text file so
hopefully you get used to them and
you're not afraid of them because
they're super powerful and awesome tools
to use especially in scripts because
there's no interaction required you can
put them right inside of a script and
they work without you entering more data
hard links and soft links or symbolic
links as a lot of people call them are
very similar in what you get on the file
system as far as usability goes but they
work drastically differently so let me
explain the difference between them so
when we have a hard drive we basically
have every file that takes up a certain
number of sectors on the hard drive
itself so this one let's say takes up
three blocks this one takes up four
blocks this one takes up seven blocks
and these are the actual
files on the hard drive but the file
system actually only knows where those
files live because of the file
allocation table so this is kind of like
a table of contents right it says okay
file one is actually right here and it
extends three blocks this one i'll say
okay file two
this actually lives right here on the
hard drive and it extends four blocks
and then the same thing here file three
and you know it extends all the blocks
here and so on and so forth for all of
the other files on the system now there
is a difference though let's say this is
a symbolic link okay a symbolic link
doesn't point to the hard drive at all
it actually just points to a file in the
file allocation table so this is a
standard
you know table of contents link right
this is pointing to
this spot and these blocks on the hard
drive but the symbolic link just points
to filename.txt
on this system itself now there's the
other kind of link and that's a hard
link so you probably notice there's
another purple file here so let's say
this is file two and it's pointing to
you know these four blocks
this could be like file 12 and it points
to the exact same
spots on the hard drive so it points to
the exact same file location and the
same number of blocks it's basically the
exact same file but it has two different
reference points in the file allocation
table that can be really confusing but
what's cool about it is let's say you
accidentally delete this file well
that's okay it's still on the hard drive
and you can still reference it from this
file here so let me show you what that
looks like in practice in our system
here we have let's do an ls minus l we
have myfile.doc now if we wanted to do a
symbolic link we would do
ln minus s for soft or symbolic the
source is my file and the destination is
going to be
my
linked file.doc
do ls minus l and we're going to see it
actually shows us exactly what's
happening my linked file dot doc is just
pointing to the name myfile.doc
in fact it's just pointing to this name
itself so if we were to say move my
file.doc to my
new file dot doc and then we do an ls
minus l this link is broken because it
still points to the name my file.doc and
that doesn't exist anymore so this is
now a broken link on our system so
symbolic links are kind of dumb they
don't take up much space but they're
kind of dumb in that they don't follow a
file if you move it or rename it all
right so that is a soft link now a hard
link works differently a hard link if we
were just to say ln without any flags
my new file dot dock to my file dot
doc and then we do ls minus l well one
we've fixed the symbolic link right
because now this file points to a file
that exists now so all of a sudden now
it's pointing to this file my file.doc
and you'll notice it's the same size as
the other one and if we were to move the
original so we're going to say
move my
new file to
my cool file dot doc
it doesn't break the hard link that we
made both of them are still there
they're still fine they're their own
independent file name in the file
allocation table they just happen to
point to the same spot on the hard drive
and we can see that if we do ls minus li
for inodes it's going to show us the
spot on the hard drive that it's
actually pointing to and sure enough
these have a matching inode whereas this
symbolic link has a completely different
inode because it's you know just a file
that only points to a file name but
these two have the exact same spot on
the physical hard drive now another cool
thing this number here which you've
probably never even thought about before
but this says how many linked files
are on this inode now this says there
are three now of course we see two right
here but that means somewhere on my file
system there's another hard link to this
inode now i did actually make it before
we started so we could use the find
command to find that i'm going to say
find
i'm going to look in my home directory
in the same file flag and i want to find
the same file as
my file.doc or it could say
mycoolfile.doc because these are the
same files so it doesn't matter which
one i have find look for a match for and
press enter and it's going to find all
three of them
sure enough i have a hidden file right
here that i that i did earlier before
the nugget started and this is just one
more hard linked file to this same
inode we could look really quick ls
minus li
l i a so we can see the hidden files and
sure enough hidden file there's that
same inode reference that the other ones
are referencing now honestly soft links
are generally used more because they're
easy to see you can do an ls and see
where they're pointing to so they're a
lot more convenient but hard links do
have their place because each file acts
as an independent file you can delete
one and it doesn't ruin the reference
that the other one has so hard links
point to inodes soft links just point to
file name references of other files on
the existing file system
when you're trying to figure out the
location of files on your system there's
basically two ways you can do it there's
the find command and the locate command
and both do pretty much the same thing
but find is quite a bit more powerful
yet has some limitations over locate i'm
going to just show you how they work
because trying to explain the pros and
cons just seems a little bit silly when
we can just actually see how it works in
action now if we look in our documents
folder i have a few files here i have
new paper and it looks like it has camel
caps here capital n capital p old file
and research paper dot doc so let's
actually use the locate command first
because it's simple so we say locate and
then what we want to look for and it can
just be a substring so if we say old
file and press enter it's going to give
us the full path of old file.txt notice
i didn't have to search for the entire
file name i just searched for old
file.txt
or old file and it found old file.txt
now we can do the same for let's see
locate research underscore and it should
find research paper and sure enough
research paper now there was one more
file in there if we type locate
new
paper
no it doesn't find it oh did i spell it
wrong well let's look over here new
paper no i did not spell it wrong and
that's where the limitation of locate is
locate uses a database that is cached on
your system which means it's super duper
fast for searching for the names of
files however the cache is only created
once a day now we can force an update we
could say sudo
update db press enter and it's going to
update the database of all the file
names on the system and now if we just
do up arrow and locate new paper now
it's going to find it because we updated
the cache of all the files on the system
so it's very very fast but it has that
limitation that it uses cached data now
the find command is more powerful but it
has the limitation that because it
searches in real time it's a lot slower
so how does it work pretty much the same
way we're going to say find
and you tell it where you want it to
search so we can say search the root
directory
and now rather than just a file name
find does a lot more things so we're
going to say i want you to search for a
file
named
let's say star
new paper star and this should find all
of the files that have new paper in them
okay so i'm going to press enter
and oh my goodness what is all this
permission denied well find actually
goes through the entire file system
because i said search in the root
directory and i actually don't have
permission to look at all of these
things so it's going to search through
every single folder on the whole system
and let's see did it actually find the
file it should have but we have to look
through all the error messages and if we
scroll up sure enough it did find it all
right it did find it just like the
locate command but there were a lot of
permission denied errors now we could do
something like redirect the error right
we could say two greater than dev null
which will just pipe the errors into our
dev null bit bucket and sure enough
there it found it was pretty quick but
it wasn't as quick as using locate now
there are some other really cool things
that find can do we can say find in our
current home directory and what that'll
do is it will allow us to search in just
this home directory so it doesn't search
the entire file system so that can be
pretty convenient so if we say find dot
and we're gonna look for the name new
p
oh i didn't do the stars
new p
it should find it for us sure enough it
did find documents new paper and then it
does this other thing we can actually
say dash
delete
and it will delete it and how can we see
if it's deleted
if we look in the documents folder whoa
it deleted that file so find does more
than just locate files however it has
some finicky things like this it's going
to be using regular expressions to
search for the files and while it's more
powerful it's slower and it can be
annoying when we do things like get
errors from permission denied things
like that so while conceptually find and
locate do the same thing they do them in
different ways the important thing to
remember about locate is that it's
always going to use old data unless you
run that update db command now find is
much more powerful but it works in real
time so it's slower and there that means
that there are pros and cons to using
both tools
while it's certainly possible to set up
network shares for copying files from
one server to another generally if
you're going to copy files over the
network from linux server to linux
server you're going to use either ssh or
really scp which stands for secure copy
but it uses the ssh protocol in order to
do that copying or rsync which actually
will sync a whole bunch of files across
the network so we're going to look at
doing both but it's important to realize
that ssh is the same program and the
same protocol that we use to connect
from one computer to another to reach
its terminal so let me show you what i
mean now i have two computers set up in
our lab i have this ubuntu computer and
i have this sent os computer they're
both on the same network so i'm going to
ssh from one to another i'm going to say
ssh to centos it's going to ask me for
bob's password on centos
and then all of a sudden now i'm logged
in to that remote computer sent to us in
fact if we go into the desktop folder
and we do an ls we're going to see over
on sent to us we have things called like
cool picture cool pic 2 and these things
are on the remote desktop all right i'm
going to exit and that's going to bring
me back to ubuntu now if we look on the
desktop folder we're going to see
there's nothing in there because on our
local ubuntu computer we don't have
those things let's say we wanted to copy
something over well let's go into our
desktop folder again there's nothing
here nothing up our sleeve we could use
scp
which is secure copy and this uses ssh
right so we would say scp from
centos now we could also specify a
different user now it's the same user
for us but i'm still going to specify
i'm going to say bob at centos
colon then the remote path which is
going to be home
bob
desktop and let's pick one of these
files i'm going to say cool picture cool
picture.jpg and i want it to copy it to
dot which means our current directory
i'm going to press enter it's going to
say okay what is bob's password bob and
now if we do an ls we're going to say
look we have cool picture that was
copied over the network using scp which
uses the ssh protocol and it was copied
over and now we have a copy of it here
locally we can do the same thing we
could say scp a local thing and rather
than the destination be our local
computer we could do it backwards right
we could say
scp
coolpicture.jpg to bob at centos
home bob i'm going to copy it just to
his home folder and so now it's sent one
over to bob's home folder now we could
copy everything all at once if we wanted
by using the rsync command now rsync is
pretty cool in that it will even recurse
directories if we wanted to so we could
actually do this we could say rsync i'm
going to say minus a so it does all the
things including recursively going into
directories i'm going to say v so it
does it verbosely so we can see what
it's doing so rsync dash av and the
remote thing is set up just like with
scp so bob at
centos or we don't have to say bob add
if it's the same username we could just
say centos
colon and then the path so i want home
bob desktop i want that entire folder
copied to here so what we should end up
with is a new folder inside our ubuntu
desktop folder called desktop because
it's going to copy this folder to our
current thing and it's going to have
recursively everything in the remote
desktop folder let's see if that works
press enter it's going to say what is
bob's password bob
and so now it says receiving all of
these files and look sure enough there's
a folder called desktop if we were to
look inside there now i look all those
files that were on that remote computer
are now on our local computer as well we
used rsync and it will transverse all of
the directories recursively and it will
copy it over for us now this might seem
like a throwaway nugget something that
is just nice to know but you're not
going to use i'll be honest i use scp
and rsync almost every single day
copying files back and forth using scp
is so easy and so fast you don't have to
set up servers it's just a way to get
one file to another server without
having to worry about installing
anything because it uses ssh which is
already installed on all of your servers
so whether you just want to copy a file
or two with scp or you want to do
recursive directories with rsync it's
really easy to copy files over the
network in linux
pretty much every distribution out there
uses system d to manage the services
like the various programs that are
installed like web servers and stuff on
their system and system ctl is the
command line tool that we use to
manipulate and manage those services now
there's a couple concepts we need to
understand we need to know enable and
disable versus start and stop enable and
disable is basically talking about when
the computer boots up will it
automatically start
the service and so you can have
something that you can start and stop
but that doesn't mean it's automatically
going to start or stop when the system
boots up that's where the enable and
disable comes into play now it's really
really easy to tell what a service is
doing by default and we can change it
without much more difficulty at all so
i'm at a computer right now and i've
installed apache 2 on this centos
machine so httpd is the package name and
i've installed it however if we go over
here we can see localhost it's unable to
connect it's not running so the first
thing we would do is say systemctl
status httpd and it's actually giving us
more information than it first appears
see it's telling us that it's actually
inactive which makes sense because we
can't get it to load but more
importantly it's saying that the service
itself is disabled and the vendor preset
meaning like when you first install it
it's set to disabled so we can change
that because if it's disabled it means
it's not going to start when the
computer boots so even if we rebooted
this computer it still wouldn't load
because it wouldn't start by default so
we can say system ctl
enable httpd
and press enter and now if we do that
status we're going to see that it's
changed okay it says it's enabled even
though the vendor preset is still
disabled this means that you know when
we installed it it was disabled but
we've changed it now so it's enabled but
you'll notice
it's still inactive or dead now if we
did restart the computer it would
automatically start up but we can start
and stop it independently from whether
it's enabled or disabled as not we can
just say system cto start httpd and it's
going to start our service we can look
at status httpd and we can see sure
enough now that it's active right it's
running and it's still enabled so when
we reboot it's going to start running
automatically now even if we left this
disabled we could still have started it
using the start command however when the
computer rebooted it wouldn't start
automatically so if you want it to
always start up you have to make sure
that it's enabled even if it comes
disabled by default just a quick look
boom it's running and sure enough it's
right there running for us and it will
run when the computer reboots because
we've changed it to enabled i really
like systemd because systemctl is kind
of the one-stop shop it's like the swiss
army knife for managing services on a
computer that's controlled with the
systemd startup init service
sys5 or sysv or system five it's called
a lot of different things but this is an
older way that linux systems would put
themselves in various modes or run
levels that determine the type of system
whether it's a gui system whether it's
just a standalone network system and we
can switch those various modes we can
set defaults to those modes but it's
important to understand what the modes
actually are and there's a whole list of
them unfortunately the modes are
different in debian
and centos or debbie and ubuntu centos
souza they actually use the various
levels differently so i just want to
briefly go over the difference so that
if you're on one system you kind of
understand what's going on so centos
actually separates them the most so
let's go here first we have run level
zero and run level zero is basically if
you go into this mode it halts the
system this is like a way to power the
system down run level one is single user
mode there's no networking or anything
and there's no asking for the root
password this is the way that you would
recover a root password on a sys5
computer mode 2 is multi-user with no
network 3 is multi-user with network 4
is not used at all with centos and 5 is
the multi-user gui system like if you
have x windows installed and then lastly
run level six is reboot if you switch
into run level six it will then reboot
your computer and it will go into
whichever default is set now debian
ubuntu are similar
halt is the same reboot is the same
single user mode is the same the
difference is here
two run level two is the full multi-user
system just like run level three is here
and then if there's a gui installed on
the system the gui will start up there's
no difference in debian ubuntu between
having a gui system and having a not gui
system when it comes to run levels
that's only if the gui is installed so
run level 2 is pretty much what we use
all the time when we're in debian and
ubuntu run levels three through five
don't do anything at all they're just
not used so that's the big big
difference between the two we still have
reboot we still have halt we still have
single user mode but it's how they
handle the other things that are a
little bit different now switching
between them and setting the defaults
are exactly the same now here's the
gotcha it took me a long time to find a
system that still uses sys5. this is
outmoded and not used in any modern
distributions but if you go if you find
one that is still in use like this is
centos version six it will still use it
so what we can do we can say run level
and it will show us what run level we're
in we're in run level five
and the previous run level we're in was
just a new boot okay now if we want to
switch between run levels we can say
tell init and then the run level we want
to switch to so i'm going to say 3. this
should drop us out of a gui
and into a text only environment you can
see here there's no gui there's just
this text box right here so i'm going to
log in so we can go back if i want to go
back into the gui system i can say tell
init 5 and it'll get us right back into
the gui system and here we are in the
gui system if i start up
a terminal and we say run level we're
gonna see we're currently in run level
five our previous run level was three
now if we switch into run level six it's
going to reboot if we switch into run
level zero it's going to just halt the
computer and power it down if you want
to change the default and the default is
just what run level it automatically
boots into we need to edit a file so i'm
going to become root and we need to edit
etc init
tab
and this file has a couple things we can
edit but really the main thing is all
the way down at the bottom which is the
default run level now it gives us a
little bit of a cheat sheet here and
this is actually really really good
advice
the halt mode run level 0 do not set
your init default to this because it'll
boot up and immediately halt and that's
not what we want same thing with setting
it to run level 6. it will boot up and
switch immediately into run level 6
which is reboot so it's going to be in a
constant reboot loop so you never want
to set the default to that ours is
currently in
run level five for the default and it's
right here now we could change that to
three
save this file and now when we reboot
the computer it's just going to
automatically go into the text only mode
i'll just show you really quick what
happens if we
telling it into run level six
it's going to reboot that's what it does
so if you run across an older system
that uses run levels specifically system
five run levels you need to know what
the various modes do and remember it's
going to be different whether it's
ubuntu ubuntu and debian or centos and
red hat and then you need to know how to
switch the modes using telonit and how
to set those defaults and most
importantly what not to set the defaults
to namely run level 0 or run level 6.
i often find myself on a system thinking
what if i need to switch between modes
like i have a gui machine that i want to
get rid of that gui interface so it's
just a server with the text mode or vice
versa well switching modes and setting
the defaults is done one way with the
sys5 system but if you have a newer
system d
initialization system it can be very
very confusing especially if you have
that cis 5 background thankfully there
are pretty simple comparisons when it
comes to how it used to be and how it
currently is now if you're not familiar
with init 5 or with sys5 init that's all
right we're just going to talk about
what the various modes are basically we
start with run level zero which has a
correlation in the system d world as a
boot target called power off now boot
targets are basically just modes right
these are modes that computers are are
set to so that they can function in a
specific way and while it doesn't seem
like a mode it's a really easy way to
shut your computer down by switching
into the power off mode now there's also
one this is single user mode in the
world of systemd it's called rescue mode
this is like insist five if you want to
like reset your root password you need
to switch into single user mode well
same thing with a boot target it's just
called rescue mode then there's mode
three which in a centos system is going
to be like a non-graphical user
interface with networking support that
translates to just multi-user target in
system d uh the gui mode 5 translates to
graphical target and of course 6 is like
the the compatriot to run level zero and
this is how you can reboot your system
by switching into run level six or boot
target reboot now switching between them
is actually easier than it is with the
old sys5 you can actually just use a
command line tool instead of editing
that init tab file that you have to do
with sys5 now i'm on centos version 7
here because centos version 7 uses
system d whereas centos version 6 uses
sys5. now the first thing you need to do
is be root so i'm going to quickly
become root once we're root we can type
system ctl which is the way we do most
things with system d but system ctl get
default and this is going to tell us
what the default mode is and that makes
sense because our default mode here is
graphical target and you can see we have
a gui interface now we could change that
we could say system ctl
set
default to multi-user.target
and see now it's changed that so if we
say get default it's going to tell us
okay now it's multi-user but notice it
didn't change we're still in the gui
environment well that's because it just
changed the default if we were to reboot
this computer it would reboot into a
text only mode now if you want to switch
between modes or between targets with a
computer that's already started you
simply type system
ctl
isolate and then the name of the target
in our case let's say isolate
multi-user and it should drop us
directly into sure enough the text only
mode now if you're already used to the
world of run levels you just have to
kind of think what the different targets
that correspond to it are but if you're
not familiar with run levels like this
is something that happened before your
time in linux that's okay because
honestly boot targets make a heck of a
lot more sense than the run levels did
because they actually have their
description right in their names and
while it's important to understand both
sys5 and system d you should know that
all systems going forward are going to
be system d so you're gonna have to know
about the various modes how to switch
between them using isolate and then how
to set and get the default so you know
what happens to a system when it boots
up so you don't have your rack servers
booting up to a gui environment because
that just doesn't make any sense
services are the various programs that
are installed on a server that are going
to run and serve out like web pages or
whatever you might have installed
they're called services and if you have
sys5 on your computer the way that you
manage and start and set defaults for
those individual services are by using
specific programs in the et cetera
init.d
folder now there are tools that we can
use to manage those specifically service
and check config and i want to show you
how they work because the services are
determined
to start and stop based on the run level
of a particular what the computer is set
to so if like it's run level three a
certain system might start and if it's
run level five
another service might not start let me
show you what i'm talking about here on
our system this is centos 6 which has
sys5 if we look in etc.d
these are all the various services or
programs that are installed on the
computer we can see things you know like
post fixes the email server sshd is our
ssh server and we can start and stop
these by using the service command so i
can say service
sshd
start
and it's going to start the service i
can say service sshd
stop and it will stop the service i can
actually do status to see what it's
currently doing so right now it's
currently stopped it says but what i
want to do is change how it starts or
stops on system boot and what we can do
is say chk config
dash dash list sshd and it's going to
show us what sshd is going to do on
every run level so run level zero it's
off one it's off two it's off three it's
off four it's off five it's off and six
it's off so this means it is not going
to start up on system boot regardless of
what run level the system is starting at
now we can set it so that it will start
for all of the run levels one through
five it's never going to start
automatically for zero or for six
because those are
those are halt and reboot and that would
just be silly but if we wanted to start
on all of them we can just say chk
config
sshd on and it's going to set them to on
for all of the run levels and we can do
that list command again and we're going
to see now it's on four two three four
and five actually it doesn't do it for
single user mode so if we just say on
it's going to set it for run level two
three four and five it's going to be
turned on but we can do it individually
too so first of all let's turn it back
off so now they're all set to off if we
look see they're all off again we can do
a single one so we could say chk config
dash dash level
3 on
and now if we look it's just gonna be on
for level oop
gotta get the format right sshd on
and now if we look there now let's turn
it on for run level three but the other
ones are still off so chk config is the
way that we change how it boots up
whereas the service command up here is
how we change it immediately if we
wanted to start or stop we can use the
service command but if we wanted to
start on boot we need to use the chk
config command because that's going to
change the behavior at the various run
levels thankfully when you install
packages they create their own entries
in the et cetera init.d folder we don't
need to make scripts or anything in
there and the programs install things in
there so that the service and the chk
config commands know exactly what to do
in order to start and stop or configure
what happens on boot with a given system
that's running sys5
modern linux systems use system d to
manage their services things like their
web server their ssh server and the same
tool is used to start them stop them
enable them on boot and that's that
swiss army knife that catch all tool for
system d
system ctl so i want to show you how to
go about starting and stopping
individual services but also how to
affect what happens on boot when a
system boots up what happens with
particular services but first there is
one thing that can be frustrating about
system d and that is that the service
files can be scattered all over the hard
drive so for example inside etc systemd
system we're going to find a couple
service files like anything that ends in
dot service is going to be a system d
service file but you'll notice like
there's no ssh here well that's
frustrating well let's actually search
for that say locate
sshd.service you'll find that this is
actually located in user lib systemd
system that's where
sshd.servicelive so there's several
places that you can find the service
files whereas with sys5 it was always in
the etc.d folder here there are several
folders that are going to house system
files that are service files for your
system so that can be frustrating but
nonetheless we regardless of where
they're stored we can still use
systemctl to query them so we can say
for example systemctl
sshd let's do a status
and this is another got you if you're
going from sys5 right into system d the
frustrating thing is normally we would
say like service sshd status well now
it's backwards now we have to say
system ctl
status sshd ger it's frustrating but you
get used to it unless you go back and
forth from systems then it can be a
little bit frustrating but nonetheless
on systemd we have to say status or
start or stop and then the service name
whereas it's backwards with sys5 anyway
we have a lot of information here so we
can see that it's active which means
it's running so it's currently started
there's more information here though if
we look up here it says it's loaded it's
enabled and enabled in systemd world
means that it's going to start on system
boot and there's even some more
information here it says vendor preset
is enabled now what that means is when
we install the sshd daemon it's going to
automatically be enabled now that
doesn't mean it's going to start unless
we restart the system but it means that
it's going to be set to start on the
system boot that's what the vendor
preset is now we can change this easily
we can say
system
ctl disable sshd and now if we go back
and say status sshd we're going to see
now it's disabled and the vendor preset
is still enabled but we've changed it
now so that it's not going to start on
boot however this is another important
thing to note it's still running because
we've changed what happens on boot but
we haven't changed what's currently
happening on the system so if we reboot
it's not going to be running but if we
want it to not run we actually have to
tell it that so we have to say systemctl
stop sshd
and now if we were to say status now we
would see it's no longer running it's
inactive and it's not going to start on
system boot but let's change that
because we definitely wanted to start on
system boot so system ctl will start it
up
sshd and system ctl
enable sshd and now if we do systemctl
again this is a catch-all tool
status sshd we're going to see it's back
to how it should be it's running and
it's enabled which means it's going to
start on boot
so regardless of what service we want to
start stop or enable or disable that
system ctl tool is what we use for just
about everything in the world of system
d really the only gotcha with going from
sysv to system d when it comes to
services you have to remember to use the
systemctl tool and then you have to
remember that the actual command goes
before the name of the service and
that's backwards from sys5. so we have
to say like systemctl start sshd whereas
with sys5 it was backwards but it's easy
to get used to and i love having a
one-stop tool to do all of the things
that when we're planning servers on our
network it's important to know that
servers serve things they serve things
like ntp which is a network time
protocol ssh a secure shell so you can
get into the computer remotely dns is
domain name service which translates
things like cbtnuggets.com into an ip
address dhcp hands out ip addresses on a
local network so you don't have to
manually assign them a docker is a
containerization system that allows you
to run services in siloed environments
and then of course configuration
management tools allow you to centralize
the individual configuration of servers
so there's basically several kinds of
services that we're going to install in
our networks we have centralized things
which are going to run on like one
server for your entire network and then
individual which are going to run on all
or most of your servers so here we have
things like i mentioned before dhcp dns
configuration management server these
are going to run on one server on your
network you don't need more than one
dhcp server more than one dns server
apart from redundancy or high
availability but generally speaking you
only need this in one place
individual computers all have to have an
ssh server installed because you want to
get into every server on your network
right this is just something that's
going to be installed everywhere your
configuration management client is going
to be installed on every computer it's a
service that needs to be there so that
it can take advantage of the
configuration management system like
chef or puppet or ansible so that it can
you know work together to keep those
servers in line docker is a
containerization program that runs on an
individual server and if you're gonna
have a lot of different servers out
there you may have docker installed on
multiple computers so that it can host
services for you now ntp is kind of the
in the junction point of my venn diagram
here and that's because ntp or network
time protocol is the service that keeps
your computer in the proper time like
you know if you have some clock skew
where it's a little bit too fast or a
little bit too slow ntp will keep your
server running in the proper time now
there is a centralized ntp server very
often on your network and all of the
other computers or servers on your
network will then query your centralized
ntp server but here's the deal this same
ntp server software is actually the
client software as well so ntp does two
things one it queries an above computer
for the time you know in the case of the
centralized one it's in the cloud and it
also can serve out that time information
to its peers or to people on your local
network so usually we have a centralized
ntp server but we don't even have to
right all of these ntp server machines
could query right out to the cloud and
bypass a centralized ntp server it's
just nice to have a centralized place
that you have one time frame that your
entire network is based on but it's the
same server program so that's why i kind
of put it in both camps here as
individual and centralized now when
you're setting up your servers on your
network it's important to think through
how it should work and it's actually
gone through this change as computer
hardware and technology has progressed
there used to be a time where you would
have a bare metal server for every
service on your network if you had a dns
server it would literally be a physical
server sitting in your server closet and
it would sit right next to your dhcp
server whose sole purpose was to serve
out dhcp same with ntp or you know a web
server but then we said you know what
now computers are getting to be so fast
that we could put multiple services on a
single computer because the problem here
is it was very expensive right if you
had to buy a physical server for every
service you wanted to do it got
expensive fast so what if we bought a
decent sized server and then we
installed dns software we installed dhcp
software ntp software web software
whatever we wanted to do it would all
run alongside each other and be really
happy
the problem comes what if you need to
run an update on one of these like we
need to take dns offline so we can
update it and maybe restart the server
when we restart the server all of our
services go down because we've put them
all in one basket right all of our eggs
are in one basket it's also a single
point of failure basically it's messy
and then the dawn of virtualization
happened and this is where
server closets got really awesome really
fast that's because we had large
computers you know basically the same
large computer it's not that computer
hardware got all that much faster but
virtualization technology allowed us to
instead of just installing a dns service
software
we could install a virtual server inside
here by taking a slice of the resources
from the bigger server and
install a completely new server
virtualized in there that would run dns
and we could do that alongside another
virtual server and if we had to take
this offline or or restart it it
wouldn't affect the others because they
were their own standalone virtualized
servers it was really really awesome it
still is a very powerful way to go about
protecting your different services from
each other on the network the problem is
and this is something that i've fallen
prey to is sprawl potential it's really
easy to spin up another server oh i want
to do this i'll spin up another server
oh what if we did this sir spin up
another server that's where docker comes
into play and i won't go too much into
docker other than to tell you what
docker does is it takes a server and it
has a single operating system running
linux and then each service has its own
like isolated pocket it doesn't have its
own
operating system it's not like a virtual
machine all it does is have its own
little slice of the running system where
it has its own file system and it can
run its own little service here and it
doesn't affect anything else because
it's walled off so containerization is
an even better way to take better
advantage of server hardware even than
virtualization when it comes to virtual
servers so yes there's a lot to think
about when you're installing servers on
your network and where to put them but
the nice thing is whether it's a local
service that has to be installed on
every computer or a centralized service
that you just install like in one place
for your whole network planning has
gotten a lot easier because you don't
have to worry so much about putting all
of your eggs in one basket we've been
able to isolate individual services
without the need to buy brand new
hardware so planning is kind of fun and
more flexible than it's ever been before
conceptually we pretty much understand
how a web server works you send a
request and the web server sends back
the web page but when you add ssl or tls
it really does add a layer of complexity
but that complexity is for a good reason
because it can secure the traffic so
nobody knows what is going
through your
internet connection like bank account
information and stuff like that so it's
very important that we have ssl
encrypted secured traffic now the
process is going to be a little bit
different than just a standard web page
and part of the thing that you want to
make sure you have if it's like for a
bank or something is a certificate
authority now let me demonstrate exactly
what goes on
when you try to get a web page from a
web server let's say this is our web
server now if you're not talking about
ssl basically the guy in the computer
here says hey i would like to see your
web page and then the computer says okay
here is my web page and that's pretty
much the entire process there's no
encryption at all but when you go to
like your bank's website you're going to
set up an ssl session so that all of
your information that goes back and
forth is encrypted so basically here is
how the process works the client sends a
message to the server
and it says hey i would like to start an
ssl encrypted session with you and then
the web server responds okay
here is my certificate this says who i
am and that i'm valid and look here's a
picture of my kid playing softball maybe
not that bar but it sends a certificate
describing who it is to prove that it's
who the server says it is that it's not
like some man-in-the-middle attack now
the only way the end user knows that
it's real is because he contacts a
certificate authority which is a
centralized trusted place that signs
certificates basically it's this
person's job to contact this web server
and make it prove who it is and then
once it proves who it is it gets its
certificate signed by the certificate
authority so then let's say this guy's
name is bob bob says okay i see that at
the bottom of your certificate it was
signed by somebody who i trust so i'm
going to trust that you're really who
you say you are
so then after that identification has
been verified bob then sends his
encryption key to the web server so the
key is sent from the end user to the
server and then the server uses that key
that bob sent and that is what is used
to encrypt the actual data that is going
to go to bob's computer so the actual
encryption
uses bob's key that he sends to the
server after the server proves who it is
and then they use this tunnel back and
forth and that's how they communicate
using bob's key now if you set up a
server in your own network you've
probably heard of something called a
self-signed certificate now that is
exactly what it sounds like when that
initial request comes from bob and he
says hey server i would like to set up
an ssl connection the server does
respond with a copy of its certificate
it says here i am this is all my
information uh this is the stuff that
you know describes who i am i'm
promising that i am the person i say i
am but there's no signature on the
bottom from the certificate authority
it's something that that the server
signed himself so bob
has to like just trust that this server
is who he says it is now if it's on your
own local network that's usually fine
and it's okay to accept a self-signed
certificate but if it's over the
internet you don't want to accept a
self-signed certificate because there's
no way to be sure that it's actually the
server it says it is and if you trust a
self-signed certificate and it ends up
being like a man in the middle attack
you could be sending all of your banking
data to a server that isn't who it says
it is and that's very dangerous so a
self-signed certificate encrypts the
exact same way the problem is you're not
a hundred percent positive who it is
that initially set up that certificate
so there's a lot of trust involved
whereas if you use a certificate
authority trust is taken out of the
picture because you trust the
certificate authority it's built into
your web browser so the actual ssl
encryption is the same whether it's a
certificate authority or a self-signed
certificate but you don't know if it's
the server it says it is unless you have
that certificate authority that signs
the server certificate that's why it's
very important especially on the
internet to make sure that you don't get
an error about not having a certificate
signed by an authority but the process
is the same either way
it turns out that local network server
roles have changed fairly dramatically
over just the past few years now don't
get me wrong things have come a long way
from when we used to have a sneaker net
so if we had a file we'd have to put it
on a floppy disk and then you know carry
it to the cubicle next to us and pass it
on like that but we don't even use local
servers as much as we used to now what
am i talking about well i'm talking
about the introduction of cloud
computing now let's look at file
services for example we used to have and
then we actually we do still have local
file services that you know if we want
to save files in a local centralized
place we do things whether we're on
windows or linux or mac if we want to
serve to windows computers we can use
the samba program which allows us
through file sharing that is hosted on
linux but is accessible from a windows
machine it's a free way very stable very
scalable that we can actually share
files with windows computers same thing
with nfs which is network file storage
and this is applicable for linux mac
windows and then if you have old school
apples that only use like the apple talk
sort of networking stuff well there's
neta talk which uses the native apple
file sharing but this isn't even used
anymore so much because now macintosh
computers can very easily do windows
shares using samba or nfs but netetalk
is still around if you like that native
apple file sharing stuff the point is
linux computers can do local file
sharing very very well the thing to
think about if you're implementing a
network though is should i and that's
where cloud services come into play
because while sure you can serve things
locally on a file you might want to
consider something like dropbox or
onedrive or google drive that works on
almost every platform and allows you to
not only sync things between computers
but also have an online backup which is
really really vital and it saves a ton
of money if you don't have to buy the
servers to actually store all of your
files if it's stored on a cloud service
that you usually pay a service fee for
you're going to save that money on
maintenance and hardware purchases and
etc etc so think about cloud services
every time you're thinking about local
services there are some cases you'll
want local services but some cases it
just doesn't make any sense and there
are complementary cloud services to
almost every one of our local services
that we can offer i want to mention the
ways that you can serve them locally
because it does make sense sometimes for
example a print server is going to be
cups common unix printing system this
works across the board if you're sharing
a printer with mac or linux it's going
to be using cups and even windows can
print to cups servers it's like a
centralized place but honestly most
printers now pretty much have a robust
ability to share and queue jobs on their
own so we don't always have to use a
centralized cup server we can all print
to the same printer and it's just
handled well netatalk also has printing
if you have an old school apple computer
you want to use that for but again
that's not even used very much anymore
how could your local printer be used
with cloud services well it doesn't make
sense until you think about
no configuration printing right with
google print or airprint these are ways
that you can actually send your print
job over the internet to a printer that
may or may not be connected directly so
it's something that isn't going to
replace common everyday office printing
but it's something to think about if you
want to be able to configure or
especially print from mobile devices
having cloud solutions is very powerful
now mail is a special case because a lot
of times we want mail to be as secure as
possible and that means we don't
necessarily want to give the ability to
another company to host our mail but
remember with great power comes great
responsibility
keeping your locally hosted email files
whether it's using postfix or xm or send
mail can be a full time job because we
want those to be really secure not only
so people can't read our emails but so
our servers aren't compromised and used
to send out spam to the entire world so
even though having that fine control
over security of your own mail is
important
think about how nice it is if a huge
company like google or microsoft or
yahoo would have to worry about the
security aspect so you can actually just
focus on communicating with it so
there's a lot to be said about using a
third-party company for email even
though you do lose some of that local
control and then lastly i want to talk
about a proxy now when we talk about
proxies in linux we're talking about
squid or squid guard which is an add-on
to squid and generally proxies have
historically taken the load off of your
internet connection so a bunch of
computers can actually request things
one time from the cloud and then the
proxy server kind of takes that and
distributes it internally but our
internet connections are very powerful
now so we don't often do that now when
we're thinking about proxy a lot of
people mistakenly call a web filter a
proxy and what a web filter does is it
stops you from going to like
pornographic websites and that's what
squid guard does there's a lot of
commercial products that keep a list of
sites that shouldn't be visited by
people and there are other solutions too
like open dns is a way that you can set
your dns server your upstream dns server
so that it doesn't resolve sites that
you don't want to see like pornographic
websites they won't even resolve
properly so your users can't get there
now when it comes to actually caching or
proxying large things there are some big
companies like akamai that will cache
entire video libraries of like netflix
and stuff because that's a way that they
can save bandwidth between isps but in
general we don't use proxies as much as
we used to although there are still a
lot of use cases for things like squid
guard or open dns for blocking unwanted
websites that are going to waste time or
expose us to things that you know we may
not want to be exposed to in the company
or in a school so while it's really
important to know that there are local
services that you can provide on your
network using linux i encourage you to
think through before you install a
server on your network to do a
particular task see if it really makes
sense to host that locally or if going
for a third party service might make
more sense
authentication services and database
services are both things that we often
do on local computers i want to talk
about their purpose and their importance
but it also might seem a little weird
that i group them together and that's
because we usually think about
authentication and databases as local
services that run on robust servers and
that's for a reason it's because they're
very very important to what we do on a
regular basis and i just want to talk
about while we oftentimes still run them
on local computers there's still an
argument to be made for putting those in
the cloud as well now generally if
you're talking about linux you're
thinking about a sql service if you're
thinking traditionally right this could
be my sequel or
maria database which is basically mysql
only newer
postgres there's a whole bunch of other
sql servers that would normally run on a
really robust server on our network now
there are tons of other
database services some of them are you
know are non-sql and and some of them
are good for certain types of data and
bad for other types of data but there
are tons and tons of database services
and generally when we have a database
server it's going to be on its own
computer and that's just because
database servers tend to be kind of
robust so you're going to have something
like mysql maria postgres they're going
to be on their own server and
authentication services are similar as
well because we need to have a central
place to authenticate all of our users
now when you log into like gmail you're
going to put in your username and
password and that's all stored in a
central place on google servers
if you're on your local network there
are tons of ways that you can store user
information on your own local network in
fact for years i would use nis on a
linux server and i would use all of our
computers in the network would
authenticate to this one centralized
server and it was so important that all
user information was stored on there
that i had a redundancy so that
in case one of the servers went bad i
would still have a backup that was live
high availability so there's lots of
ways we can do it but the vital
importance of having our own server or
even multiple servers is important but
here's the deal you'll notice i have all
of these things around the outside you
can use open ldap to host your user
accounts on your network and it's going
to work with a bunch of different
programs but honestly i would say 95 of
the time user data is going to be stored
on an active directory on a windows
computer even if you're a linux person
in a linux shop it seems like ad has
taken the cake as the king when it comes
to user authentication now the one
alternative to that is if you're going
to use an online like saml or i don't
want to get too much into programming
but there are ways that you can leverage
online authentication for your local
stuff like single sign-on and things
like that so that may take the place of
active directory on your network but if
you're if you're talking about user
authentication active directory is
almost certainly going to be where a
medium to large or even small office is
going to host all of their user accounts
so it's important to know that you can
host authentication services on a linux
machine
but you may
not end up doing that because active
directory is probably going to be
somewhere and it's a great place to
centralize your users and your computers
so the whole point of this nugget is
really twofold one authentication can be
done on linux and i did it for over a
decade where everything was hosted on a
local linux machine and i used nis for
authentication i could have used
openldap but generally you're not going
to do that on a big network because you
have more than linux machines that need
to authenticate now the other thing
though is database servers i want you to
know that they're almost always going to
be on their own server because they use
a lot of resources a lot of memory a lot
of cpu a lot of disk io so if you're
setting up server roles on your network
think about a database server as having
its own need unless you host it out on
the cloud in which case you're just
paying for somebody else's resources
which can often be even more effective
centralized logging and monitoring is
great for a big network because it's
easy to lose track of a big number of
servers but honestly it's great even if
you have a tiny little network now i'm
going to look at
combining syslogs but i also want to
peek at
snmp because both are vital for
combining information from multiple
sources centralizing them if you will so
that it's easier to see and easier to
use for making predictions and
adjustments in how your infrastructure
works so first of all i want to talk
about central logging okay now there are
a ton of devices out there a lot of them
can be you know servers you know and
lots of servers on the rack and you
don't want each one to have its own set
of logs you want to combine them but
there's other things now that can create
logs but may not have the storage area
to keep those logs on themselves like
security cameras routers motion
detectors smart bulbs printers all of
these things can create log files and if
you can redirect them
to a centralized server that's going to
allow you to comb through data in a very
efficient way and in fact sometimes this
is the only way you can get data from
certain devices that have absolutely no
storage on them but can generate logs
and information now when you combine
them all together it is pretty neat how
it works the centralized log server is
going to just have one big log file
however each individual device is going
to put its own name in the log file so
you can sort by whatever computer is
adding it so even though you have one
log file that is going to contain
everything it's easy to separate out the
individual devices to see what they're
doing using tools like grep or there are
some really fancy devops tools that will
allow you to sort data from combined log
files
when you combine log files like that you
end up being able to see some trends or
see some relationships that might not
otherwise be easily accessible for
example if none of these devices are
able to access a dns server well maybe
you have some problem with the network
in that portion of your company and so
you can help troubleshoot based on what
logs are being submitted now snmp
is slightly different and it stands for
simple network management protocol but
it's a little bit of a misnomer because
traditionally this was used to not only
read data but also remotely control
devices using this network management
again it was a two-way street protocol
now there are still some instances where
you can use this to manage devices but
mainly it's used for pulling data and
what i mean by that is let's say you
have some data that you'd like to
concatenate together for an informative
data pie that's just delicious you're
trying to make graphs or something you
can use snmp
to pull data from a device one of the
most common things that i use it for is
i have a router that i connect to the
internet with and i would like to see
some interface statistics for what's
going on how much data is going through
it and things like that snmp can pull
that data it's not really like
individual servers pushing data to a
centralized logging it's kind of going
the other way it's kind of using snmp to
pull data from individual devices and
what that looks like in practice here is
this is actually the home page that
every time i load up a web browser this
is what loads up and i have a couple
convenient links for me you know to go
to see the weather in my area that sort
of thing but i have these graphs that
show the bandwidth usage both in my
house in the town and we own a farm as
well that has fiber internet connection
and this shows the connection between
them now you'll notice there's a lot of
matching between the two and that's
because i will often back all of my
townhouse data to our farm because it's
an off-site storage location so that
makes a lot of sense but this is just a
way that i can see what's happening on
my network and i pull this from my
routers using snmp now it's important to
realize that while they accomplish sort
of the same thing centralized logging
allows all of your servers to push data
to a centralized server so you can comb
through all that data in one place
whereas snmp is generally used as a
protocol that you can pull data out of a
server and do something with it like
make cool graphs or whatever it is you
want to do
vpns might be something that you use
every day but don't really understand
what's going on so vpns or virtual
private networks are really just a way
to connect to a private network that
isn't accessible from the internet
itself now talk about the concepts then
i want to talk about what options are
available if you're using linux because
vpn isn't just a one-size-fits-all thing
there are several different protocols
and stuff that you can use to connect
but first of all conceptually what is
going on well we have two networks let's
say these networks are separated by
being in different countries okay now
you want to have this computer be able
to interact with this computer or this
server or something on the remote
network but you don't want to open those
ports up to the internet right because
that's unsafe so what you do is your
router or your linux server or something
will establish what's called a tunnel
and this tunnel is just a layer of
encryption
that goes from one side to the other and
then inside that encrypted tunnel it
just sets up a route like it would any
other route on your network so your
router just sees inside the tunnel and
it sees a route using standard network
addressing like let's say the vpn
internal route is
10.10.0.5 or something and it just sees
this as another route so that this
computer can route information across
the tunnel to this router and then get
into here so it works the same as
traditional routing the only difference
is the router or like i said the linux
server or whatever it is sets up this
tunnel that blocks anybody on the
internet from actually seeing what's
going on in the route so that tunnel is
set up and then the route goes inside
the tunnel so nobody sees the traffic
now this setup that i have here is
called a site to site vpn and what it
means is since there is a standard route
set up here anything on this network is
going to be go is going to be able to go
over here to this network and anything
on this network is going to route over
to this network as if they were in the
same building it's just a standard route
inside that encrypted tunnel now the
other type of vpn is going to be just an
end user connecting to an office and if
if you're a remote worker or you're like
a road warrior you're going to use this
a lot your computer is going to
establish the same type of tunnel to
block all of the internal
network traffic from the internet itself
once it sets up that tunnel then just
your computer is going to be connected
to this internal network okay so you're
actually going to as if you plugged into
an ethernet port in the wall next to all
of your other employees or your other
fellow workers who happen to be in the
headquarters so what this does is it
puts your computer inside this local
network by establishing a tunnel and
then setting up routing protocols that
will put you inside there so it's a
little bit different than a site to site
because these computers are probably not
going to like serve data from your
computer it's going to work a little bit
differently but conceptually the same
thing is happening your remote computer
is now able to connect to computers
inside the remote network and it's all
protected from the internet by using a
vpn now i talked about different
protocols to do that and there are a
bunch there's openvpn which is an open
source program that allows you to
establish these types of connections uh
there's ssh which can establish a tunnel
for you to do stuff there's l2
tp there's ipsec there's all these
different protocols and programs that
will allow these tunnels to be created
and a vast majority of these will
actually run on a linux server inside
the network so if your router itself
doesn't support vpn that's okay you can
port forward into a linux server and the
linux server will handle all of the vpn
routing now there are lots of nuances
when it comes to vpn like can you only
connect through the remote business can
you connect to the internet and also to
those things is all of your traffic
routed through the vpn even if it's a
slow link so there's a lot to think
about when setting up vpns but once you
understand what's going on it's a lot
easier to plan how you're going to
implement it so that it so that it can
best serve your users or your multiple
branch offices so they can communicate
to each other i hope this has been
informative for you and i'd like to
thank you for viewing containers aren't
really new technology they've been
around for quite a while there have been
options like lxc and you've probably
heard of docker and also kubernetes
comes into the mix which is actually
like an orchestration tool that takes
care of docker but while containers
aren't new they are kind of the new kid
on the block when it comes to devops and
containerizing applications is something
that's really really popular now
conceptually they're a little bit like a
virtual machine but they're they're
different enough that it's important to
understand the difference so let's say
we have a traditional virtual machine
which i'm going to say is the left hand
side of this slide so how it works is
you have the the big computer you know
and then that computer or that host has
its own operating system and then on top
of that we carve out a section of the
host's cpu and memory and and cards and
hard drive space we carve that out and
then on top of that we install another
operating system inside this virtualized
environment and then we can put
applications on that now containers work
in a different way they run right inside
the host operating system so you just
have an app
running in another app running and
another app running and this seems like
the traditional server model right where
you just install linux and then you
install applications like apache on top
of it the difference is with a
containerized application they are
running directly on the host computer
but they have
not really their own operating system
all they have is like their own file
system
and they're jailed off or they're
completely separate from the file system
of the host operating system itself so
they run in their own little world
but they're still running directly on
the operating system it's just like
they're sectioned off in a little
container
but they're still running on the host
operating system and that's really what
makes them efficient you'll notice over
here um yeah it's drawing it's not like
the actual technology but it takes up a
lot more hardware and storage and slices
of the host system itself if you're
going to install an entire operating
system on top of virtualized hardware it
just you're not you can't put as many
things on one host operating system plus
you also have then this operating system
to maintain along with this operating
system these don't have their own
operating system so you don't need to
maintain anything except the application
itself and it works really cool that
jail system is neat so i want to show
you how that works and let's go actually
over to a virtualized environment so
here i am in i'm running ubuntu and i
have docker installed so we're not going
to get into how docker works there's a
whole course on how docker works that i
taught which is one of my favorite
courses but first of all we're just
going to start a docker container and
we're going to put ourselves inside of
it so this is just a little bit of free
info we're going to say
docker run dash
it for interactive tty let's say we're
going to run the ubuntu image and i want
to run bin
bash which is the shell command that i
want to run so now boom it it was that
fast right it created the container that
quickly and i didn't like pause the
video and wait for it it actually went
that quickly and now we're inside this
container which acts like its own
operating system because remember it's
jailed off but it's still running on the
system and we can demonstrate that see
i'm not i'm no longer on cbt docker now
i'm on this internal container and we
have our own file system but let's run a
command in here we're going to run
something that'll show up with cpu usage
so i'm just going to say
dd
input file equals dev 0 i'll put file
equals
dev no and this is just something that's
going to keep running keep running keep
running and not really do anything
except use up resources on the computer
and i want to do that so we can come
over to cbt docker here run the top
command and even though this is now in
its own container completely separate
from cbt docker the operating system you
can see look dd shows up as another
command running inside this computer
because even though it's separated in a
container it's still using the same
operating system the same kernel the
same hardware that everything else along
this system is it's just separated so it
doesn't interfere and dependencies won't
interfere with other apps it won't
interfere with dependencies on the host
system it's just super efficient so
whether you're looking at lxc containers
or docker containers which is what we
looked at it's important to understand
that containers are a lot like a virtual
machine except they don't use all of
that hardware and they don't completely
section themselves off and most
importantly they don't have their own
operating system that's where containers
make things much more efficient and much
easier to deal with with much less
overhead meaning you don't have to
maintain the operating systems of
individual apps
it's really easy to confuse the concepts
of clustering and load balancing because
they kind of are the same it's kind of
like the question is a hot dog a
sandwich i mean they're both meat
between bread but are they the same
thing
not exactly not quite but they both
function similarly and that's what
clustering and load balancing is like
the difference is though clustering is
an actual computer term for computers
working together to do one task that can
be split up whereas load balancing is
more of an i.t concept that can be
accomplished in the multiple ways so
when we have a cluster basically we have
a bunch of computers like we have here
that are working together and then
there's like a cluster manager it can be
a computer it can be a software on you
know one of the cluster computers but it
actually keeps track of which computer
in the cluster is doing what part of the
task and these are designed to work
together they know about each other
these computers are a team and they
really do well if susie here
sends them a task that is designed to be
broken up into multiple pieces so people
can work on it at the same time so some
jobs lend themselves to clustering
solutions whereas some of them don't but
basically they know about each other the
cluster works together as a team to
break down a bigger task into a bunch of
smaller ones they can work on at the
same time a load balancer like i said is
more of a concept it load balances
meaning it it has a big job and it
splits that job up and lets different
computers do the job but usually these
computers don't know or care about each
other at all they don't know each other
exist the load balancer itself whether
it's software or a hardware device it
knows
the entire big load that susie is
sending to it and it splits it up and
says okay she has 12 jobs so you do
three jobs and you do three jobs and you
do three jobs they don't know each other
are doing jobs as far as the computers
know there's only three jobs to do it's
the load balancers job to keep track of
everything so it's a little bit
different they don't really work
together they each work separately
and accomplish a bigger task that the
load balancer itself knows about now i
said it's a concept it can work multiple
ways right a very common way it's done
is the load balancer will be in front of
some web servers and there's a whole
bunch of people that want to hit that
web server and so the load balancer says
okay you go to this one and now you go
to this one and the next request will go
to this one and it splits up the load so
that one computer isn't doing all of the
work now we can do that very simply on a
linux machine if the linux machine is
set up for round robin dns now this is
not a great way to load balance just
conceptually this is what it's going to
do so here is my dns configuration on my
network i have the domain name web it's
actually set up for three different ip
addresses okay so you'll see it's
actually web web web but they have three
different ip addresses and what my dns
server is going to do is then round
robin and it will split up the load
between these three let me show you how
that works here we are on the command
line so i'm going to say ping web
and we'll see we get the response from
the web server notice the ip address
here is 216
58192.238. if we do the exact same thing
now
boom if we get responses but notice it
sent it to a different computer together
so we got these from another computer
and if we do it again we'll get still
that third one
if we do it a fourth time it's going to
wrap around and give us the first one
again so this is technically a load
balancer we're using dns round robin
load balancing and it's conceptually
splitting up the load of the pings so
that each computer that is responding
only gets a third of the requests so i
guess it's fair to say that all
clustering is load balancing but not all
load balancing is technically clustering
because clustering is a specific way
that computers work together to
accomplish a task now is a hot dog a
sandwich i gotta leave that one up to
you i have no idea but i hope this has
been informative for you and i'd like to
thank you for viewing cron jobs are
pretty much the linux equivalent to like
the task scheduler in windows now
there's some really cool things that we
need to understand and that's how to set
up the scheduling which is kind of
complicated but also very powerful and
i'll be honest it's kind of fun the
other thing i want to point out though
is that there are pre-made folders that
you can just drop scripts in and they
will execute at a regular interval i'll
show you those but first let's talk
about how we set up the schedules
because it can be intimidating but like
i said it's not that bad and it's
actually kind of fun so the scheduling
fields which we'll look at in practice
are separated into five different fields
so we have minute hour day of the month
month of the year and day of the week
and how it works is for example this
first line that i have has all asterisks
and this means everything so every
minute of every hour of every day of the
month of every month of the year of
every day of the week it's going to
happen so this means every minute for
all of eternity whatever task we
schedule with this string is going to
execute so every minute it's going to do
whatever you tell it to do
now there are some shortcuts we can use
for example down here i have asterisk
divided by five this means every five
minutes now we could actually spell it
out we could say zero comma five comma
ten comma fifteen all the way to
fifty-five but i don't really like to do
that because it's a big mess and you
know one field would be this entire big
string of numbers so rather than do that
we can just say asterisk divided by five
and this is going to be every five
minutes
during the third hour of the day so this
means at 3 am 305 am 3 10 am 3 15 am but
once it gets to 4 am it's going to stop
doing it okay so this is during the
third hour every 5 minutes every day of
the month every month year every day of
the week so this means every day it's
going to do this but only between 3 a.m
and 3 59 a.m and every five minutes okay
now this one is very very very specific
this says two minutes after the fourth
hour so two and four means at 402 a.m on
the 13th
of july but only when that 13th of july
lands on a tuesday the day of the week
goes from zero to six so two is a
tuesday right sunday is zero monday is
one tuesday is two so this means every
july 13th at 402 am if it happens to
also be tuesday so this is only going to
execute every few years when july 13th
happens to land on a tuesday and then
down here this one zero minutes after
the hour so this means that six a.m
precisely on
every day of the month every month of
the year
days one through five so this means
monday through friday at six a.m it's
going to execute whatever task okay so
this is basically the way of saying six
a.m every weekday because we've
specified one through five on the days
of the week over here pretty cool right
let's actually see how it works in
practice now i'm on a centos system here
and i'm root because we're talking about
the system wide cron jobs if we go into
etcon
dot d we're going to see we have a few
files in here now any file in here is
going to be read by the cron daemon so
let's actually look at one let's look at
systat all right because this is already
in there so we're going to look at
systat and here we can see a couple
things are scheduled here are the five
fields that we just talked about so
here's the first field so every 10
minutes of every hour
every day every month year every day of
the week so this is going to be every 10
minutes it's going to execute
as root so this field talks about what
user it's going to run as and then the
rest of it is what it's going to
actually do so we have the five
scheduling fields who it runs as and
then the last part however long it is is
what it's going to execute so down here
these are commented out but let's
pretend it's not this would be every
hour at zero past right because this is
like at one o'clock two o'clock three
o'clock four o'clock it's going to run
as root this command down here at 23
which is 11 so 11 53 p.m
every day see all these are asterisk so
every day as root it's going to execute
this so you can either add to any of
these or really the best thing to do is
create your own right just create a file
and then put that scheduling the
username and what you want it to execute
and it will do that now the one other
thing i wanted to mention really quick
if you go back into
the etc folder and let's do an ls and
just
look for
cron we're going to see there are a
bunch of folders in here there are cron
daily cron hourly cron monthly cron
weekly and if we go in there let's go
into cron dot
daily
we're going to see these are just
executable scripts these are not timed
things right let's look at one real
quick so vi log rotate notice there's no
like startup star star star star star
star there's no scheduling in here this
is just an executable script that we
want to have
execute every
day so this is going to do the
scheduling of everything in here once a
day same with monthly same with hourly
the kran deny is a way that we can tell
a specific user that they're not allowed
to use the cron daemon for personal use
uh cron.d we looked at actually cron tab
is a single file let's look at that one
really quick that'll be our last thing
etc
tab and this is the same sort of thing
we can put things in here if we want it
even tells us like very specifically all
the things the five fields the username
we want it to run as and then the
command to be executed this is the same
thing as creating a file in the
eccentric cron.d folder you can just add
things here and they'll automatically
execute now the pre-made folders are
very convenient for dropping scripts in
that you want to have execute every so
often but really the coolest part about
cron is just how flexible that
scheduling system is and you can figure
out how to do that by you know
manipulating all of those different
fields like we looked at in this slide
here so i encourage you to just try to
figure out how you would specify a
particular time and you know just play
with it it's a lot of fun to do
when it comes to scheduling events you
have a couple options as a personal end
user on a linux account you can use
crontab personal crontab which you
invoke by typing crontab minus e or we
can use the at daemon which is a one
time thing it's not like for recurring
events it's for events that happen
just at a specific time so let's go
right to the command line because it's
not difficult to use either one and
scheduling tasks is something that's
really really nice to be able to do so
here we are on a centos machine i'm
logged in just as a user notice i'm not
root and the first thing i want to do is
look at my personal cron tab now this is
a little bit different than a system
wide crontab so first we type
cron tab minus e and it's going to bring
us into an editor okay and now this is
my personal crown tab again it's not
system wide and it's slightly different
because i still have five fields if
you're not familiar with the five fields
look at the system-wide crontab nugget
because it'll explain how this works but
we have every 10 minutes of every hour
of every day of every month of the year
every day of the week so here we have
every 10 minutes it's going to do
something now notice there's no field
here that specifies the user in the
system wide we have to specify what user
it runs as but since this is my personal
crontab it obviously runs as me so we
just have the five fields and then we
have the command that we want to have it
execute at the time scheduled here so
what this what happens here is we have
echo and this text string and append it
to a file called homebob timetracker.log
every 10 minutes so every 10 minutes it
should add a line to our field so let's
see if this is actually running because
it's been here a while
let's quit here if we do ls we can see
oh there is a file time tracker.log and
if we look at it well sure enough it
looks like about a half hour has gone by
since i created that crontab entry and
it's been adding to this file if we do
ls minus l we can see the last time that
was touched was at 18 10. so if we
waited around until 1820 it would do the
same thing again it would add another
line to it so that's how you do a
recurring event using a personal crontab
now if you just have something you want
to have execute one time let's clear the
screen we can use the at daemon and
first i'm going to do something really
quickly so we'll say at and then can
specify the time and this is what's nice
it's very flexible we could say tomorrow
we could say
next week and it will interpret all of
those different commands it uses a lot
of fuzzy logic to figure out what you
want i'm going to say at now plus one
minute and then we're gonna get this at
prompt which now allows us to execute
something so i wanted to do echo
this was a one-off and i want to append
that to home
bob time tracker dot log press enter and
now we could do another thing we could
have like a whole list of things we
wanted to do at now plus one minute but
i'm just going to do control d
and that will put it in queue so it says
job4 is in queue and it's going to
execute at 18 13. okay now if we type
atq
oh it already happened dog on it
first of all let's look cat time tracker
look at that it did it right it put it
to the end of the file but i need to do
another one so at now plus one minute
again and i'm gonna say echo hello
into
home bob time tracker dot
control d
atq ah there we go okay did it in time
so what this shows us is the queue of
things that at is going to run so job
number five is scheduled for thursday
june 20th at 1814 and the user bob is
who's doing it so if we keep pressing at
q
once the time rolls around it's going to
execute that and then go away because
it's a one-off right we could do
multiple things we could say at tomorrow
then i want to say
echo
test tomorrow i spelled it wrong but
that's okay
on home bob time tracker.log control d
on a blank line now if we do at q we're
going to see well look job 5 executed
but job six is going to wait until
tomorrow and it does it the same time
tomorrow so 24 hours from now and
tomorrow at 18 14 it's going to do that
command test tomorrow okay now let's say
we don't want to do that we want to
change our mind well then we can say at
rm job six and now at q is going to say
there's no jobs because we've deleted
job number six that was going to execute
tomorrow but if we look at time tracker
look at that sure enough hello was put
there along with that this is the one
off and if we wait around until the next
10 minutes pass our cron job is going to
add another 10 minutes has passed on to
the end of this file and that's how we
can schedule things with crontab for a
repeating task like these or just a
one-off task like this by using the at
daemon it's great to be able to do
system-wide things using cron but i
personally like the fact that you can do
it as a personal end user using cron tab
minus e and it's going to do it just as
your user so you don't have to become
root or worry about escalating
privileges it's going to just execute it
as you even if you're logged out same
with the at daemon even if we're not
logged in it's still going to execute it
at the given time
working with multiple processes on linux
is really really easy because you can
put them in the foreground or the
background and interact with them
however you want now there are some
tools that may not seem intuitive at
first but once you get the hang of using
them they're really really easy and
there's also some keystrokes that we're
going to have to learn and a couple
tricks that will allow us to do things
that we normally couldn't do so let's go
right to the command line because this
is the kind of stuff you have to
experience in order to really understand
so first of all i am on the command line
and i'm going to show you how to put a
process in the background now i'm just
going to use a simple process called
sleep the sleep command if you're not
familiar with it it just pauses right so
if we say sleep one it's gonna sleep for
one second and then it's gonna be done
so i'm gonna say sleep for a whole bunch
of seconds which will like i don't know
that's probably a couple hours or
something and then i'm going to put the
ampersand after it
now what's going to happen is notice
it's done a number one and then this is
the actual process number so our job
number is one now we can do that with
another one sleep two two two two two
put that in the background and now we're
gonna see we have job number two in the
background with this process id and
they're just running in the background
if we type jobs we can see sure enough
there they are there's sleep one one one
there's sleep two two two job one and
job two now if we want to start going
and using one again like let's say we
wanna bring one in the foreground we
just type f g and then the job number so
fg two and it's going to bring us it
tells us what the command is that's
running and here we are we're just at
the command line here if we wanted to
stop this we'd have to do control c it
stopped that process and now if we do
jobs see there's only the one job
running it's actually really cool now
what if we did a job like we did
sleep 33333 and press enter and i'm like
oh man i really wish that was in the
background i didn't mean for it to just
like hold my command prompt here well
what we can do is do control z
and it stops it and puts it in the
background so see it says stop if we
type jobs we can see this first one that
we did is still running but this one is
stopped so if we want to make it run in
the background we have to say
b g for run in the background job number
two
and now if we do jobs we're gonna see
now they're both running in the
background so bg and then the job number
will start that background task running
fg will bring it out of the background
and bring it right to our interactive
terminal okay so that's kind of neat
it's a way we can create them we can put
them in the background if we've started
them and we don't and we want to put
them in the background just ctrl z will
suspend it briefly and then we can tell
it to go in the background by doing bg
and then the job
number so let's do foreground one i'm
going to do control c
foreground two control c and now jobs we
have no more jobs running now there is a
problem because if we have a job running
in the background like i have a command
here called my hello all right and all
it does is every two seconds it prints
hello on the screen
all right so i'm gonna control c what if
i wanted to put my hello
in the background and it's going to run
in the background i was still going to
put it out on the screen every hello but
it's running in the background if we do
exit it's still running in the
background but the problem comes where
if we log out
and then we log back in
we open a terminal window
and we do a ps aux grip for my hello
we're gonna see it's no longer running
this is just actually the grep process
that it actually found here but notice
it's not running in the background
anymore and if we wanted it to stay
running just putting it in the
background wouldn't work we'd have to
use a program called no hup because
here's the problem when we log out of
the system up here it actually sends a
hang up interrupt to all the running
processes and the hang up or hup
tells it to stop running well we can run
a program by saying no hup which means
don't hang up when the user logs out
what program we want to run so my hello
and then ampersand in the background
it's going to put it in the background
just like before we can see it jobs
there it is running but it says it's
ignoring the input and appending the
output to nohup dot out alright so i'm
going to exit i'm going to log out and
then i'm going to log back in
open up a terminal window
i want to notice two things one if we do
a ps minus aux grip for my hello it's
still going to be running see here it is
it's still running because we ran it
with no hup but here's another cool
thing if we do an ls see this nohup dot
out let's look at that
all of the output was put into that file
so all of the hellos were put into that
file so we know what's going on plus
when we logged out it didn't stop
running so not only is it really easy to
handle processes when you're on the
linux command line it's also possible to
do a couple cool things like no hup if
you want to make sure it doesn't quit
when you log out and also control z
of a running process which will put in
the background suspended and then you
can run bg to make sure that it
continues executing in the background
finding specific information about local
devices on your system can be a little
bit challenging but thankfully there's a
bunch of tools that will help us along
the way d message is one that we can use
that will kind of see how things are
going in real time if you plug something
in d message is going to show you the
results of plugging that in but then
there's a whole suite of ls tools if you
will they start with ls it's ls usb
lspci lsdev msblk ls cpu all of these
tools are going to be able to be used to
find out information about hardware on
our system and there's a nice trick to
remember these so that you don't have to
actually remember pci dev blk cpu all of
these different things so let's check
that out and see if we can find the
various hardware that is in our system
you have to be root to use most of these
some of these you can use as an end user
but since we're going to be looking at
all of them i became root just so that
we get a better view of what's going on
now first of all d message you just type
d message on the command line and it's
going to show you things as they happen
and this is the location that we'll see
things happen if we make changes to the
system like if we plug in a usb drive or
plug in a sata drive or something like
that a new mouse it's going to show up
here and it's going to give us
information about the particular device
but if something's already plugged in or
you just want to see like what's built
into the system that's where the ls
tools come into play so let's clear the
screen
and what i like to do is just do ls and
then hit tab a couple times and that's
the trick because really tab completion
is vital here there are so many of these
commands now we know ls just means list
like the file directory but they've used
this same tool or the same keystrokes to
prefix a bunch of commands like ls blk
for example which will show us the block
devices it will list the block devices
on our system if we do that it's going
to show us all the block devices that we
have like the floppy drive all of these
are virtual loopback devices that were
created down here these are our actual
drives on our system sda we can see
right here it's mounted on forward slash
sda1 is then we have a bunch of other
drives down here that aren't being used
right now but they're all 10 gigabytes
in size we used those and we set up raid
before but this shows us all of the
block devices so if we do ls and hit tab
a couple times again let's look at the
next one we have ls block we have ls cpu
now i actually really like this one
because it will give you all of the
information about the cpu in the system
so we can here we can see here that it's
a 64-bit processor little endian it's an
intel
it actually shows us the actual
processor itself the model number it
shows us the clock speed all sorts of
stuff that we have vtx enabled so we can
do virtualization and it shows us all of
the awesome things that our cpu has
including all the flags that it supports
when we're compiling things anyway
that's ls cpu if we hit ls and tab a
couple times again i'm going to do this
every time because it's the quickest way
to see what's there we have lsdev i want
to do this you have to be root to do
this and what this shows us this might
not be as useful as it was years and
years ago and we would have to
troubleshoot hardware more frequently
but what this is going to show us is the
the device like what device it is like
our floppy disk our keyboard a pci port
here and it's going to show us what
direct memory access number it uses what
dma what irq number it's using uh the io
ports meaning like in memory what io
parts of memory or what parts of memory
is it using for i o and it will show us
all these things now if we're trying to
find conflicts on our system this might
be useful but i'll be honest i've never
once had to use this in practice it's
important to know that it's there though
ls dev will show you all the devices on
the system now if you do ls tab tab
one that i actually do use fairly often
is
lspci where is that up here lspci so oh
pci will show us all the pci devices so
here we have a vga compatible controller
this is the acpi controller the ide
controller
so these are the pci devices that are
plugged into our system uh we can do ls
usb now i don't have anything plugged
into our usb ports but if we did ls usb
would would show us what's there same
thing ls
pcmcia if you're a laptop user you might
have things that show up if you type
that and one last one we'll look at is
ls mem and this will just give us the
range of the memory and how it's being
used and where it is in our system but
really the big big pull away from this
is ls tab tab and it'll show you all of
the different ways that you can look at
the devices on your system so whether
you're trying to get an inventory of the
things that are currently on your system
or you want to see changes as they
happen in real time there's some really
simple built-in tools on our local linux
machine for detecting and looking at
specifics on devices
you ever try to solve a problem only to
make it worse yeah me too for example
we had a wall with a nail in the wall
and that nail would get loose after
hanging stuff on the nail for a long
time because it was just in the thin
layer of drywall this nail just went in
the drywall and then the more we hung
stuff on it the more it got loose so i
thought i would make things better by
getting rid of the nail drilling a hole
in the drywall and then getting one of
those really nice hollow wall anchors
that you could then put a nail or a
screw into and it would be really nice
and sturdy the problem is i drilled the
hole way too big the hollow wall anchor
didn't work at all and then i just had
this gigantic hole in the wall that my
wife was really upset about that's kind
of what happened in the world of linux
virtual file systems and let me tell you
what i'm talking about here because the
idea of virtual file systems has been
around since the unix days basically
it's a file system that's created when
the system boots up and one of the
really popular ones is called proc and
what this was used for is process
information like of running apps and
running programs on the system they
would store all of their runtime
information in this virtual folder in
memory called proc and then people said
hey that's a really neat place to store
things like process id number 181 for
that application and 2 5 5 6 for that
application what if we also put things
about like the cpu in there or the
network card in there and then people
started adding things to the proc folder
it started to get a little bit confusing
and so we thought hey wouldn't it be a
great idea if we separated all of that
kernel information so that process
information was stored in the proc
folder and kernel information was stored
in assist folder they're both virtual
file systems that work the same way but
some organizations seem to make a lot of
sense right now the same thing with dev
dev is a folder that we thought why
don't we start putting things like
information on different devices like
hard drives or mouses mice mouse mice
mouses anyway when we put those things
into the dev folder
oh here's the issue the proc folder had
been around for a long time and it
already had a mix of things in it so we
said okay we'll keep all of those things
and then we'll just put new things in
the sys folder the problem is there's
not that many new things so while the
sys folder is very well maintained and
very neat and organized it doesn't
contain a lot of the things that we use
on a daily basis because they were
already in the proc file system and now
they're there for backwards
compatibility
now that doesn't mean proc and sys are
any less useful if we go into the proc
folder and do an ls we're going to see
here are all of those numbers these are
the process ids that i talked about
right and if we do like an ls of oh the
process id 47 inside here it's going to
be all of the various things that this
particular application is doing like
it's it's memory io what's mounted uh
the status all of the things about this
running thing are in here so if you want
to find out information about whatever
process id number 47 is you can look at
these various things but notice over
here on the right hand side there's also
a bunch of things that aren't process
ids and that's where like mdstad meminfo
cpu info let's look at that so if we
look at cpu info this is going to just
be a complete breakdown of the cpu in
the system right now that's running this
is our current cpu which is really
useful information but it might make
more sense if it was over here in the
sys folder because the sys folder is
very well laid out right there's not a
whole bunch of crud here this is laid
out in very nice sections we could go
into oh let's say the kernel folder and
inside the kernel folder it's separated
into various things about the kernel
like the current configuration
all of these things are nice and
organized but it's not all inclusive
meaning it doesn't contain a lot of the
information if we scroll up that's still
stored in the proc folder so here's how
it ends up working a lot of the
interactive stuff is going to be in the
proc folder because it's always been
there but a lot of the information about
the running kernel is very organized
well in the sys folder and that's where
a lot of times programs will look if
they want information about the current
running kernel like do i work on this
program well i don't know let's see you
know information about hypervisor and
kernel modules and all of those things
it'll look in the cis folder so
generally you'll find yourself in the
proc folder more often all right now one
other place that is worth looking in is
the dev folder and this just shows about
system devices right these are hardware
devices that are plugged into the system
either like soldered in like the
real-time clock or hardware like hard
drives that we put in here and this is
going to be information binary
information generally available to the
system talking about the various bits of
hardware that are plugged in now this is
fairly well organized too and a lot of
times programs will look here to find
out information like hey is there
hardware that is going to be compatible
with my software well this is where it
would look for hardware information so
while it sounds like it's a big mess
honestly it's not that bad there's three
main places to look the proc folder
which is what we see here the sys folder
which we see here and then the dev
folder which we see here all of them
contain different information sys and
proc have a little bit of crossover
there's going to be some kernel
information insist that's already living
in the proc file system but if you're
going to be interacting it's mostly
going to be in the proc file system and
applications are going to be hitting the
sys file system pretty hard now i know
that's a lot of information about linux
virtual file systems the key takeaways
are that we need to know information
about the running kernel are going to be
in generally one of three places in the
virtual file system that happens when
the computer boots up the proc file
system the sys file system and the dev
file system if you can look in all three
of those places you're going to find
what you're looking for but they might
be spread out in places that don't make
a whole lot of sense just because we
keep things there for backwards
compatibility i hope this has been
informative for you and i'd like to
thank you for viewing on a linux system
the printing is going to be handled by
cups which is common unix printing
system which interestingly is actually
owned by apple of all people but
nonetheless this is what every modern
linux distribution is going to use to
handle the printing now the nice thing
is there are some backwards
compatibility command line tools so we
can print things from the command line
and if you don't have a gui to actually
install the printer like if you don't
have gnome or kde or anything like that
installed you can use a really nice web
interface that will allow you to
interact with the cup system and install
modify and do all the things you need to
do to a printer but we're going to look
at the web interface really quickly just
to show you where it is and i want to
show you how to use the command line
tools so you can print from a command
line system even if it's a headless
system on a rack now i'm logged in here
on my local ubuntu computer on my local
network and you'll see up here i went to
localhost port 631
now that's important because cups
listens for incoming connections on port
631 and if you go there it'll allow you
to log in so you can do things like
administration for example we are here
and i have one printer installed we can
click on it'll give us information about
this particular printer called office
underscore laser we can see it's a
socket-based connection on this ip
address on port 9100 and basically it's
installed on the computer i actually
installed it using the web interface
instead of going into the gui on this
computer and installing it with the
ubuntu tools i used the web-based
interface to make sure that it would be
able to install correctly and it did
once we're here we can actually do
things you know from firefox like print
the page but if we're on the command
line things are a little bit different
there are a couple tools that start with
l p and if we hit lp and then hit tab a
couple times for tab autocomplete we're
going to see some of those here now
they're not all things we're going to
look at right now but mainly lpr
is going to send commands to the printer
lpq is going to show us the queue of
things waiting to be printed so if we
type lpq we're going to see office laser
is our default printer it says it's
ready but there are no entries meaning
there's nothing that's currently being
printed now we can use lpr to print
things in a couple different ways we
could actually just say echo this
is a test and we can pipe that into the
lpr command and if we look over here on
my printer it's going to print this page
right out
and we can see sure enough it says this
is a test so it'll do text just like
that now we don't have to do line by
line we can also do something like in my
folder here i have a full file called my
document so if we look at my document
you can see it's just a string of text
things and we can say
lpr and then the name of the text file
my document we'll print that and as it
prints out on the page if we look at lpq
we're going to see we have a job right
here job number 10 is that we could use
lprm if we're quick enough and get rid
of job10 oh it's already completed but
that is how we would delete a job that
we had already sent so if there's a
whole bunch of things queued up and
something's wrong we can use lprm in
order to fix it and if we come back over
here we're going to see sure enough it
printed out that entire file for us
right there on the page so it's really
easy to print using the command line
once it's set up with cups and
thankfully cups is really easy to set up
too because it's all web-based and that
web interface honestly is very powerful
we can use it to queue up jobs to stop
jobs do test pages we can use cups for
gui environment printing but the most
important thing to realize is that we
have access to the cup system by using
the command line tools that are
installed on our system
udev is the userspace device manager
that has replaced dev fs and older linux
systems now what's really cool is it
uses sysfs which is a virtual file
system that has information about the
hardware and then it follows rules in
order to keep devices with consistent
names now what i mean by that is if
you've ever had a linux system with
multiple anything but we'll say hard
drives the order that you used to put
them in the system depended on the name
they would get so the first one the
system recognized would be sda then sdb
and then sdc but on the next boot if
they came up in like a different order
while all of a sudden this one might be
sda and this one would be sdb and this
one might still be sdc and those are
real pain in the butt so what udev does
is it creates devices based on specifics
with the hardware so it'll take its like
uuid and it will create a solid
consistent device that that's always
going to be so if you put them in a
different order or the buses come alive
in a different order on boot they're
still going to be the same devices which
makes things a lot simpler when it comes
to mounting drives and things like that
now it also allows us to do some other
things like create rules so first of all
i want to show you some of the things
you can do if you're root you have more
access to do this so we're going to say
u dev adm this is the administrator
command that allows us to do some things
with the udev system so the first thing
i want to do is say udev info
let's actually look at dev
sr0 which is actually our dvd drive and
it gives us all sorts of information
specific to this drive so we'll see a
couple things like let's scroll up we
see this is n means the name so this is
the name that it has assigned it this is
the place in the pci device where it
exists this is all the specific
information about it and if we look
lsdev
grep sr0 we're going to see sure enough
it's right in the dev folder sr0 it's
dynamically created when it detects it
and puts it in now sr0 is not terribly
useful at least for me to recognize a
hard drive or a dvd drive when it's in
the system i can see it mounted right
here but that doesn't help me sr0
doesn't mean dvd to me so we could do
something like make a rule that creates
a shortcut to it every time it
recognizes it in the system so we're
going to go into the etc udev rules.d
folder and in here let's see what there
is there's one called snap core rules
but i'm going to create a new one i'm
going to say vi
we'll say number 10 so it loads it first
sean dot
rules sean rules nice anyway it has to
end in dot rules and then we're going to
create our own rule now the format here
is something that you just kind of have
to get the hang of but the kernel is
equal to
sr0 meaning this is what the kernel
knows the device as
it's in the
sub system
is equal to
block which it actually showed us when
we did that command and then what i want
to do is create a sim link and i want to
call that sim link my underscore dvd
okay so what we've done is created this
rule anytime it has a device called sr0
in the block subsystem meaning like a
block device like a hard drive or a
cd-rom i wanted to create a sim link
called my dvd in the dev folder so i can
reference it there instead of
remembering sr0 so let's save this
now we could reboot the computer or we
could just do udev adm
trigger
okay and now if we go into the dev
folder
and we do an ls
we should see in here
look at that my dvd it's created that
sim link to well in fact let's do ls
minus l grab dvd
my dvd is a link to sr0 it looks like
there already was a dvd shortcut to sr0
but we created a new one by making our
own udev rule called my dvd and that's
pointing to sr0 and we can use this when
we're referencing the device in anything
that we want like mounting and that sort
of a thing and the cool part is this
isn't just a sim link sitting on our
system this is something that's going to
be created every time the dvd is
recognized
and set up by the system so on boot even
though the dev file system is a virtual
file system it's always going to have
that sim link my dvd pointing to sr0 now
we just graze the surface of the things
we can do with udev rules we can
actually make things happen when certain
usb drives are plugged in that sort of a
thing but one of the key things i want
you to take away is that it's really
smart and it uses sysfs in order to know
information about the drivers and
everything else how it interacts with
the kernel it uses the information in
sysfs to create the entries in the dev
folder i hope this has been informative
for you and i'd like to thank you for
viewing
you